[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
do
this
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
welcome to ndc melbourne we are so glad
that you can make it even though we
can't meet up in person there was no way
that we would miss an ndc event that's
right william despite all the hurdles
and challenges in the last 18 months
we just had to put this event on so
thanks everyone for attending we have a
great lineup for you starting with scott
hanselman in just a few minutes and
thank you to all of our other speakers
as well remember you can use the youtube
chat to connect with other attendees and
speakers yes exactly the chat will also
let you win prizes and ask any questions
that you might have to the sponsors
partners and all the volunteers behind
the scenes thank you you rock we would
not be able to do this without you we
have an incredible program lined up for
you we've got news q a yoga and quizzes
so you can win some really awesome
prizes and speaking of prices make sure
you visit the official expo site at
expo.ndcmelban.com
with that enjoy the show and we'll see
you online throughout the day
i'm so sorry that's supposed to happen
on a zoom call welcome everybody i was
on mute and welcome to ntc melbourne
this is nothing like a zoom call though
isn't it um we are live here from
melbourne in australia and yes we are
three of us but you'll meet the other
two in just a minute um i'm last clint
and i am here with william and melissa
and we have a whole day planned with
tech events uh stuff so take content
take quizzes take prizes
well lots of tech things in general and
um
i think maybe we should first up though
go to a gentleman who probably doesn't
need an introduction to be honest
he's a purveyor of very fine thrift
stores he's a loved youtube creator he's
a former professor a current blogger and
podcaster and in his spare time he also
works as a principal program manager for
microsoft sort of getting the world
really excited about development content
so welcome scott
uh hanselman and thank you so much for
joining us this is quite the honor
is it though
yeah i don't know i had to say that i'm
sorry yeah
i thought it would i was going to do the
whole i'm on mute thing and then maybe
spice it up a little bit with like up
can you hear
me
but you can't do that because you're not
in australia because we are on
australian internet right so we can do
that gag i don't think you're allowed to
yeah i could pretend to be like
buffering
oh yeah yeah you could be you got to get
pixelated though yeah oh yeah i don't
know how to do that yet i'm working on
that i need a stretch for it to be
pixelated that's awesome welcome right
that's um fantastic to have you here and
you don't have to get up at 5am to do
this because it's your evening so that's
even better no i don't you know and i
even went out of my way to make my
lights match and then i ended up on the
right side of the screen where the
purple is so
i mean all that all this all this
incredibly hard iot there it is now
yeah we have we have tricks
that's amazing look at that lower your
expectations people yeah absolutely
that's i went for the for the orange
pink the red thing um because it matches
my skin color i don't know
um
so what have you got in store for us
today let's go
i have a talk about uh mentorship
uh about the difference between
mentorship and sponsorship and then what
what what we and by we i'm putting you
in the we now i was gonna say aye but
now you're one of us uh what we can do
is people who are maybe a little farther
along in our career right i think that
there are a lot of exciting things
happening right now in software even
though we're in the middle of a panini
and it's very stressful to everyone uh
there's early and career people there
are people who started this year people
we have interns that have never been to
microsoft that started this year they've
never met a person they've just been
they went from their bed to now they
work at microsoft
and uh we want to encourage them we want
to move from mentorship into sponsorship
we'll talk about what sponsorship it and
then what we what we can do as the
elders to encourage them with our
stories and with the technology
information that we have so as i head on
the way out to retirement and i don't
know learn to golf or something uh they
will be heading back in and how we can
lift them up and lend our uh lend our
privilege
that's awesome yeah this is um i've been
doing professional mentoring as well for
for quite a while actually and i love it
professional mentoring as opposed to the
management mentoring that i've been
doing that's right as in i've charged
people money for it and they paid i
don't know why but they did i have never
got to that level i have got to the
point where someone bought me lunch once
that's the level i'll take a mentorship
that i have it taco based mentoring oh
tacos yeah now so it's it's really an
area i think it's super important um
like how do you know where you're going
if you don't have someone to guide you
uh but i'm not going to talk about that
because you are um i should just mention
before we start though that there is a
slido link
and we will share that in the chat as
well that you can ask questions to scott
about and there it is
and i will make sure that i
can you actually hear me when that's
happening i'm not sure i think oh we can
use that qr code again i'm going to go
to that qr code yeah right good
so throughout the talk i'm happy to uh
to vet through the questions and i'll
ask anything uh to scott i'll just
rudely interrupt him so feel free ask
your questions go for it and use this
to that point i want to make sure that
you're clear that the the audience is
clear that when we do live events like
this when ndc puts on a live event it's
really live
right it isn't that i recorded it and
then you have a list of what scott's
going to say and i recorded this last
week
i really did forget to go off mute that
was me i did all that yeah and i i made
the observation that you know we could
just watch a youtube
but that's no fun because we do live
events here at ndc so i want lars to
interrupt me he's gonna interrupt me and
he's gonna bring your questions to me
and it's gonna be awkward and you're
gonna be like why is that guy jumping on
the key on the keynote stage get him off
but but that's what you would get if you
were at ndc live uh at least down under
would be lars just running on stage
randomly and interrupting uh the invited
keynote speaker it's the first time i've
been asked to actually interrupt i
normally just do it just be yourself
really is what we're asking you to do
which i think is a challenge but enough
of me take it away the audience by the
way at large the audience says that
muted lars is the best lars i have heard
that many times for some reason yet i
still get to produce videos so i don't
know
all right all right let's go let's give
a talk my friends
all right someone in the comments said
that i really love tacos of late if if
by of late uh you mean in the last uh 30
years yes of late i have been super
interested in in tacos as a as a
potential meal
so every great
keynote starts with a slide in uh comic
sans because that's the way to go my
friends let's go ahead and have somebody
who's uh a part of the ndc melbourne
crowd drop the slideo link into the chat
because the folks
over on the youtube are asking for it
that'd be great we'll have the
questions for the speaker so starting
with comic sans i'm told that that is
unprofessional so i'm going to improve
that by putting in a fancy font a little
bit of drop shadow
michelle is offended by my my comic sans
so then i will add not only better fonts
but evocative stock photography
as well as my cash me so you can send me
money hi sophie
and also just be noted that i am not
only an old man but also a tick tock
influencer i'm huge on the talk
my friends um you know when you're
getting in started in tech people show
you uh pictures like this and they imply
that that is their space that's their
this is this is my office right that's
clearly what everyone's technical office
looks like right no no it doesn't this
is what an office looks like right
that's like a realistic view of what a
computer person's office looks like
cds that they've never used these are
like msdn cds and stuff like that but no
matter whether your office looks like
this
or whether your office looks like that
then
i want you to know whether you're early
in career or later in career
that we welcome you we welcome you to
the technical community we welcome you
whether you're old or young
and whether this is your first ndc
virtual or whether you are an ndc
long-timer and you love hanging out with
us here
at ndc but what i want to talk about is
community attitude community style what
we can do as a community in order to be
welcoming and what we can do as
engineers
who work with people who are early in
career to make sure that they are
successful in what they're doing okay i
want to show you this this uh
magazine this magazine was from march of
1984. march of 1984. look at this we
have a young woman on a computer
magazine it says enthusiast 99 that's
actually 1984 and they are using a ti
uh 99
and uh i said ti 89 now i'm confused but
it is in fact a magazine from march of
1994 we have a young woman who's
programming here she's got her bubble
gum and her pigtails and her dress and
that is and was how computing should be
so i hope that even though as we
struggle to diversify tech and that we
see challenges for people who are not
the majority that we are reminded that
this is the way it was supposed to be is
that everyone is supposed to be
programming and enjoying themselves
because you know we hear a lot about
like inclusions being asked to dance you
know
diversity is being invited to the party
these are all different quotes that
people use to talk about the difference
between diversity and inclusion but one
of the ones that i really like from
january daniel judy's blog
was that inclusion is being a member of
the party planning committee isn't that
great what a great idea that's a much
better way of saying inclusion right
inclusion is the opposite of exclusion
you see our cartoons the childhood
cartoons there that we grew up with you
notice how there's basically one of
everybody
oh you got like you got one chinese
person you got one black guy can't have
two because it's cartoons
that's called power rangers diversity
that is totally artificial that's when
you're doing pie charts and you're like
you know we need a slice here and a
slice there but inclusion is just making
sure that everyone is welcome is
included and is a part of the planning
committee not just being invited to the
party so what we can do as we are
inviting our new friends into tech
whether they are remote whether they are
differently abled whether they are
whatever that they feel welcome
back in the day back in the day not just
in the 80s and 70s but i'm talking about
five six seven hundred years ago
there was this thing called the
priesthood and this is where
priests would not let the plebs the
regular people
read where knowledge was hoarded the
priests knew how to read they would stay
up at the top of the castle in their
cloister and they would have that
knowledge available to them and they
would read to people but they didn't
want them to read and paper and things
like that were exclusive resources what
we don't want is for computers to be
like that
all this knowledge should be available
to everyone we shouldn't be hoarding any
knowledge keeping any knowledge secret
that's why we're on a live stream right
now and our friends at ndc are making
this stream available free on youtube
because that knowledge and allowing you
to have access to experts in the fields
is so exciting this was a a quote here
from 1974
1974 where they were already recognizing
this gentleman ted nelson in his
computer lab was noticing that
that the technology priesthood the
priests of tech were already putting
people down oh you know no no true
programmer
is a programmer unless you've written
your own linux kernel you know unless
you've written your own c c compiler can
you really call yourself a software
developer we don't want uh that kind of
an attitude in our environment right we
don't want to see gatekeepers
those gatekeepers are standing at the
gate they're standing in front of the
club and they've got the velvet rope
that they can open up and allow you in
and we don't want anyone to be
controlling that information flow for an
entire social system for technology
whether it be javascript or net or
python or whatever we want that
information to be available and what we
can do
is set up our new friends and our new
early and career folks for success we
can set them up for success and allow
them to be involved in technology and
that's a thing to remember to remind
ourselves of how did you get into tech
what was the thing that got you involved
and what keeps you in tech
and just because you've been in tech
three years or five years or ten it's
never too early to be sharing your
information a lot of early in tech folks
might say well what am i to say i'm just
a i'm just a junior developer and i
don't want to start a blog there's
nothing for me to talk about
no no your experience your
your journey into tech is important so
what i want folks to do no matter what
level they are is share their energy
put out the work put out the things that
you're excited about don't waste your
keystrokes i'll talk about that in a
second your experience is more
interesting to me than whether or not
you're an expert.net or expert at python
i don't want someone to say i'm not
going to do a c-sharp tutorial they've
all been done well i haven't seen the
one written by lars or david or michelle
or chattiest or sophie or meschino these
are the people whose experiences into
c-sharp is interesting to me oh well i
found it to be easy because of this or i
found this to be difficult or i like
video content i like textual context
put those experiences out into the world
keep your blogs running blogging is
dying and it's not my blog i'm not the
one causing blogging to die you all need
to be blogging more put that information
out and then that energy will come back
to you i like to joke that if you
blog occasionally uh for a number of
years like me uh for the last 20 years
you too will be a mid-level computer
person that people have
maybe heard of once or twice
it's lars he's letting him engage he's
interfering with everything get off this
page yes i wanted to uh say we've broken
the ice of the question pool so now the
floodgates are open i believe but it's
actually a good question is isaac's
asking at what point in your career did
you realize that your strongest skill
as a mentor is your storytelling i
thought that was pretty a pretty good
question actually that is a lovely
question i will actually defer that a
little bit because i'm going to get to a
section about storytelling but i would i
would offer this answer and this short
answer before i get to that is
there are people who will find that
their gift is that they're the best at
what one thing
i'm the dot-net maui person i'm the
xamarin person i'm the python pie torch
person and then there are people who
will be swiss army knives
funny little knives that aren't good at
anything
um and then there will be people like
myself where i figured out a couple of
years ago that i'm a pretty average
programmer but i'm a pretty darn good
teacher so my job is to knock the doors
down to open the gates and say come on
everybody let's go the water's fine
everybody in the pool
and that's what i like to do so i would
say it took me a while to come to that i
am not a coder i'm a teacher if that
makes sense
coding enables you teaching basically it
does well i think i think of myself as a
professional enthusiast you know i
really like people who are enthusiastic
about their jobs right there's some
people who there's people who keep
knocking on my door and they say have
you heard the news
and i don't know what the news is but
i'm very excited that you're excited
about the news come on in let's talk
about the news i'm running around about
iot and raspberry pi's and open source
pancreases and c-sharp and f-sharp have
you heard the news about.net have you
heard the news about open source come on
how can you not be super excited about
this stuff
that's the best teachers in my opinion i
agree all right i'll go back again
you're star you're lovely thank you so
much all right so back to the slides my
friends so you share your energy which
is what i'm trying to do i'm trying to
get you excited about this stuff that
energy will come back to you but i made
a comment here in the middle i said
don't waste your keystrokes don't waste
your keystrokes
when i say conserve your keystrokes
that's really significant this is really
important
you have a finite number of keystrokes
left in your hands before you die
that's a really intense statement right
we've gone from this super high energy
talk to being like
uh
okay thanks for that bit of mortality
but let's say i'm just looking at the
flow of chat here let's say that
sophie emails me and she's like hey
scott great talk saw yet ndc you're
awesome here's a question
i mean i know sophie from the internet
like twitter but i'm not going to go and
give sophie 2 000 of my keystrokes for
free i'm not going to be like
tapity-tappy-tappity-tappy-tappy write a
whole long email and then she's like
thanks
okay what happened to those keystrokes
they were thrown out into the universe
but what can i do with them i can put
them
anywhere with a url
i can put them in a blog in a medium
post in a sharepoint in a word doc and a
google doc somewhere in a pamphlet in a
book i could do a youtube video when
someone emails you when an early and
career person emails you a question it
is a gift they have given you a gift of
an awesome question
wouldn't you rather give them a url to
the answer to that question
then to just type type type type burn a
half an hour and then it goes out there
the best part is that when i go to sleep
that email that i that that
that url that blog post that i put out
there works for me while i'm sleeping
see
so you might say well no one's going to
visit my blog maybe i'm only going to
have like two people visit my blog well
then if two people visit your blog you
just double the number of keystrokes you
have but most likely 10 100 200 people
are going to visit your blog
right and what that means is that that
is going to
multiply your power
like i said i'm a mid-level blogger you
know i'm kind of known but like i'm i
can't go i'm not getting recognized at
the grocery store but in the computer
world oh yeah someone's a pretty good
guy that's because i show up
consistently for the last 30 years and i
share my stuff as much as i can and i
think that we as a community should do
the same you're here right now you're in
the top one percent of programmers i
just made up that uh statistic because
you're here at ndc and you're watching
this talk if you have a blog even higher
if you're on social media you're sharing
your information if you volunteer at
your local school if you have a
mentorship relationship like lars is
talking to people and lifting them up
and lifting their voices you're in the
top
uh percentage of programmers because
you're not just coding you are sharing
the knowledge chad makes a comment in
the chat here where he says everyone's
blowing the cobwebs off their blog right
now
own your urls my friends own the url own
your own your words don't give facebook
your words don't give twitter your words
your words should start a domain that
you own that you control and then you
share them on social but where's myspace
it's gone where's geocities it's gone
all those websites are gone your
keystrokes belong in a place where you
control it you control it alright my
friends
so oh michelle makes another great point
if you raise your hand if you paid for a
url with the intention to blog and never
did anything i have 49 registered
domains so i've been there trust me
there's only one that matters it's my
name yes lauren
hello
yeah i just pop up from time to time
this is fantastic um so i had another
question and it was pertinent right to
what you were saying before and bronze
asking that the you know the number of
topics and everything is is not a
problem for blog articles lots of ideas
but the hardest part is the example code
and actually kind of making it usable
like a tutorial kind of thing any tips
for that um
well ultimately i would say back in the
day with snippets right you help people
with like five or ten snippets these
days a github repo or a gist is a really
great place to do that kind of stuff
i think it's fair to say that github's
not going to go anywhere
usually if it's a complicated thing i'll
zip it up and i'll have a release and
here's the sample like babysmash.com a
game for babies is a sample that i made
a number of years ago
i usually use github for long
complicated examples and i always make
it so i can go get clone and then you
type build
right and everything sucks if you go to
clone or github repo and it doesn't
build so then no probably all been there
so i recommend that i wouldn't get
overwhelmed i wouldn't get overwhelmed
to the point where you feel that you
need to have a complete sample
right sometimes just you know 20 or 30
lines of code is all people need keep in
mind that all of stack overflows
succeeded very well without fully
downloadable perfect samples therefore
your blog can too that's true very good
thanks good all right
now moving on to the next thing you
might say well i don't want to kick off
my blog i don't want to go and blow the
dust off my blog because i don't know
what i'm doing i'm an amateur
oh they're actually by the way they're
arguing now about gist versus gist
i've never heard anyone say gist tell me
the gist of your day no it just
and it's gif hard g just soft g but now
it's going to become a whole thing and
everyone's arguing now and they're going
to go off and talk about other things
we're all amateurs we're all amateurs
there are no professionals i went to
school 30 years ago my degree doesn't
mean anything anymore it just taught me
my degree taught me how to learn
my degree taught me how to absorb
information my degree taught me assembly
language and object pascal and and c and
other than c i'm not using any of those
things anymore so the argument that
there are everyone's a professional and
an expert
is uh is is those days are over i think
that sometimes people come around saying
you know i got i got 20 years experience
been doing this for 20 years doing this
for for 30 years well do you have 20
years experience or do you have the same
years experience
20 times
this is a really important thing this is
one of those like pause for effect type
like things that make you go hmm
[Music]
right do you have the same years
experience 20 times we have to be honest
with yourself i want you to think about
this and maybe post it in the chat
let's say you have five years experience
or 10 or 15.
do you feel good about all of those
years
i've been doing this for about 30 years
to be really honest with you here live
at ndc i would tell you that about seven
of them
i kind of slept through
i slept through those years meaning i
wasn't present i wasn't intentional i
wasn't in the moment i wasn't really
there
and the experience that i could have
gained by being present in the moment
taking classes taking notes being
conscious in meetings not sleep walking
through it because life happens uh those
years were wasted those years are over
so the truth is i probably have about 23
years experience not 30.
maybe of the last five the pandemic was
your year where you know nothing got
done i didn't learn anything it didn't
didn't grow
what this is for me
as a reminder of two things one to be
honest with myself
about you know well i stayed at this
company five years and i didn't really
learn anything so i wouldn't really feel
like that was five good years of
experience but also uh whether or not i
wanna you know stand in my stand in my
own understanding of computers and say
yeah the first couple years were rough
but the last five years were great
ask yourself how much experience you
have and whether or not
you uh
you want to assert those years i'm
looking here
in the chat here someone says same
year's experience a number of times
interesting uh michelle is pointing out
how incredibly old i am so thank you for
that gift
and uh oh i love this
serdar is saying that they've learned
more in the last two years and the
previous change because the job change
was a good kick to get their mojo back i
love it this is fantastic really great
stuff
bad experience can be good experience
but also poisonous companies you might
need to get out of there make sure that
you are conscious and this is a moment
for you maybe after this talk to sit
quietly and ask yourself what did i
learn this year
what could i do if i wake up tomorrow
and change my perspective maybe i'll
feel like i could get my mojo back and
go ask different questions or listen
more at work
i really love this slide with tim
berners-lee tim berners-lee of course
you know was one of the inventors of the
worldwide
web
and notice his
job title
he didn't say
the he didn't say he's the web developer
like you know how i really wanted to be
senior web developer and i'm like i
can't wait till i get senior in front of
my title and now here's tim berners-lee
and he could have just said the i'm the
web developer yeah i made it that was me
but he's modest and he says web
developer so if he's got that good
attitude then i too am going to have
that good attitude
i love that sophie points out no more
sleep living
a lot of really great stuff happening
in um
in the chat here cause sir i was
pointing out humility humility 100 i
love that
another thing that's worth pointing out
is the idea of finding a mentor we
talked a little about this in the
opening with lars finding a mentor
you're never too old to get good advice
remember how i said
i wanted you all to become mentors i
also want you to find one i want you to
find a mentor that means that uh you
know i could go around with an attitude
of like hey i'm old i should mentor as
many people as possible
who's my mentor where i'm the mentee
maybe they're younger than me maybe
they're gonna give me a fresh
perspective what flavor of mentor do you
want do you want a a life coach do you
want a a coding mentor i might
you know hire a 22 year old or befriend
a 30 year old to teach me python it's
not about the age it's about the
difference in experiences so i don't
want to be
egotistical imply that i don't need a
mentor but then if you're early in
career
maybe you're only three or four years
into programming you're not too young to
share your experiences
so you can go back
and share because you're just a few
years ahead of those people right you're
just a few years ahead of people now
here's where things get really
interesting because when programmers
start thinking about word definitions
they start to parse those words right
because with object oriented programming
you know
naming things is important you might
look at the words mentorship versus
sponsorship and not think that they're
any different
but mentors
they help you with your strengths they
advise you they guide you
sponsors
they are spotlights and they are kind of
creating luck they are inventing luck
creating luck and they lift you up into
new spaces a mentor says you should try
to get into that meeting that could be
good for your career a sponsor takes you
into that meeting sits you at the table
and then backs
away which is a very different
perspective so you'll have a collection
of mentors and a collection of sponsors
and they'll come and go they'll come and
go in your life
you won't necessarily have lifelong
mentors that's another important thing
to think about you can even go and look
at sponsorship as a spectrum
as a spectrum from more passive mentors
that give you advice all the way up to
someone who's fully advocating at you
for you and you may already have one of
these at work who's the person at work
who's the opportunity giver who's the
person at work who's a connector and
connecting you
to uh to new opportunities and new
people
that's going to be different perhaps
than the person who is the strategizer
who's helping you plan your career and
think about your strategies and things
like that so we myself as a later in
career person can start what's called
lending privilege lending privilege can
be like my positional privilege like i'm
kind of a you know a high up person at
microsoft so someone who's earlier in
their career who has a lower rank
i can lend my privilege and i can say
you should come into this
meeting you should join us in this stand
up and i'll lift them up
and i have unlimited amounts of that i
can bring an unlimited number of people
into a meeting like that i can share
opportunities with them i should say you
could come speak at uh
uh at ndc i have a feeling like lars is
going to pop in at any moment he's
stressing me out
here i am
yesterday on your mind that was eerie i
did not prompt that for you and here was
anyway
um we've got another question which
actually i can relate to quite a lot
because i live in the middle of
absolutely nowhere i travel in
to melbourne today to host this so that
we wouldn't have to talk through you
know two cans and some string and stuff
but i live in a rural area how do you
find mentos in the rural area because it
can be really really tricky
yeah well i think that we all learned
over the last year that video is a thing
and uh it's funny how we have discovered
uh keep keeping in mind that i've worked
remotely from a rural area in rural
oregon for microsoft for the last 15
years i've never everyone thinks i live
in seattle i have never lived or worked
in seattle and i occasionally drive up
there but i haven't been up to work in
two years
so i've been telling people myself phil
hack damien edwards
video video video for 15 20 years now
we've proven it
now we have discord we have twitter we
have stream yard we have zencaster we
have opportunities to have these these
these get-togethers so you can organize
a virtual get-together
you're organizing your game your gamer
friends and your dnd friends on discord
why don't you get involved with a
mentorship
ring not just a one-on-one mentorship
ring but a a pool
of people who all need different things
at different levels and i've assembled a
couple of mentorship rings
at microsoft and i'm trying not to be
the leader of the ring but rather the
facilitator and then it's a matchmaking
kind of thing oh like you know uh i
don't know rock climbing compiler design
you should talk to so-and-so they're
interested in compiler design and then
you have an engagement for two weeks
three weeks or whatever you learn what
you need to learn so you want to kind of
have that um that connective connective
tissue happening does that make sense
yeah absolutely the people that i mentor
uh i've never oh i've met one of them
but the others i've never met face to
face yeah so it's very very possible
yeah but it's all about what feeds your
spirit again this is about being
intentional for me i have a bagel shop
that i go to uh and i meet people there
at the bagel shop so we commiserate over
bagels but then i have people who are in
other time zones and we do our kind of
our skype calls or our team calls and we
have those conversations the important
part is not to just show up and talk
it's to have a plan like what are we
going to talk about today set a a light
agenda and the thing that i need to
always remember as a as an older person
as a an an elder is a mentorship
relationship with let's say 20 year old
lars should not be
scott lectures lars every week like an
uncle
and you go oh thank you so much for your
wisdom old man and then that's our
relationship right i can't wait to get a
great beer myself exactly
it's coaching it's encouragement it's
strategies and it needs to be yeah
people are saying peer-to-peer
mentorship
those are the kind of things i think the
key word's intention i think you hit the
nail on the head there it's got to be
intentional and and actually one other
thing aaron uh dandy in the chat here is
saying that they went into the rust
discord and they got a stranger to par
with pair with them rather on a bad
program remember how i said
all i've done all ours has done in the
last you know 20 years is shown up
you're known in the community because
you arrive you are there
if you show up in the rust discord for
some weeks
it's not going to be weird for you to
say i'm looking for a mentor no right if
you show up on day one of twitter one
follower you said nothing i'm looking
for a mentor you're basically taking a
chance who knows but it's like oh yeah
that's so-and-so that's jt he's always
at the user group good dude you should
introduce them to sophie you should
introduce him to the chat he is they
could hang out together and mentor
showing up is a big part of life
fantastic i'll go back in my hall oh
lovely
all right cool are we having fun my
friends i hope this isn't uh isn't
boring you this is good
all right the other thing that people
don't remember and they don't realize
about mentorship is that it happens in
phases right mentoring phases what is
your career phase what is their phase
and
make sure that you're conscious about
where they are positionally especially
if they're that you're they're at your
job
if they are diagonal to you at your job
that's ideal that means they're not your
boss you don't have your boss mentor or
your boss's boss
mentor you what you do is you find
someone who's above you in rank in
another org that means that they can't
affect your reviews they can't mess up
your reviews they can't hurt you
but they are a parallel universe a loki
variant as it were of yourself that's a
best kind of mentor someone who is a
future version of you and as we
mentioned before when lars popped in
mentorship is a two-way street not a
scheduled regular lecture from an old
person super important
okay so let's talk about some stories
i'll tell you a couple of fun stories
that make me happy and you can tell me
if they're stupid that'll be fun
remember before i mention swiss army
knives this is a big thing for me i
really am a fan i actually have the
swiss army knife that my dad bought me
when i was 12 and i keep it always
available to me
on my desk here not just because it's
got cool you know hex screwdriver type
stuff and and the swiss army knife has a
pen
it's got a freaking pen so i can look at
that i can't really see it oh that's
tweezers that's because i'm blind
it's got a pen
in the thing it's got tiny screwdrivers
in the thing the thing about the swiss
army knife that's interesting is that
the swiss army knife is a really a lousy
pair of scissors
it's not really good at anything it's
kind of mediocre it is a generalist it's
okay to be a generalist right it's okay
to be a funny little knife that isn't
amazing and everything but we can we can
say one thing about the swiss army knife
is it is a good knife
so when you are thinking about
technology often you're going to try to
say can i should i just specialize in
jquery should that be my thing i'll just
be the best person at jquery and then
jquery goes away or react or angular or
whatever or technology du jour goes away
what doesn't go away cpus
memory
storage
distributed systems design patterns
none of those things are technology
specific
be a good knife
yes
oh you did notice um there's there
questions are coming now thick and fast
that's lovely i know it's really good so
um i got two that's sort of related but
um i'll go with the first one first what
tips do you have for a mentee so how can
a mentee get the most out of it
from a mentor obviously and besides
buying tacos for them yeah bribery of
course is gifts is really what it's all
about um what a mentee can do and this
is this is important and i'm gonna i'm
gonna stare
into the camera for this one
show up
yeah i have had mentions ghost me on
meetings i've had mentees show up and
have nothing to say i've had mentees
complain about how everyone sucks but
them i've had mentees not take
responsibility for the things that
they're doing
show up with questions with an agenda of
three items and
pull the information from your mentor
what do you want to know
i'm dealing with a difficult person at
work i don't understand hash tables
please explain the cloud to me
and that sets your mentor up for success
if you do that then you're going to get
what you want out of it
as opposed to a lecture from an elder
once a week yep completely agree um yeah
be prepared and then the other one is as
a consultant
it's sometimes difficult to be a mentor
because i can't build the time should
seniors use a percentage of their time
to mentor that's a really good question
it's a tough one
as a consultant when you're thinking
about your life in the context of hourly
that is a challenge
yeah the way that i did that when i was
a consultant
is i thought about not just my billable
hours but i thought about all of my
hours
meaning all of my waking hours
and be intentional about that now i'm
not saying you have to do this every day
but what an interesting challenge it
would be
if you
wrote down every single hour for a week
not 40 hours i mean seven times 24
and you have to be honest with yourself
sunday afternoon
sat in the garden for three hours
2 a.m on a tuesday
binge watch netflix because my job
sucked that day and i needed to revenge
nighttime procrastination and steal the
time back because my job sucks and i
hate it so i watched
something stupid on netflix for three
hours be intentional about it then look
at that and think to yourself wow
i wasted what some amount of time now
i'm not saying i'm advocating for hustle
culture or what's called productivity
culture every minute counts no like you
can take a leisurely crap on the toilet
and scroll and tick talk that's allowed
but
if you burn three hours watching netflix
maybe burn two
hours watching netflix maybe
walk on a treadmill and watch netflix
like what can you do to combine things
to fold hours together
right i started doing tick tocks on my
treadmill on walks combining two things
right um and i bet you you could find an
hour or two that you had wasted that
would be a gift to someone else and it
wouldn't affect your billable hours
good answer thanks good stuff lovely
laura's adding value all right let's try
to get through some of these interesting
questions here these are some stories
and some stuff that is uh that i'm
thinking about first
young people in problem solving comes up
i think that problem solving is asking
yes no questions at scale all right
yes no sec questions at scale yes no
questions at scale is how you debug and
when you as an early and career person
sits down with a later and queer person
and you wonder why i've been trying to
debug this for six hours and they just
they just had it right there i'm gonna
share with you the reasons that those
senior people can do that and one of the
fundamental things that they can do is
they can eliminate entire classes of
problems
with a yes no question all right
so here's a question for you my friends
actually large pop in here for a second
you're going to be the young person in
this experiment pop in here pretend that
you're not hi scott
maybe don't do that too much no a little
too much on the nose all right lars
young person my toaster is broken and i
really want toast we're going to learn
how to be a programmer today i need
toast help me out buddy what's that
what's going on with my toaster have you
got a lighter
you
just put a lighter what does the lighter
have to do with the toaster you're
solving it will they just burn the toast
directly well toast is just you know
carbohydrates turning into sugar i used
to add heat isn't it
all right i need to actually i want to
use the toaster i paid for i do okay
it's not working uh you know a simple
minded person might say well just buy a
new toaster yeah no no yeah but we're
going to debug it because you and i are
systems thinkers
yes so give me some questions to ask
what are some yes oh there we go hassan
says is it plugged in yeah yeah that's a
good it could be a hardware problem i
tried turning it off and on again okay
is the power on i like that how would i
test to see if the power of the
toaster's on
we put something else into the
powerpoint oh look at that plug in
something else see how it's like we did
not plan this okay
we didn't talk about this
i plugged in a light the light is not
turning on which i don't know
call it electrician no you see if you're
sure the light's working well you can
keep going down that path but yeah
where's that what else is broken okay so
uh is it connected to the wi-fi peter
says
i hope not
um so uh i don't know i plugged it in i
got no power anywhere so is the power
even on
in the house
how would i go and see if the power in
the house is even on and and if it's the
neighbors got power yeah
look at you how did you know that
because it happens frequently when i
leave when you live rurally did you live
in rural australia
exactly do the neighbors have power
that's a great question
we started this whole thing i just want
burnt bread
and now we're asking a fundamental
question about
does the neighbors have power and if you
wanted to take it you know maybe as far
as like dylan beatty would take was
there an emp has there been an attack
have the aliens uh taken over right
these are the questions we have to ask
ourselves all of this is part of the
system right it's always dns whatever it
is probably but the point is when you're
a programmer you need to be thinking
about systems it's not about toaster
expertise
it's not about having a degree in toast
it's about well where does the toaster
fit into the system if someone were to
by the way i don't know i don't know if
you saw this last night but i was doing
something stupid i recorded myself
taking linkedin assessments
live on my phone
for products i don't know anything about
did not see that it sounds amazing i go
into linkedin and it's like you should
become uh certified in aws
so i'm like
okay sure anything about aws right i
know it's a cloud
so i recorded the screen and i started
taking the test and i passed and i'm now
certified in aw that's fantastic so new
job opportunity exactly does that mean
i'm smart and i know a lot about aws
no no not at all it means systems
thinking right yep computers have cpu
and memory and subnets are things
i have a funny example for that actually
well let's not say funny clown haha but
interesting because i like cars right
but i grew up with 10 thumbs i had no
idea about fixing anything but applying
software debugging skills to cars
actually goes a really really far a
really long way because it's like what's
not working okay that's working then you
do the next thing and it's this exact
same approach systems thinking is the
deal so if we go back to the slides and
we look at someone who's early in career
versus someone who's later in career the
reason that you're googling a lot for
stuff hopefully with bing
you are you don't know what question to
ask
later in the career it's not that we
know stuff
it's that we know questions to ask
right and as the american president
abraham lincoln said it's always dns
i made a list on the left hand side here
of things to check this is literally
just a silly list that i just made up
of like a young person comes to me and
asks me what's wrong and i ask all these
questions and then they fix it and they
go oh my goodness how did you know
you're so smart oh wow i can't wait till
i'm experienced i don't know what's
going on when non-technical parent calls
me
and i'm like look for a gear click on
the gear light is there anything like a
gear it's not that it's just if they
have to fix the printer you just run
away because you never can turn it off
and turn it on again and then as my and
the other thing to watch out for right
is uh if you see if you hear hoof beats
you want to think horses not zebras uh
as my sons were watching sherlock holmes
recently and this lady killed her
husband and then she was also seen on
the other side of town and watson says
to sherlock holmes it was twins that's
how they did it there's twins and
sherlock holmes is never twins it's too
obvious it's never twins
these are all just things to check you
as an early and career person will
collect these items so problem solving
is collecting questions and asking yes
no questions at scale let's bang through
the last couple ones here as we get
towards the end of our chat so layering
is when you start hiding complexity it's
vertical vertical layering and layering
in computer science is actually not
layering it is
lying it is the computer lying to you
when you call an api or you
make a function in a virtual machine
it's an abstraction on top of something
else that layer is meant to hire
other things to hide other things rather
and typically the things that it's
hiding may be reused it may be a thing
that you already know about here's an
example that i always like to use
people know about http right you all
know how to like call an http get and
things like that right
but no one really thinks about email no
one presses f12 tools and looks at an
email getting sent this is
an actual on the wire email
with
name value pairs
content type plane
encoding
and look a a little separator here's
another separator
here's the
plain part of the email here's the html
part of the email
that looks surprisingly
familiar does it not
this is posting
a multi-part email a multi-part html
form and this is sending email
so all this time
email which has been around forever is
name value pairs with separators
because multi-part form data is a
specification and here's posting html
form so would you
you should be surprised i hope you're
surprised that email and html are
similar
this is a really important thing that
makes it seem like later in career
people know more than they do
it's not that i know more it's that i've
seen more
and then i'm i've realized i probably
already know a thing
html is text that goes over http over
report
email is text that uses smtp and goes
over a port it's all just internet
traffic if you understand things at the
text level
just like lars was using the example
about cars right it's got wheels i could
probably drive it we've seen that in the
movies where a mechanic is like it's got
wheels i can drive it's got wings i can
fly it
okay now that means we can reuse good
ideas
on the left hand side we have a spinning
hard drive physical hard drive on the
right hand side we have an old record
player an old victrola and in both
instances we have a circle
with encoded data that spins and a head
that picks it up
and we have a circle with encoded data
and a head that picks it up and this
might be terabytes and invented last
year or made last year and this might be
150 years old but the idea is the same
a blu-ray a hard drive a record player
they are the same they are the same
now
in computer science we have composition
composing things has a it's all part of
layers uh layers are on top of each
other a composition are things are
inside of each other uh this is a real
story of a thing that happened to me and
understanding how things fit together
was how i solved it this gentleman here
is my now friend chris connor who is an
actor and he was in a great show on
netflix called
uh altered carbon and in the film he
played an ai named poe he was basically
an ai a construct that represented edgar
allan poe
and i met him on twitter and i said you
know i'm a big fan of your work you're a
great fella we should hang out sometime
and have tacos so we did so we hung out
and we had tacos and he's he's amazing
and i'm a nerd and we hung out and you
know we he's a good dude
then i came home after podcasting with
him and this is what i found on the sd
card
this is me wondering where my files are
from the interview with my new
uh
best friend right
i'm thinking to myself this man is never
going to be friends with me again and
we're not going to hang out at all how
am i going to call this actor and say
hey man can we redo that podcast that we
just burnt an entire hour on because i'm
an idiot and i lost the file
and you can see here that the hard drive
had an infinite recursive
empty folder
the files were gone
i don't know anything about sd cards i
don't know anything about file systems
but i do know that file explorer is a
an abstraction
on top of a bunch of things yeah i
thought i was going to die i was sick
literally sick i was like would i just
ghost the guy do i apologize there's no
scenario where this goes well i went
into file info
and i noted that file info said that 300
megs were used up on the disk
okay
so this is a black box right that's a an
sd card this is one of the sd cards that
i would use and this card had nothing on
it so i'm thinking to myself i'm dead
but it's all about bytes right it's an
array of bytes it's specifically
345 million 776
936 bytes in
an array
let's go look at them so i dumped
that sd card i made an image file of it
because i didn't want to hurt it because
you know when things are corrupted i
want a copy of the corruption i don't
want to mess it up so i made an image
file i just googled for how to make an
image file out of an sd card and i
started poking around and i knew that it
was a a fat or file allocation table
card
because you have a fat file system and i
started poking around and looking at
the structures
and noticing an awful lot of zeros
and the starting cluster should
definitely not be zero and i didn't know
this stuff i looked it up
you know this stuff
you know this stuff you just don't
acknowledge that you know this stuff
it's literally the difference between
driving a car your entire life and never
knowing there's an engine
versus having a passing familiarity that
you can open the boot you can open the
the trunk you can open the front of the
car and find an engine inside and go wow
there's an engine i'm not saying that
every early and career person should
become a mechanic i am saying that a
familiarity with how your car drives
will make you a better more powerful
engineer and it will allow you to be
more in control the best way to do this
is to know one layer below
your comfort zone
so just pick your comfort zone and go
one layer below there and like folks are
saying in the chat google is your best
friend so i ended up fixing those bytes
in the image file
found that the two files the wav files
in there
and learned a lot about how applications
talk to the file system and they talked
to i o control which talks to devices
and
dug in
below my comfort zone
and discovered how these things are
composed exactly hassan is saying go one
level down my friends and finally
what makes later in career people seem
magical and what we can do to make early
and career people successful is by
helping them understand
pattern recognition i've seen a thing
before that seems familiar i've heard of
that
one time i spent 13 hours
debugging a segmentation fault in a
raspberry pi
and um
oh there's large i'm almost done large
like two minutes okay okay we'll take it
after we'll do you here to kick me out
because i'm running late no no no no
we're not late i feel like just keep
going we'll do questions in a minute
okay well you can oh he goes away he
left me alone
oh good all right i spent 13 hours
debugging a segmentation fault in.net
core in a raspberry pi and i made a file
said hello world i copied it over to the
raspberry pi and it crashed
i was like that sucks and i pounded on
it for a while and it was awful and then
i even made a folder and i put
a folder called good and i put my
application in there
and i made a folder called bad and i put
the application in there and i noticed
something weird let's squint shall we
let us squint
here's a 0d here's a 0d
here's a big blank space here's a big
blank space
where
where are all the zero d's
the one that doesn't run has no
13s 0d is
13. why is that that's super annoying
well it turns out i was using ftp
file transfer protocol to copy my files
over and you'll notice right here that
this is a executable called raspberry pi
running on linux it doesn't have an
extension because linux doesn't use
extensions
and in my transfer program there's been
a bug
which the
the owner of the the manager of this
open source project filezilla refuses to
admit is a bug called treat files
without an extension as an ascii file
ascii of course being the
standard american standard of something
something character encoding yada yada
yada it's the thing that describes like
an a is 67 and uh b is 68. those kind of
things
and i realized where have i seen zero d
before where have i seen zero d before
well zero d is a thirteen
like i said it's a carriage return and a
zero a is a line feed so my executable
my program was being treated like a text
file
and it stripped out the carriage return
and replaced it with nothing because on
unix on linux machines they don't use
carriage returns they use line feeds so
it corrupted the file because it said it
has no extension and it ripped it out so
then the question is my young friends
what's a carriage
why is it returning we have people
learning git right now and they're
setting features like auto cr lf they're
wondering why their text files get
corrupted and they don't realize that in
fact a typewriter has a carriage along
the top here that carries
the
paper and this item right over here
the carriage return
is used to go
push it all the way back so you go type
type type type
carriage return ding
and then
the knob turns the what's called the
platen
turns and feeds the next line
carriage return line feed carriage
return line feed
isn't it weird that a typewriter that
was later hooked up as a terminal to a
mainframe in the 40s somewhere and then
ascii was invented and someone decided
that 13 moves the carriage and 10 feeds
the line is now causing us consternation
and frustration in the year of our lord
2021.
how do i know that because i dug deeper
how do you know that because you watched
this wonderful talk at ndc and we had
all kinds of fun and now if you ever
bump into an issue like that you're
going to be like 13
10 that's character turn line feed
patterns
asking the right questions how are
things layered how are they composed
together and problem solving at scale
allows us to make cool stuff and that is
itself super cool i'm going to actually
skip ahead and just say to you all how
happy i am that you are here and invite
lars back on to interrupt me in that way
that only lars can and we'll do a couple
of questions as we head out to our next
interrupted consider yourself
interrupted
yeah we do um actually i had a question
as well but we'll get to that after this
one so um sergey is asking
while having the right solid foundation
and attitude generators tend to struggle
with practical hassles like getting a
job any advice on that yeah that's a
tough one i have a 13 year old and a 15
year old right now
and one of the things that they're
struggling with is handshakes looking
people in the eye
small talk
these are squishy things that we never
really learned we never really taught
and we get all this stuff about data
structures and discrete math
but not how to be noticed i don't have
good answers for that other than
try to be as well balanced as you can be
be visible be kind show up
user groups i would say is how i got my
start i got my start speaking my first
talk ever was a talk on the emerging new
brand new technology it was called xml
and i gave a talk at the oregon software
association on this new technology that
was taken over the world called xml and
i talked to 20 people at a luncheon
and i showed up and they're like oh
there's that guy again show up at user
groups be visible people who are in the
chats right now are visible i know half
of these people
we've got a very kind gentleman in the
chat here who's saying that they're 42
and they struggle with handshakes and
look people in the eye and small talk
it sucks that
being good at computers and being good
at humans is a thing that we have to
balance and then you aren't always
measured and metric on just simply your
ability to ship
and it seems sometimes like people with
snazzy personalities get the job
i would say you know learning to network
learning to be involved learning to show
up what do you think the answer is lars
i think there's something to it uh from
what you're saying i i usually say that
if you're uncomfortable in a like say a
meet-up setting where there's 40 other
people
the
people's favorite topic is usually
themselves
oh
yes and you go so the only thing you
have to say
you walk up to someone says hi
what do you do and you're off
i used to know much more to use i used
to sell computers at a place called
incredible universe that's now was fry's
electronics and then recently went out
of business a computer store big
warehouse
and all the other
you know geek squad people would go
around and say are you good you're
finding everything okay can i help you
right and then you're always like just
browsing just brown don't talk to me
right pretty much but i
is our person that i am would go up and
say are you having fun have you seen
anything cool today
and then they would go just browsing and
i'd go that's great but have you seen
anything cool today
and
and then they like reset and then
suddenly you're talking to someone and
you're you're you're good friends you
can practice you can practice at the
mcdonald's drive-through at the
starbucks you can learn you can practice
your how to be friendly and personable
on the produce guy at the totally sure
and the interesting thing is that people
are usually in the same
situation right they don't want to start
either so if you can get you know past
that initial kind of oh god what am i
doing here and a feeling go hey
you look interesting you don't look
threatening i'll start there what do you
do you know as you said what's a cool
thing you learned tonight kind of thing
and just having that little tiny
icebreaker can mean so much and again if
the person doesn't want to talk to you
they'll let you know you know move on to
the next one there is a great youtube
channel called charisma on command
and what they do is they watch people
who are
demonstrably charming and they analyze
their interviews
and one of the best episodes of uh
charisma on command is when they take
russell brand
who is a
uk kind of like rock star type and he's
known to be universally charming
and uh they put him on a very awkward um
certain direction leaning talk show
where they're basically passive
aggressive and they're mean to him and
they're kind of a jerk and it's like wow
why are we watching this incredibly
painful thing
and then you see him using his body and
his position and his turn and the way he
turns and the way he presents himself
and in about 10 minutes he turns the
interview around he's got them eating
out of his hand and then the the
commentator
on this
on command show explains notice what he
did he physically turned his body to to
rebuff this person who had insulted him
but he did it in a classy way
he turned this this was an insulting
question that he answered with a
question thereby putting the honest on
the person to answer it it was just
full analysis of what charisma truly is
yeah check it out that is very
interesting lovely lovely stuff
um well to jane's subject we have a
question from our mutual good friend
adam cogan oh
oh yeah that you should be scared no
that's fine um
he's just asking if you can talk about
how you found your migration to tick
tock
tick tock
is a joy
the deal though with tick tock is if you
just jump in within about two days
you're going to see a bunch of
inappropriate stuff and things you don't
want to see and you're going to like if
you're you know
not interested in
dances and skimpy clothing and bikinis
and stuff you're going to be like why am
i on tic tac you have to teach tik tok
what you like it takes about three days
and you'll see some inappropriate
content that's a problem and that turns
people off tick tock particularly older
people however
once you start liking stuff and
hard-pressed not interested on the
things you don't want to hear i have
this most amazing tick tock it's called
the fyp for you for you page it's your
personalized feed
i've got
woodworking inspirational quotes from
gurus
i've been i found my way somehow to
native american first nations tick tock
and i'm learning about their culture
learning japanese
spanish grammar
geometry lessons for my kid and in his
high school i've got a curated stuff i'm
interested in star wars things marvel
fan theories and i'm not seeing like the
stuff i don't want to see but if i
texted you a tick tock
the one you thought would be awesome but
then the next one would be something
that's probably they're just rolling the
dice and you're going to end up seeing
something you don't want to see
yeah i have found my way on tick tock by
finding what a joy it is
uh yeah and here we go john is saying in
the chat that he watches it with his son
and keeps it and they've kept away from
any dodgy videos sophie makes a great
point it's like twitter it's what you
teach it yep
that makes sense and i have not used
tick tock i must admit but i have heard
many different varied stories
and i'll send you two or three favorites
one of the other fun thing about tick
tocks is people will say a thing and do
a thing and then the sound can be marked
as a sound so i could go to the tick
tock see a thing where you're ranting
about a barista at the coffee shop hit
use sound
and then
talk over you basically i would lip-sync
to your sound and then that's how things
go viral right
so there's one lovely one where this
woman is in the new york subway and she
sees a rat and he's eating something in
the subway and she's like you know
people ask me why i moved to the city
and it's just that i love the charm of
new york and there's just so much
happening in the culture and she's
saying this while the
so now people use that audio
to show just horrible things that are
happening in new york
and now we have code talk and programmer
talk and tech talk it's a really very
supportive fun yeah yeah community
that's a neat feature yeah and i don't
have to do any funny dances or anything
no yeah and you get to listen to
shanties and stuff it's wonderful
um oh people questions keep coming um
what's your opinion on boot camps
do your research in the number one way
you can tell if
a uh
a boot camp is a good idea is talk to
someone who graduated
so just to clarify what is a boot camp
boot camp would be
a
fixed length
intensive program that is to not
necessarily simulate a degree or give
you a degree but we'll call it a
nanodegree or a micro degree they're
going to say i can teach you php in six
months and when they mean six months
they mean 40 50 hours like you quit your
job
live at your parents you know
you you can't have a job and do a boot
camp it's a boot camp like we're going
to put you in combat
in the next six months
which is different than the kind of the
gentle four years of of an undergraduate
degree um i've seen people come out of
boot camps incredibly successful i think
of uh
saran yad barak from code newbies who
you know did a boot camp
dropped out of medical school became a
very successful programmer i created
code newbies etc there's a lot of people
a lot of people though will find that
boot camps will charge them 20 000 u.s
they'll have to do huge loans and stuff
like that
um
about imposed discipline the structure
of the boot camp provides discipline and
a
curriculum the challenge is that you
could create your own curriculum online
the it's all available but that requires
a lot of discipline and a lot of
familiarity but i would encourage people
to take out things like free code camp
and think about the structure of that
and also cs50 the free class at harvard
and some of the open courseware things
as well as the khan academy computer
science khan academy.org
cs and see if you could put together
your own one um i would i would look at
that before and then i would would talk
to other folks as well
yeah yeah that makes it graduates
um no i had a question as well and
there's uh from sort of way at the start
of your talk
you mentioned that you try and inst you
know you only have finite number of
keystrokes
and am i gonna use 200 keystrokes on
sophie or not if i can write a blog post
so from that
when we talk about mentoring at what
point and how do you decide whether this
particular piece of advice
is for a single person that you're
talking face-to-face or you're going to
turn it into something that you can
either present in a talk like this or in
a blog post or a youtube video like
because there's value in both so how how
do you define how do you decide
um
general purpose stuff
like i'm always looking for things that
happened privately that could be shared
with more people
um
mads torguson that one of the designers
in c sharp shared an internal email
recently about hybrid meetings meetings
that are both mixed and in person and i
was like wow this is huge it's like nine
paragraphs and it's great stuff can i
use that as the jumping point of a blog
post so i asked him could i credit you
and write a blog post about this um
that's something that's generic right if
someone sends me a how do i get started
in podcasting or what microphone should
i
uh get i say go and google hanselman
good better best and i know that google
and bing will send them to my starting a
uh
you know getting a good webcam or
hanselman getting started podcast and
they'll find those things so i've got
those keywords in my head um but if it's
very private or personal then i keep
those things separate to the to the
mentee but i would say 80 of things like
dealing with difficult people or
compiler errors are very much um
for everyone and not for just one person
okay that makes sense
and so i'm just checking the chat here
if there are people that are asking
anything
because that is all the questions we
have and we are almost out of time
lovely so if there's nothing else i just
want to say thank you scott because that
was really cool and there was as always
there was a tech element to it i was
freaking out i was like i don't know if
this is what they want to hear i don't
know what we're going to do
yeah oh that's scary i liked it it
wasn't scary at all well thank you for
your help i appreciate it and thank you
to everyone in the chat for keeping
things moving and thanks for everyone
who are giving us good questions
absolutely yeah that's uh was very good
so thank you scott from everybody
and um
oh we have a few minutes before our next
speaker is going to come up and i'm just
going to check our schedule here and see
what we're doing
so
maybe
we can
move over to william because we is ready
and he's probably got a bit to say
before we uh
go in and talk to our next
presenter for for ndc melbourne now i
will just mention as well that
throughout the day you can win stuff win
prizes there are a couple of quizzes
that are going to come up so we have one
at 11 which is a developer quiz and we
have one after lunch i mean we're not
providing lunch but whenever you have
lunch
and uh and that's more on melbourne so
if you're not from melbourne that could
get really interesting but you can win
hoodies like this one that i'm wearing
it says melbourne on it and you see
melbourne might not be exactly this one
because i'm wearing it but you can win
hoodies and there's also prizes at the
end of the day but make sure that you uh
use the slido which we'll get to as well
for the quizzes so you can win
as well as the end of the day so lots to
come still also yoga so get your yoga
mat out that's at 12 o'clock so what's
that two hours from now um but lots of
stuff but um
let's uh yeah visit the expo that's
right go to
export.ndcmelton.com that's how you can
win uh the grand prizes as well which is
uh tickets for next year's ndc melbourne
which will be in person fingers crossed
and all access pass for that um so go
there make sure you put in your details
visit all the sponsors because they're
the ones that makes this happen
but i think that was all i had to say
for now i'm gonna move it over to
william who is gonna say hello and
introduce himself as well take it away
william
thanks lars hello everybody i'm william
liebenberg
i work here at ssw in melbourne and
before we actually get started with the
next speaker
i would just like to
let our sponsors
give them a moment to
show their videos
[Music]
the idea behind distinguished engineers
is really to assemble a diverse team of
our top level engineers and some of the
best engineering minds on the planet to
really solve the most complex problems
both for cba and for our customers our
distinguished engineering program
started internally by us having a good
look at who'd really shown amazing
engineering leadership or technology
leadership already inside the group and
we basically started assembling those
people and focusing them on really
important problems both for us and our
customers
[Music]
i get to actually roll up my sleeves and
actually really help solve some really
tricky problems in the bank one of the
big challenges we have right now in x-15
is how do we get small teams of
engineers to be able to within just like
a few months go for an idea and get it
into our customers hands if we can crack
that i think that's an incredibly tough
engineering problem but also means that
we can make a massive difference in
australia
[Music]
one of the main reasons that engineering
is important at combank is just the
scale of impact that we have across
australia for commonwealth bank we're
the largest lender in australia and so
the scale and importance of digitizing a
process like that has an impact on all
australians the thing for me that's
really appealing about engineering at
combank is the combination of really
important problems for australia and
really difficult engineering problems
[Music]
hello again everybody and i just like to
personally thank our sponsors because
without them
this event wouldn't have been possible
um so today the first talk we're going
to have is from david wenger
he is a developer at microsoft and here
is hi dave
good day will how's it going
going very well i'm i'm always impressed
by that uh lego collection you have in
the background there dave
do you ever uh just pick one off the
shelves and take it apart and rebuild it
or they just build ones
leave
sometimes they fall off the shelves and
get rebuilt but uh usually i try to be
nice my kids not so much
[Laughter]
now
i mean
same i love lego do you find the you
know lego sort of helps you
take a break from programming but still
keep your mind active in a sort of
way of
programming in a way nice and procedural
there's always instructions
or do you just like building a random
things
no i'm definitely not the random builder
i leave that to the kids i'm definitely
follow the instructions and
i like to uh so you know there's cars
and stuff behind me i like cars um
what i like about it is as you're
putting it together you can see some of
you're seeing how it works and how it
fits together and then of course
it's uh it's greater than its parts kind
of thing uh that's the same thing i like
about programming so there's definitely
parallels
now you are talking to us today about
records but i'm assuming it's not the
old
music records there's something uh very
different
uh c sharp records right that's right
yeah and uh so can you maybe just give
us a hint
before we start why would i choose
to use a records over
classes and structs for instance
uh that's an interesting question uh
that's
kind of
you know maybe what i'm gonna answer but
uh
yeah i think i think the
uh scott kind of i won't say he stole a
line from me because i'm pretty sure i
stole it from him but i have used it
before in talks
when he was talking about looking
you know one level below what you
understand um i love that idea that's
what i do as well and that's sort of how
i approach uh records so for me
it's not that much about when you would
use a record or a structure a class it's
what's more important is to
understand what a record is
under the covers so that you can make
that decision because it's always going
to be you know dependent on what you're
doing
uh i'm looking forward to this dave
because uh
uh i've i've got questions of my own
about records for you but i'll leave
that to the end i think we'll go through
your talk so
the stream is yours take it away all
right thank you no pressure following
that wonderful keynote but uh hello
thank you for tuning in my name's dave
let's talk about records
is a record uh
that's a
tough question that i don't know the
answer to because
well i didn't prepare for this talk at
all um
no
a record is a funny thing to define
because in c sharp 9 a record is another
way of defining a type
but in c 10 even that statement is not
true and a record is now just
a thing and it's another way to define a
thing but it's not really its own thing
and um what i think a record is and this
is a
very well led to by williams question
which was completely unscripted i
promise uh is a record is really just
the collection of its parts right it's
it's all the bits of record put together
that's what define it
and
i've sort of put six uh of those
features i guess uh on the screen there
to me this is what defines a record it's
just a record has these uh has these
qualities essentially um what's
interesting here about records or about
these qualities is that
five of these which i have circled with
a squiggly square
are not exclusive to records and so
like i was saying before one of the
really cool things about records is even
if you're never going to use them
by understanding how they work and
understanding what the compiler does to
achieve
recordness
you can
bring some of those concepts to your
existing code even if you don't use
records or maybe you will use records or
maybe you use records and you'll take
some of them out so that's kind of what
i want to talk about
and i'm just going to barrel through
here we go
so the first one up is
simplified declaration and as of right
now
and including cs10 which is coming out
in november
this is exclusive to records the only
way to get this
simplified syntax is to use a record you
can't put it on your own classes and
things there's lots of requests for that
but you can't at the moment um and what
this essentially is is
well i mean you can see there right it's
a one-line declaration it kind of looks
like a type declaration because it's
public
something car right it's not a return
type it's a thing
it kind of looks like a constructor
because again it doesn't have a return
type but it does have brackets and
parameters so it kind of looks like a
method call right so it kind of looks
like a constructor and it kind of looks
like a type declaration and it turns out
it's kind of those things in one
that num doors uh parameter there
explodes out and becomes a parameter of
the constructor and a property of the
class that this would generate
and that's really what a record is at
the end of the day a record is a
different way of defining a class and it
has some other behaviors but that's kind
of what it is
now
full disclosure if you know what records
are and how they work that's a lie it's
not a set we'll talk about that later
and there's a lot more that gets
generated
with records it's not just a one
constructor we'll cover all of that
um
but simplified declaration is uh for me
the sort of the quintessential thing
about a record i love that you can
define a class in one line and use it
and it has properties and it does what
you need to do it's really good for you
know data transfer objects those sort of
things those small classes um i just
have you know a file and put 20 records
definitions in it's 20 lines and you're
done
so it's really nice and if nothing else
uh it's what's probably one of my
favorite or second favorite feature of
them um even though it's arguably the
least interesting um but that's what a
record is essentially
so
let's keep going uh i said that records
was a class and in c sharp nine that's
true
in c 10 that's not true so
what you can now do or
well now if you're using preview
versions of vs and in future
is you can actually tell the compiler
what type of thing you want this record
to be so you can say public record class
car and that will generate a class and
of course if you can say class well then
you can say struct and that will
generate a struct
and this is also why records aren't
really anything because a record is just
a class or a struct it's not a new kind
of type in.net
which it seems like it is at first but
it's not
it's just the features you know
um
i just saw melissa's question about
david's room and i thought she was
talking about lego uh yes if you ask
questions on slider that's what that qr
code in the corner is for um okay so
immutable
back to records
uh records are immutable by default
um
someone
there's many people who disagree with
that statement uh
there's often
i won't say heated debates but there's
discussions about this concept there's
some in github on like the docs page
where it says they're immutable by
default and people complain that they're
not
on c-sharp discord hello everyone on
c-sharp discord uh i say things like
yeah they're immutable by default and
everyone says no they're not
immutable
is
controversial
so let me let me talk about this when i
say by default what i mean is that
simplified declaration of a record right
this one liner if you define a record in
one line like that then it is an
immutable object
guaranteed the problem with immutability
in records
is you can't
essentially know
whether a record is immutable or not
there is nothing by definition that says
it's immutable so
this record definition right single line
this is immutable
this record definition is exactly the
same
but it is not immutable
and from a consuming point of view you
can't tell obviously you can look at the
source code and tell if you can look at
the source code well that answers all
the questions right
but if you are given an instance of type
car and someone tells you it's a record
that doesn't mean anything right this
record down the bottom there is a
mutable record because it has a set
accessor on that property you can set
that whenever you like
so
as i lied to you earlier that's not how
the c compiler generates a record what
it actually generates is
an init accessor so this is a new thing
added in c sharp nine
four records
um but it works on any property it works
on structs it works on classes and what
it does is it allows you to define a
mutable sorry an immutable
type so one where you can't set
properties or the unit properties anyway
except you can set them in if you're
initializing an object
and there's essentially two ways to
initialize an object in c sharp
number one is the constructor whoops
that's the constructor there on the
screen thank you um so as you can see
right in the constructor there we're
setting this numdos property but well
we've said we can't set it so how does
that work well the compiler knows that
okay in the constructor you can call it
property and it is very specifically in
the constructor you can't set an init
property in a method even if the method
is called from the constructor like it
is specific
the other initialization case which i
skipped to earlier is object
initialization so pretend we didn't have
the constructor you can construct an
object in c-sharp like this you just
specify those properties and
c-sharp will let you the file will let
you even though you're setting a
property because you're initializing
the
initializing object thank you aaron yes
they did
uh
if you try and set the property the
normal way then you get an error
because the compiler cannot know or
doesn't know that you're initializing
an object kind of like i mean you look
at that and you're like well obviously i
am but you don't get what i mean
um
so let's let's let's just dig into that
because
fine that's immutability it's easy to
say yes there's an inaccessor but the
interesting thing comes as i said from
knowing why
so
this is sharplab
if you haven't seen sharplab before
sharplab is an amazing tool it's a
website written by
a
lovely man just across the pond in new
zealand and what it does is as i type
out code over here
which i will do right now
it is compiling my code
into il and then it is
using sorry using the latest bits of
roslyn
10 essentially and then it is
decompiling my code but it is telling il
spy which is the decompiler it's saying
hey i wrote this code with c sharp 1. so
none of these features
are sort of available to il spy as it's
decompiling so if we look at this record
i've just defined what it does is it
explodes out to well here's our class
car
and there's a bunch of stuff here's our
backing field for our property here's
our property and we can see it has an
internet accessor right that's cool
doesn't really tell us much but okay
if i
create a variable
of this type
i can this is a bit weird but i can set
the property even though it's also set
in the constructor
uh you wouldn't want to do it but you
can
but you can see here this is my object
initializer right this is what it
compiles to it compiles to create a car
and then set the numdos property
the compiler
is allowed to do this because it's the
compiler it knows right it trusts itself
if i paste this over here i'm going to
get
an error so this is the compiler
enforcing hey you've got an init
property here right it says here you
can't just do this
so how does an unit property work well
if we switch to il which is very scary
scary and i don't like doing so i won't
do it again but
if we have a look at what this really
generates and actually you know what i'm
going to change this because
it's too scary for me
i'm just going to make this a uh what
does it say number doors
i'm going to do the old-fashioned way on
a class which means i need to get rid of
that
this is a class with an inner property
uh sorry i'll just go back to the c
sharp just to prove there's no magic
here so this is just got a field
property in it accessor
we'll get rid of all that record junk
if we go down the bottom here's our
properties here's a property called num
doors it's an int now properties if you
didn't know they're really just getting
set methods under the hood so our get
says get them dollars and our set
is
set numbers so in il right in a net dll
there's no such thing as in it it's a
c-sharp compiler thing
uh an init is really just a set with a
hat on and this is the hat
it's a mod rack i have no idea what that
means and
it basically annotates it with this type
and then the compiler knows hey if
something is annotated with this type
it's an init property and so it doesn't
let you send it
so
why is this interesting well there's two
reasons number one firstly
you can use inner properties in your
normal classes right you don't need to
use records to get this feature that's
pretty cool
number two
this type is defined in
dotnet right it's in.net core
i'd know 3.1 or whatever
if you're not targeting.net 3.1 you
can't use init properties
you get an error that says hey there is
no type called is external in it and you
look at that and you're like what the
hell are you talking about well it turns
out if you work out what the compiler
does
you can do this and go public static
class is external in it and
i'm going to get rid of the ielts
computing
if you do that
actually i'm not
if you do this you can use inner
properties if we look down at our
property here you can see our mod rack
now if you were keen eyed this is
actually slightly different before
this said system private core live in
front of it right that's where the type
came from now the type is coming from
our assembly
so we just essentially put in part of
the runtime and uh you know now we can
use inner properties everywhere
it is a little bit tricky in that you
want to be careful making this public
because if you've got something
consuming you that targets 3.1 or
whatever
good question um graeme good question
can you get a property by reflection set
it yes so this is the
the asterisks here for immutability in c
sharp
c sharp loves backwards compatibility in
fact so does all of microsoft
so we don't like breaking people so as
you can see this is a set in il this is
still called set num doors
you can set this in reflection
a
now the good thing about that is it
means that a d serializer will still be
able to set it
so you can use a record or you can have
a class with an inner property and if
you're deserializing it from json or
whatever that's cool your inner
properties still
work they can still be set by the
decompiler but also your immutability
still works
and so you know that you know no one
else can change this property which is
cool
so the one uh
drawback if you like to inner properties
or not not drawback but
there's a bit of a gap still within a
properties which
hopefully will be fixed in future
and that is around nullability so if i
define a class
and i have a nullable string address
then fine we can make that init property
you can only set it during
initialization
uh and that's it it's great
but if i define a non-nullable string
and i don't have a constructor then i
get an error because nothing is
initializing this property which means
its default value is null but you've
said it's not nullable
but you don't want to initialize it
because you want the people to
initialize it and they can't set it like
so it's it's all very
these kind of features kind of bump into
each other
and there's a few ways around it you can
just have a constructor and i mean that
makes sense right if everyone has to set
a name then have it in your constructor
right
the other way around it if you're sure
that someone is going to set the name
like for example if you know your code
and you know for sure this is only ever
going to be used when deserializing um
you know some input then you can sort of
work around the issue so one way is to
assign it to null and then use the
exclamation mark which is the null
forgiveness operator which is the
compiler shut up and get out of my way
operator
and this will work and this just says
here look okay fine i've initialized it
don't worry someone will follow up later
and obviously you could just make it
nullable as well but that's a bit
annoying because then you've got to you
know check for nulls all the time so
what's coming
in c sharp 11 it it recently got cut
from c sharp 10 sadly
is required properties and i mentioned
this because this is just going to make
everything so much nicer and it's really
going to fill in the sort of the
the complete picture here so within it
properties i can say this can only be
set during initialization can't set it
anywhere else with required i can say
this has to be set during initialization
and so that really completes the picture
and then you can really create classes
that you can control
how they're used
fully
when when they use an init property over
a record
i
will leave that question until the last
slide thank you
aaron
um
value semantics so value semantics is
the next property we're going to talk
about next property shouldn't use
property it's really hard to talk about
types and clients and classes and
objects
value semantics is the next feature
we're going to talk about
uh what is value semantics
good question
uh what does this code do right what is
result is it true or false
right who knows no way of knowing um
value semantics will submit the
semantics that we're talking about here
is what does it mean for one thing to be
equal to another thing
i'm going to switch to uh visual studio
for this one
which is over here so
uh feel free to yell at me producers if
i need to zoom i will in fact a little
bit later so i have a different type of
record here called the point and uh i've
constructed a point it's got two
properties x and y right pretty
important
uh i'm actually going to make another
points though
and i'm going to set it to the same
the same values
and then when i do equals here
so
that's p1 equal p2
and i run my code and i look for the
console window hello contour window
there it is that's not the right one
um
oh there it is
sorry that took a while so yes what can
i say
um
so that output's true right those two
points are equal
because they point to the same
point if i change one it's now false
great make
sense if i make this a class
not a glass but a class and i run this
it's still false
right
so
why isn't this
why was it true with a record and why
was it false with class well that's
value semantics so records
have no sense of equality of themselves
they they sort of pass that on to their
constituent parts
um the real answer here is that um
for a class
the default equals does
the default uh equality for a class is
reference equality which means is this
literally the exact same instance right
so what a record does is it does
value equality
the value equality means yeah these
represent the same thing they're still
not the exact same instance right that
second check still returns false but
they mean the same thing
now if you've used struts before structs
also have value or quality
so and this is another thing where
records get weird right what's a record
well it's a class well except it can be
a struct what's cool about records they
have value equality but so destructs but
records can be structs so they already
have it
it's kind of weird
and this is kind of why i didn't want to
answer the when would you use question
because it depends
so
if a struct has value equality i can
achieve value equality now great
uh if a record has value equality i can
use that to get it what about a class
well it turns out you can achieve value
equality very easily you can just
override the equals method
here and i can say return
now i get to type on camera
while making lots of mistakes
and
theta x equals x i'm just gonna
describing oh look thank you intellicode
oh yep
you compile
oh i miss vehicles
no one in the chat is yelling out equals
i'm shocked so
i've just made this class have valuable
quality
so
what's so good about records right like
this is where you have to uh you have to
pick and choose what you're using why
would you want to do it well
so valuable quality is really good in
some circumstances for example a point
class
it's pretty uh well i won't say obvious
but it might be common that uh
we don't care
what instance is what we just care where
is this point in physical space and so
that's what value equality provides
right and so you can achieve all these
things but again it's just
a cool thing to know
so now the question becomes
or rather
back to here whoops nope wrong one there
we go
so value semantics so classes have
reference to quality but you can
implement value equality if you want
structure value equality
records act like structs which is good
so why would you use records well it
turns out records are better at being
struck than structure
so this is a benchmark.net output thingy
and so this is just calling the equals
method and a record
the equals method took 20 nanoseconds i
think this had two in properties it was
basically the point class i had um and a
struct took 340 nanoseconds now
that's a very short amount of time
and 104 bytes allocated is not a lot of
memory but sometimes people can care
about these things
and if you do you might want to choose a
record so
how
is this speed achieved well for that we
have to go back to
sharp lab
and we go back to making this a record
and we go back to c sharp and we look at
the equals method
the equals method in a record
is right here and it does a bunch of
rubbish but essentially it does what i
did in my class it says hey are these
two fields
uh equal
and if i in fact add another field here
uh private print underscore new field
we will see in the equals method
um at the end at the start there is
no let's get hash code sorry
there it is
we will see that it is including new
field in its uh in its equality check so
a record will generate an equals method
that checks every single field and
that's how it does it equality right so
it's the constituent parts a struct on
the other hand and if we look at the
source of net we can find this out so
all structs inherit from value type
which is confusingly a class but ignore
that
value types equals method happens to be
at the top of the file which is very
convenient for me
um and if we look at what it does we get
to this line and
if you know what this line is you'll
know why it's slower right this is
reflection
and if you think about it this kind of
makes sense a struct at run time has to
work out right what fields do they have
okay let me loop through them and and
you know this
this gets the value of both fields and
checks the equals are like it's the same
logic but this is happening at runtime
working out which fields you've got this
is happening at compile time generating
an equals method
so
records
are
sort of i won't say they're cheating um
because they're not but they're a form
of code generation and if you've looked
into source generators and if you know
me you know that i love structures um
that's one of the advantages right is
they can look at your code and they can
do things and therefore can get faster
results
and with expressions uh this is good
we're banging through them hopefully
there's lots of questions waiting for me
maybe please ask questions um
all right with expressions so
here i am defining two cars a honda
res2000 is a car with two doors and a
honda record euro is basically the same
as a honda s2000 but with four doors
now if you know cars you now know what
car i drive
it's not the convertible
so
uh what am i doing here like what is
this new with rubbish
um so what this is doing is this is now
firstly
it's setting a uh
setting a property which well hang on
isn't that illegal because of any uh
properties well
it is but this is another form of
uh initializing types and well it's kind
of the same form this is like an object
expression but with some other stuff but
so what this is doing is saying hey
here's an instance of a car on the
rs2000
take that
make a copy of it and give me a new one
but
set the num doors to four
so it's still initializing our honda
record euro object
it's just that as part of that
initialization we're going to get most
of it
from
the existing object right
so
let's go back to here and we'll zoom the
browser as requested sorry for not
noticing earlier
um
so what are we going to do so here we go
so we have a car
and everything and i'm just going to
so see with
oops
with none doors now this one
is a silly example because car only has
one property but let's just have a look
how it works anyway
uh scroll down here it
is so
this is our with expression now it's not
very clear and you just have to trust me
on that but it is
the way a with expression works is a
little bit more compiler magic where the
compiler gets to cheat so you're not
allowed to set the num doors property in
your code but the compiler can set it in
its code because you know it's the
compiler right so what the compiler does
is it makes a copy of the car and then
it sets the property and then it gives
you back the car you want it now these
variable names get confusing that's
because the compilation doesn't know
your variable names
um
but so it calls this weird clone method
right now so
i did this before and i'll do it again
if we copy the code here you'll find
this is illegal code besides the fact
that carbon exists
um
not only because we're setting the
property which is this error
but the name clone doesn't exist and
there's an end of file expected and
things just get weird and that's because
of this right this is not c sharp code
so what is this nonsense this is what is
referred to as an unspeakable method so
this is a method that is valid in il as
a name but it's not valid in c sharp and
so the compiler uses this all the time
to generate things that it doesn't want
people to call in fact you can see it
right here in the backing fields the
same thing the backing field of a
property is unspeakable because the
compiler doesn't want anyone to be able
to get at it
so why don't we want people to get at
the clone method well in order to
maintain immutability
we have to know
that there is a way to make a 100
percent accurate copy
of this instance right
uh we have
if if the if the act of copying changes
something then that breaks immutability
so the clone method uh is down here it
doesn't look very interesting it just
calls this constructor here's the
constructor it just sets fields
in fact again if i can i can add a field
here as well
[Applause]
yep
you'll see the the new field is here as
well so again all fields get uh
generated into this
but so this
what this means is that there is a a way
the compiler trusts to clone a record
and as soon as it knows well okay if i
can make a faithful copy
and
that means i can set some properties and
that means
i can sort of maintain immunity but
allow for
it's not really modification because
it's always copying but it allows for uh
i guess deriving new instances and so
that's what we the expressions do
so
the other thing with with expressions oh
this is just i love this you can nest
them and it makes for really expressive
code so this is actually from my train
game
it draws a bunch of stuff on the screen
so i have a background and when you
mouse over things i want to hover them
so i can define the hover background and
saying hey the hover background's the
same as the background it just has a
different color
and so then whatever i do with the
background i know hover background will
sort of inherit it right it's not
inheritance but you know what i mean
um and same thing with the colors right
i want light blue but i want an alpha of
85 percent
so it's really nice syntax once you get
to use it
with expressions are
not exclusive to records but they are
exclusive to things the compiler knows
it can copy so in c sharp nine that
means records and in c sharp 10 that
means reconstructs
in c 10 it's also going to be available
on every struct which is pretty cool so
every structure you might have out there
you can now use with expressions
and anonymous types so anonymous types
is another one of these things where the
compiler generates code and since the
compiler generates all of the code for
them it knows it can make a faithful
copy
if we look
let me
make a new anonymous type quickly
the anonymous type here it is
unspeakable names again
right
the anonymous type doesn't have anything
interesting it has an equals method it
has two string like there's nothing here
to clone but because the compiler
generates well essentially all of this
code but it generates this constructor
the compiler is going to uh when user
with expression
it'll just call the constructor of this
type
pass in all of the properties from the
existing one except for whatever you set
on here
unfortunately i can't demo this because
it's version
i don't think sharp web uh this version
this branch is up to date tonight
and unfortunately the master build of uh
royalton is currently failing and um
it's not my fault
all right so that's with expressions
fully customizable so this is the last
my last point uh we're doing well for
time
uh they're fully customizable and so
i'm just gonna go back to here
we've actually seen this already and
we've seen this in basically every
demo i've done
let me get rid of all this stuff in fact
here look i'm customizing a record um
that sometimes gets confused there we go
what the compiler does is it wants to
generate a bunch of code for your record
uh he wants to generate a property
and
what it does is for everything it's
going to generate it checks whether you
have first so here
it would want to generate this numbers
property sorry no it won't wait a minute
[Applause]
now it wants to generate a number of
property but i got there first so it's
not going to so
if i comment out my property here's
another property we get
if i
don't comment out my property
well we still get it but this is mine
now you can't tell because i've done it
the same way but if i change this to a
set
and now this number property has a set
and so this is true of every part of a
record so if you want to change how a
records to string is uh done
you can just
oops
you can just do this
and you can go
oops
you see
and now when we look at the generated
code for a record the two string method
says return in dc
so you can take the bits of the record
you want and if you want to change them
then you just change them what this
means is
you can take this
equals method
and you can put it here
and you can
return false and now you don't have
value or quality anymore right
um and so this is
i mean you probably wouldn't do that
please don't right but this is
where records again they get kind of
weird right a record could be a one-line
declaration that does everything for you
or you could have a 3 000 line file that
has methods and properties and fields
and whatever else any fields you define
the compiler will put in your records
method any uh properties the backing
fields are going right so you can
customize as much as you like
and so that
goes back to the question of you know
when should i use a property method well
see what is a record right a record is
anything you like it can be immutable
and some would argue that it's immune by
default but it's also not necessarily it
can be really simple to declare or you
can declare it in a really
long verbose way
it can have value semantics or it cannot
right so what i like about a record is
that i get to look at how the compiler
team at microsoft who writes c sharp
think a
immutable class should be written and so
i get to look at the get hash code
method and go huh what does this do how
does this work
more importantly i get to not write a
get hash code method because i'm not
smart enough and i don't want my
dictionaries to break right
i get to take advantage of the things
from a record that i want but not get
the things that i don't want
on this though
i strongly recommend if you're going to
do this
that you
invest in
using sharp lab
to uh to have a look at what's going on
i'll give you an example of why
let's just make we're going to make this
a record
that's going to have an
x and a y
uh and we're going to
i don't know let's just we'll define one
property and we'll let the compiler
define the other and we'll try to
correctly
use a cursor
so we have a we have a points got two
properties great
i'm initializing it to one and two great
so what should this output
you would think that it should happen
one and two and it's just building and
it's going to be really slow oh there it
is
but it outputs one and zero
so why is that
so the danger of customizing is that the
compiler
might be doing things you don't know in
this case
uh it's because i never set this
property
now it's gonna be one and two right so
if you're going to customize it please
be careful
but
uh
you can
so
it's kind of nice but it also you know
can be a trap
the compiler does tell you here there's
a little green squiggle and it says uh
the parameter y is unread
so that's nice um
it just it means that the the you
shouldn't necessarily assume maybe that
things are going to keep working the way
you want which is again that's you know
that's why i said you can't tell a
record is immutable well in this case
here's a record with two properties you
can't tell whether one is used or not
and i can't set this so
this record's just fundamentally broken
this y can never be anything but zero
that's not a good thing
um
but anyway whoops hello you're still on
screen
anyway
i guess so records can be anything but
what's sort of important is that you
look that one level let that one level
below what's going on and therefore
you'll know what's going on and
but you can take those bits you can take
the bits you want use them in the class
use them to instruct
you know
change your existing code maybe i don't
know it's up to you
and with that
hopefully someone has some questions
because i
am done but i'm pretty good for time
ah it's just me hello
that's fascinating dave there's uh
a whole lot to learn about the the
c-sharp compiler and and records there
and we do have some interesting
questions actually the first one
comes from aaron powell
and he's asking
when would i use an init property over a
record
yeah
i mean essentially this is up to which
bits do you want if you only want init
properties then
you probably just want to use one and if
you want unit properties and
some of the other stuff records provide
then use records
and my dog agrees um
you um yeah it really just is a matter
of i mean essentially write write down
the pros and cons and pick which column
has the more things and it's very much
case by case
so
no that's cool so the next question is
from harry asking how does inheritance
work with records that's that for me
that's an interesting question as well
what do you think yeah so so inheritance
is is uh
it's
i didn't get into it because it makes
the code well it doesn't make the code
harder to understand but
some of the features of records are the
way they are because of inheritance so
things like the clone method and things
like if you noticed when there was a
two-string method it called something
called print members that is there to
support inheritance and so
if i have a record that inherits from
another record then the two string of
the outer one will call print members on
itself and then print members on the
inner one not two string on the inner
one so the output looks better so
there's a bunch of things around like
yeah with clone especially like with
immutability where they
the code they generate is specifically
to handle inheritance so the answer to
the question is it works totally fine um
you can't inherit
you can't inherit a class from a record
or a record from a class though oh maybe
you can write so you always have to
okay it's registered from a record yes
it's exclusive and again that's because
of those immutability guarantees right
if you could inherit from a class then
that base class could do anything you
want
so um the next question from graeme
greene i think you've already answered
that question before uh can you get a
property by reflection and set it yeah
none of this none of this stuff is
really sort of run time um
effect like there were yeah there is a
slight change to the runtime four
records which is that is external type
but yeah at the end of the day these
classes are just plain old.net classes
you can set properties but then that's
also true with private setters and
private fields and private properties so
that's sort of not you know that's not
new right read only fields same thing
reflection right
yeah you can do what you want
but i think you know in some ways use
records because you sort of would prefer
the generated code it's like you said uh
or showed the one benchmark it's a lot
more optimal to use the generated code
it's smarter you know it's real code
um cool so that sort of segues in the
next question uh
when we combine records
with the with keyword
um and if you have a complex record for
instance it has a dictionary or an i
list a collection
and
and you then with that add another value
to that record
does that complicated type or complex
type get cloned exactly correctly
yes so this is this is uh
yes
sorry no it doesn't um
this is where records get uh a little
bit hairy and in fact so destruct right
there's no deep
cloning ability like there's nothing
baked into.net right
if there was the compiler wouldn't have
had to generate that clone method so
there is no way
to know
essentially know how to clone a
dictionary right we can say i know how
to clone a dictionary because we
understand what the dictionary that's in
the framework happens to do but there's
no guarantees you know someone else
could write a dictionary that does
something different so
no you're not going to get a deep clone
you're not going to get an exact copy
like that so
you know you essentially are copying a
pointer to the same dictionary across to
the new instance um so you do need to be
careful of that you know you can't get
immutability out of mutable things
um that's you know that's just life
essentially uh this isn't gonna this
isn't gonna reinvent the world um so you
do have to be a little bit careful yeah
i wouldn't go i wouldn't suggest going
and changing all of your classes to
records just because you want to
you know
i don't know i don't know why you would
anyway but uh you're probably
um but yeah so you do need to be a
little bit careful um they are
i mean the value of quality thing is
it's
yeah what is the value of a dictionary
right about when you compare two
dictionaries it doesn't compare every
element it doesn't i think and i think
as dot net developers we sort of
understand that that that's different
and so when you think about well how
would that work with valuable quality
well the answer is it doesn't right
which i think makes sense but maybe
so to
so give a recommendation is if you had a
record
uh with an array for instance just a
simple array or something very basic
rather than a dictionary
that cloning would be
more guaranteed or more
correct
yeah definitely i mean so this is sort
of not i guess not relevant to records
really at all but essentially if you're
going for immutable immutability
everything has to be immutable from the
ground up like you just and and you
certainly can achieve immutability
without records like the internet
accessor helps but i mean you can do it
traditional ways right with constructors
and private setters uh you don't get a
with expression but you can make with
methods that do the same thing
cool
that's fascinating david um
thank you very much i think we've all
got a fair bit to take away and learn
from your talk
um
so thank you very much
now uh just everybody to say no we have
the ndc melbourne expo website so andy's
expo.ndcmelban.com
if you go there please sign up you know
check out the sponsors and there's some
great prizes for you to win at the end
of the day there's ubereats vouchers
there's airpods
keep cups xiaomi bands
an apple watch or samsung watches a
whole lot of prizes so
definitely go and check it out
now next i'm going to hand over to my
co-host melissa and she's going to take
us through the developer quiz
thank you melissa
thanks william hi everyone i'm melissa
and i'm a lead software engineer at
azenex and i'm super stoked to be here
coming to you live from melbourne and we
have a
very fun tech quiz it's going to be on
slido so i'm going to activate the quiz
now and if you go to the quiz room on
slido you should be able to join that
and i have my very special quiz master
hat that i will be wearing uh so
register for the quiz and the top three
winners will win a one of these super
awesome ndc hoodies so get your name in
there try to sign up with your twitter
handle your full name some way that we
can reach out to you and know who you
are so we can get you your awesome prize
and do keep in mind that slido uh
the live stream does have a bit of a lag
if you're watching on youtube so watch
everything on slido so that you can get
the questions in right on time
and and then they will come up later on
the live stream so watch as it's going
on slido i see a bunch of people jumping
in there now
as long as we can figure out who you are
and get you your prize if you win that's
all we need to do
cool lots of names popping up get your
names in there now and get ready to
answer some it's going to be a tech
themed quiz so get your cool tech hats
on and get ready to go
cool we have
27 people there's tons of people on this
stream so i think we can go more than
that so wait a little bit more to get
some
more people up on our special quiz
see someone's commenting on my my nice
plants i have around me it's my my
greenery background we were saying
before it might be on like a gardening
show or something like that
so make sure if you're not finding the
quiz go to the the quiz room within
slido enter in there try to enter uh
either your twitter handle or some name
that distinguishes you from other people
so that we can figure out who you are
and get you your prize which would be a
hoodie if you win
cool
so we are at 44 participants
i think that's
getting up there 45.
see
do a little countdown last chance to
join the quiz before i kick it off
okay
okay we got to 50. so i think that's a
good number to to start off the quiz
with you can still join in after it goes
but you have to be quick to answer the
questions remember to watch on slido
because there is a bit of a lag on the
live stream
so
starting the quiz
azure functions natively support any of
the following excepts
what answer do you think it is
get it in quick
cool
we have
76 percent of you were correct
it is c plus so let's see what the
leaderboard is looking like
looks like graham foster is up at the
top so far oh there's a whole bunch of
people it's tons of people um tied
obviously one question but let's see how
we go okay next question get ready
what does link stand for
see the answer is coming in
cool and we have
72 percent of people said language
integrated query 28 said
language interface natural query let's
see what it is
good one
cool
who is at the top
pk and a whole bunch of other people
tied for its top place hopefully we can
get some questions wrong so there's a
distinguished distinguishing people up
at the top there so next question
who is known as the father of the world
wide web
you have 20 seconds
cool looks like lots of people said tim
brenner's lee is that correct
and it is
yeah who's at the top now
still tons of people tied and we got
lots of winners so far so hopefully uh
hopefully we can get this going
get some free hoodies out there for you
all
so what does mpeg file extension stand
for
i think this is a difficult one
i can see the the
votes coming in all spread around
cool so there's a bit of a tie there is
it
motion picture export graphic or is it
moving picture experts group let's see
what it is
and the moving picture experts group is
the correct answer
they're actually the ones who defined
the extension standards
which is pretty interesting i just
learned that recently
so we still got a whole bunch of people
outside for first place i don't know how
many hoodies we have that we might have
to procure a whole bunch more to get the
to get all the winners some hoodies
cool
so this this one i think you might be
able to get let's see what html tag can
you use to apply css rules to a document
cool
all right looks like most people are in
it is style
cool a leaderboard still tons of people
tied for first place i think um it's
showing the people who are the fastest
at the very top so that'll help us
distinguish who gets the hoodies
next question get ready
who is considered the world's first
computer programmer
let's see how well do you know your
computer science history
the thing i love about this question is
that all of these options are wonderful
women in computer science and women in
tech
and the correct answer
is
otta lovelace so well done to 72 percent
of people let's see if it's
distinguished our leaderboard
cool we got pk and matt fighting out at
the top
get ready next question
what does sdlc stand for
so you get some looks like you get some
extra points for speed so you gotta be
really quick to answer the questions
there
cool looks like most people
have got it
were we correct nice good job everyone
software development lifecycle is what
it is go to the leaderboard who is the
quickest to get in there so pk matt's
still battling out at the top but pk is
winning this time
cool where is developers developers
developers from
i like this question
this one is one of my favorite questions
where do you think it might be from
let's see if you know your tech
conferences and software history
cool so there's a bit of a split
a big portion said from a microsoft
developer conference and the other
fortune says the tech conference known
as ddd which is correct
is actually from a microsoft developer
conference when the ceo went developers
developers developers go find that gif
and that mean out on the internet it's
awesome and that's where ddd conference
actually got their name from but it
originated at the microsoft conference
so well done 58 percent of you that got
that correct
and leaderboard still matt and pk
battling out at the top getting in there
quick with your reaction times
next question which programming language
came first
so again you got to know your computer
science history on this one
cool answers in this one looks like was
a bit more tough a bit more spread out
between all the different answers so was
it the top two are pl1 and fortran which
one came first
and the answer is fortran
pl1 is programming language one but it
unfortunately was not the first one if
you look at the history fortran actually
came first
and leaderboard says russ now jump to
the top with the quickest time that's
awesome good job russ
cool just one more question left you can
win
what did ndc originally stand for see
how well you know this conference that
you are constantly you're
in tuned into right now
last question get it in quick try and
win your your hoodie top three winners
will get an awesome
hoodie
cool and time's up
let's see who our winners are
so it stands for norwegian developers
conference because it originated in
norway so we have some awesome people
currently behind the scenes located in
norway helping us out so thank you team
and overall winner russ well done you
got to the top in the end
nice congratulations russ
congratulations graham foster and
congratulations reuben all three of you
win a hoodie actually i just got word
that we can actually give out four
hoodies so vats you get an extra hoodie
as well well done everyone
good job team
so thanks for participating in the
awesome ndc melvin tech quiz and now we
have an awesome video and words from our
sponsors
i love running this company i love
running it because of the people i deal
with
it's such a great team of people from a
career perspective it's the best move i
ever did being a great consultant which
we are the cw is half half between
technical skills and communication
[Music]
it's given me the opportunity to work
with lots of different types of
technology and explore some stuff that i
maybe only dabbled in at university or
before ssw is a company that makes
enterprise software solutions
and that's what we do we build software
for clients on demand we build bespoke
solutions using the latest technology
and the latest best practices i've been
involved in the development of some
mining software being involved in the
development of software for a legal firm
and everything in between there even in
just under two years i've been working
across so many different projects
it's just a really great place to come
into and i always look forward to coming
to work
[Applause]
[Music]
as an investor or wealth professional
you want a wealth provider that is
flexible smart and tech savvy
a provider with fresh eyes who sees
opportunity to present wealth solutions
differently
a partner who can administer wealth your
way
netwealth was created with an
entrepreneurial spirit to do all of this
we exist to help you see your wealth
differently to realize your potential to
inspire you to discover a brighter
future
at our call we are a technology company
a super fund an investment specialist an
administration business
but in our daily lives we are you
moms and dads call centre operators
sales and marketing professionals
analysts netball teams friends
technologists developers and most
importantly family
to investors we provide award-winning
superannuation and investment accounts
products and services
to wealth professionals we provide a
market-leading platform to better their
business
underlying all of this is cutting-edge
technology anywhere everywhere
with us you can see your wealth
differently and more positively we
identify new opportunities with our
fresh perspective and natural curiosity
we provide choice through our flexible
approach to business and product design
we prioritize your security to give you
peace of mind
we are involved in your world in schools
we support financial literacy helping
our younger australians also see wealth
differently
we are a team of talented people working
hard to make life better for more
australians
we are creators
we are curious always looking to spot
the change that matters
we are authentic and genuine
we believe that strength is in teamwork
we are agile and nimble upbeat energetic
and optimistic about the future
with us you can see wealth differently
because we are different in our approach
our attitude our commitment and our
spirit
partner with us to see what's possible
[Music]
all right welcome back that was uh i
love that quiz that was awesome and
there was just a couple of questions in
there that were just a little bit harder
just to kind of throw people off but we
still had four people that got all of
them all right so well done everybody
and you get a hoodie yay
now i should just mention again please
go to the
expo.ndcmelban.com website and sign up
for prizes just check out our sponsors
because we wouldn't be here without them
so and you might even win a prize from
it so do that
and um
someone was asking about the agenda for
the entire day the agenda is on
ndcmelbourne.com
and you can check it out there to see
when the breaks are on who else is on
um but next up
we have michelle mannering and she's
also known as the hackathon queen or the
queen of github hello michelle how are
you
hey how's it going
good now rumor has it that you have a
particularly rare uh sample of github
stickers with octo kitty
now is that
uh i do not know what you seek but i
have a very large collection of stickers
with lots and lots of octocats so
um that's awesome hopefully when we go
back to irl events if you ever see me i
always have a big stash of stickers on
me so please always ask i'll always be
happy to give you lots of github
stickers
now you heard it here um now i believe
that you are today going to give us a
bunch of tips and tricks and hidden gems
on how to use github a lot better
that is correct super excited
that's awesome now i am going to monitor
the questions uh in slider as they come
in and we might take those at the end or
and as you prefer you can also
you know interact with the youtube chat
as well we're pretty informal here so um
i will let you do your thing and um
thanks again mish
sounds fantastic thank you so much for
that wonderful introduction really
excited to be here with you all it's
super great to see the chat popping off
i love watching that quiz and seeing
people get things right or wrong i
i'm from new south wales so i was like
oh somebody clicked new south wales
ndc like yay new south wales represent
uh so it's really exciting um the talk's
been great so far and i hope this one is
going to be
just as awesome for you i will be
watching the youtube chat at the same
time um so feel free to comment i might
i might make comments of what you're
saying as well uh but feel free to
comment on um things as we go away or
say hi
and we'll take questions at the end from
slido
so let's jump into it right so get up
like a bus so lots of people will say oh
you know mitch what are some of your top
tips doing github so this is going to be
what they are now um also i just
realized i didn't change my title on
that one i am now the developer advocate
not developer community manager i was
one oversight id that's all good uh so
if you haven't seen me around or heard
from me i am mish uh also known as mish
manners online as i said also hackathon
queen because i've run a multitude of
hackathons now but if you are looking
for you can find me on pretty much any
social media platform known to men
you can find me on
twitch streaming both coding and video
gaming obviously you can follow me on
github and plenty of other places as
well
i'm on the deaf role team at github as i
said my title is now developer advocate
which literally changed like a week ago
which is why i haven't changed that one
um but yeah i'm the developer advocate
at uh github on the dev roll team we
have a few of us in australia now which
is really exciting
and it's such a great company to work at
but also an awesome product that we have
so i'm here today to talk to you about a
bunch of top tips on how to use github
how to get up like a boss and then we'll
also have a demo as well something that
um is really fun i'll show you some of
the ways that i use github pretty much
on a daily basis so
all the things i'm talking about are
things that i do every day
things that we use all the time and i
hope they're really exciting and useful
for you too
i just love michelle's comment in our
chat actually like has all the
stickers um last time i did catch up
with michelle she did get lots of
stickers so um
can confirm it's a thing
uh but today's top tips um i've broken
them up into a couple of sections
um so the first one we'll talk about is
personalization so how to actually
personalize github for you
next one is collaboration github is very
much known as this social coding
platform
so um yes there'll be a lot of
collaboration happening here uh talk
about the way that not just the way i
work but the way that you can work on
github and and i mentioned a demo as
well
now i've seen some couple of um comments
in the chat about the laptop with
stickers that is actually my laptop um
so yes when you do save it in person
that is literally what it looks like
okay so the first thing on github is
personalization
so
i love legos i always try and fit a
photo or something about lego into my uh
presentation so i thought about this one
so in the same way you would customize
like your lego models and you build
something um and something that's really
you you can customize your github
profile too
now one of the first things to do that
is similar to the way you do a social
media profile so when you open up a
social media account for the first time
some of the first things you might do is
go in add a profile picture write a bit
about yourself and just kind of like set
it up a little bit uh well you can do
that now on github too so we have this
new thing called um a profile readme so
not only can you add really cool things
like a profile photo and that now you
can now add a readme to your actual
github profile and the cool thing about
this is that you can add
anything you like to showcase you you
can add a fire of yourself you can add
um some of the top project you're
working on you can add um some links to
like maybe a website that you write
about articles that you're doing um you
can obviously write some code in here
the whole thing's written in markdown so
the sky is really the limit here in
terms of a github profile
so in order to create a profile readme
all you need to do is um create a
repository that is the same name as your
username and when you do that you'll see
that you've like a little thing will pop
up here saying you've created a special
repository now you can you know
showcase this on your profile as it read
me as i mentioned it's all written in
markdown so anything you can add into
marketing pretty much adding to her
profile um so that includes um things
like gifts this is monica's one she's
got like a cute little gift here of her
optical which i really love and i loved
it so much
i added it to mine as well
you can add
images and you can even add um as i said
it's coding so you can add all these
really funky things at code uh one thing
i've seen a lot of people add on their
profiles now is games so they'll use
github actions to set up a game that's
running on their profile and you can
jump in and be part of that game uh
which is really really fun and i say
phil dash has said that some people have
forked his um profile really um which is
generally confusing
uh it kind of is but i'll show you a
little bit about that too we can jump
onto phil's one later um but often when
i'm looking for something people say
what's up some of the best things to do
for a profile readme and to set up one
of the cool things to do is to just look
around on github and when you see a cool
profile um
i often just click the edit button to
see how they've actually done it and
when you click the edit button it forks
there um that that repo so then you can
actually have a look at it copy some of
the code um as phil said it kind of kind
of has a little bit confusing because
like why is somebody forking my personal
repo but it's because they they like
what you're doing and therefore they
want to do the same
so that's one really good way about
going into um build your profile reviews
see what other people do
uh the next one about really customizing
things is something that not a lot of
people don't get um
i often forget about it and then i'll
come back to it after a while like well
that's a good thing to remember um it's
the notifications um we've changed the
way notifications work quite a lot um so
notifications if you haven't um see them
for a while if you go into like just
github.com and you're signed in you'll
see there's like a little bell at the
top and that is your notifications um so
you can click that and if you haven't
been on there for a while you can click
that bell and it'll say like hey would
you like to clean up some of these
notifications i've been on here for a
while um but one of the cool things that
we've changed recently with
notifications is a better way to filter
them so because i not just work at
github but i have a lot of
organizations and teams that i'm part of
on github sometimes i want to see
certain things i want to be able to
filter certain things so for example
when i come in on a monday i don't want
to see all this stuff from all my
weekend projects or open source teams
that i'm working with i just want to see
stuff from my github org so i can go
into the notifications i'm filtered by
the organization i can say yeah just
show me stuff from github or from
michael i wonder what my
teams specifically say be dougie i
wonder what vdoggies um
got for me so i can go and filter by
author as well so i can go and filter
that down so i can really help mention
my notifications
which is really cool
um the next one is reminders and
reminders are really good way to control
the way you work again i don't always
want reminders um for all my orgs so we
can uh set up reminders specific to each
org that you're part of um and what you
can even do is that reminders that um
are linked into slack so i'm integrated
into slack so i can set up a reminder to
say like hey if i haven't touched this
issue in a few days send me a reminder
um on slack um you can set up things
like sleepwater as well which tells you
like hey no one's touched this issue for
14 days it's gonna close if no one does
something to it um so you go to your
profile
um go and choose the organization team
that you're part of and click on
settings and set different reminders
that you need
and really help take control of your
work that way um so i said you can
connect into slack too and you can set
um organization settings so for example
if i only want to see
um slack notifications my github org i
can send them to my github slack or if i
want to set them for my open source blog
i could set them to my open source team
on slack um which is really really
awesome and i see people already
stalking one another on how to do stuff
so um i love that um so aaron's got a
github action on his profile um to
update his review whenever he publishes
a blog post i really love that and i'll
show you some of the actions i have
running on my profile as well
um now talking about personalization of
github before we jump into a few other
features
one of the things that people really
really ask for and something that we
launched last year um at universe you've
probably seen this gif making its way
around the installed video making its
way around uh this is one of our most
loved tweets when we put it out last
year um at universe was our github dark
mode which is super exciting because um
like many people i was also using a um
like an extension fun fact the extension
i was using was open source to available
in github uh but yeah i wasn't using
extension but now we have dark mode um
available natively in github which is
really awesome so if you haven't seen it
you can go to your profile and you can
flip across um up the top
um on your above your readme profile and
you can flip to darkmoon um and if you
want to go into a little bit more if
you've already used that feature um you
can flip it up in your repository or you
can even go into your settings as well
we also have a new dim mode as well so
if you go into um your profile settings
you'll see uh there's also a dim mode so
you can have like a dark mode like a
high contrasty type dim mode or you can
have light mode um now because i am a
huge fan of dark mode where possible i'm
gonna be using dark mode for the rest of
this presentation and when we do the
demo i'll be using dark mode as well
so next one is collaboration so here's a
few ways to collaborate on github now
one of them is project boards so this is
our project board um that is publicly
available and it shows all our public
roadmap and our project was a really
great way not just for tracking overall
progress of a project but it's a really
good way for developers and
non-developers to work together so with
the project board you can link to
different issues you can add notes um
and it's just a really really great way
to collaborate and it's something that i
really love
something that is also coming you is a
new way to see and view projects so um
this is
currently available in public beta so
for example instead of just having the
overall board you can now add and track
specific issues and see their status
their assignees um you can see you can
add different um categories that you
want to add and filter by and then once
you've got this kind of like project
board type thing set up
you can create different
um views and things that as well so for
example if i like this game loop view i
can go and add that um as a new view
here which is really cool so i can
change that to a new view and i can
always have that done you can view
things as tables and boards and this
this stuff is like super exciting these
are some new things that are coming
um another new thing that is coming
which is built into the project side of
things is task lists so when you create
an issue now and you've got a list of
tasks that you want to do you can go in
and um convert those tasks to issues and
then as you close them they'll get
ticked off on the original uh issue
which is really exciting because lots of
people often go in and start planning
for a project they'll like write a whole
list of tasks and go hey we need
actually
issues each one of these tasks so now
you can go and automatically do those
so as i said those um those couple of
features are coming soon you can
actually go in right now and sign up for
um the beta on those um i'll show you
where to do that that's just on our um
our
page for this um new project planning
stuff which is really cool
um so another way to collaborate really
well with people on github is
discussions um so if you haven't used
discussions at all or you're not part of
a an open source repo that is using
discussions discussions are really
really fun
so with discussions you can talk about
different things and discuss uh certain
issues now the reason one of the reasons
we've decided well one of the reasons
discussions exist is because often if
you have a look back at issues you'll
look at some issues and go
wow
that thing really wasn't an issue
because an issue was really designed for
like you know telling people what issues
are whether it's a feature you want or
bug fix or things like mostly bug fixes
right so
often people go oh you know we want this
you know new feature request it ends up
becoming this giant big conversation
like why isn't this in a forum type
thing so now you can have a discussion
about that
um and if you ever find that your issues
are becoming too much of like a
conversationally type thing you want to
make it into a discussion um you can so
you can just go in and you can convert
an issue um into a discussion this year
we've got issues i'm like oh yeah um
this would be really cool we should just
convert it into discussions literally a
button that says converse into
discussion super easy um so it's really
exciting so discussions can be enabled
at a repository level and some of the
other project you type things that i
mentioned like having that big giant
project board um that has to be enabled
at the organization level so you can
then track projects across different
orgs but discussions is specific for
each repo so you can set up a discussion
for each repo if you like
um another thing that we have that we
just launched um publicly in beta on the
23rd of june and is now accessible all
public repos is issue forms so
if you are a maintainer of a project or
um you've got a team and you're like
okay every time i get my team to submit
an issue about a bug or a feature like
half the stuff isn't filled out and no
matter how
much i create a really cool template for
them to use
the half the stuff just isn't filled out
so what we've done is we've created this
single issue forms so if you want
specific things to be
added into the form um compulsory uh you
can now add those in you can add tick
boxes you can add bullet points you can
add like little description boxes you
can add categories and things like that
so it's kind of like a google form but
it's built into issues which will make
make uh things a lot easier for
maintainers and like team admins and
things to start collecting information
so
um it's really cool this is something
that will um go through a little bit in
the demo too
so as i said that was publicly available
to um all publicly accessible repos as
of the 23rd of june it's currently in
beta so if you have
if you are using this or you end up
using it after this talk um please give
us feedback we love your feedback so
i'll show you where to do that too
now i'm going to dive into we've talked
about some of the new features and
things that have came up um come up from
like using github i'm going to talk
about some of the ways that not just we
use github but i use it firstly every
day in a way a lot of our users use
github and also some of the ways that
you might want to think about using
github if you really want to take your
github usage to the next level
so the first one is github for mobile
now i
love github for robots it allows you to
take github with you literally wherever
you go um so it's available on both ios
and android and since it's available on
both those platforms it's not just
available on say your mobile phone you
can also use it on your ipad
now what i like about github for mobile
is it allows you to do a whole bunch of
different things like quickly comment on
issues reveal bug fix merge code there's
even discussions on mobile so we have a
look at a couple of the mobile screens
like say for example this is a home
screen um so
in the morning like say on a monday
morning i wake up i roll out of bed um
actually i don't even roll out of bed
i'm still in bed but i check my phone uh
but i can roll over in bed pick up my
phone open up github and see all right
what issues
have been assigned to me this week now
it's monday my time um so it's usually
like sunday still in the us um but we
have a whole lot of github actions set
up to automatically open certain issues
at the start of a week so i can wake up
roll over click on my issues and see
what has been assigned to me um for that
week without even having to get out of
bed uh before i make breakfast which is
really cool um i could also have a look
at like what couple requests i made
might have missed from like an open
source project or something i was
working on over the weekend um and i can
really just like look at all these
different things and like have a really
good sense of what's happening now i
can't just i don't just have to do this
in bed obviously we've been locked down
something anyway um but it's really
useful when you're traveling on the go i
don't always have to pull out my laptop
i can be sitting at a cafe um or an
airport and it's just like really really
easy
time to check uh there's also a couple
other cool things on the mobile app like
github explorer so you can see like um
featured repositories and featured
trending things you can see like we've
got some coding interviews and stuff um
and there's even some new things that
you can see like all our release notes
straight on mobile now which is really
really awesome i like real nasties like
actions to open weekly issues sounds
really interesting it's actually really
really useful um so no one from my team
has to go and open an issue at the start
a week it's just automatically done for
us um which is really great
now the other cool thing about mobile is
we're always shipping new features to
github um github for mobile so there's a
couple of new things that we've shipped
kind of recently as i mentioned release
floats um but now there's a whole lot of
new ways to filter things on mobile
which makes it really really easy now
going back to that whole idea of
personalization being able to filter and
manage your notifications be able to
filter all this stuff on mobile is super
awesome so i can filter issues by um
like labels assignees i can filter
issues um by like multiple labels as
well um which is really cool because i'm
saying um greatly improved since your
last user app as i mentioned but always
updating mobile so if you haven't um
updated mobile in a while go and update
it um i think the last time i gave this
talk it was like a month ago and we've
already updated it since then so this is
new since that last talk that i gave a
month ago um and the other cool thing
about some of these filterings is i'm
just looking at the gift now you can
actually filter by emojis which is
really cool so if you want to filter by
like oh which issues have give me a
thumbs up go check it um so as um
as you mentioned yeah we do a lot of
updates to mobile so go and check them
go and check it out download github for
mobile if you don't have it
or go and update it um if you've already
got it so it's a really great way to
just use github on the go as i mentioned
uh it's on ios and android so you can
have it on both phone ipad tablet
whatever you're using which is really
cool
um another way that i like to use um
github is github for desktop or github
desktop which is available on windows
and mac os now the reason i like github
for desktop is it's a really good way to
manage your repos and when you're
working on a local
um
like piece of code or like a local
repository a local get environment get
off a desktop is a really really good
way to manage that and see what you need
to pull in or push out
um as a like a non-developer by
background um i love this because like
i'll pop into github for desktop after
i've made some changes it'll be like
this big blue button that says hey
you've got changes to push or you've got
things to pull in
and it's really really great i love it
so
um
github desktop is awesome and obviously
same thing when you're pushing
online um when you're making changes and
you're about to update your your main
branch you'll see that um you can see
all the changes that have been made to
each file there
which is something i really like so
again we're always making changes to um
desktops if you've got the desktop
version go and check it out and make
sure you're up to date
um
so if you
are not super into github for
mobile or get off a desktop um or you
are a bit sick of using github.com
there's three ways um you can use github
the fourth way which is our github cli
this is something again we launched last
year and is constantly in development
and there's so many exciting things that
always being done to the github cli uh
but developers are loving the cloud
because it allows you to work seamlessly
in one window um you can do so many
things on the cli you can create
edit view issues you can check out pr's
you can merge pr's you do my personal
favorite which is coin repos um you can
now manage all your ssh keys from cli as
well which is really um really really
useful
so um yeah it's available on windows mac
os and linux so it doesn't matter what
platform you're using um the cli is
amazing um and fun fact about the cli is
the cli is actually open source so if
you want to contribute to the cli you
can um obviously there's no obligation
for youtube but it's a really fun uh
product use i've been using it quite a
lot as well
so speaking about using things quite a
lot um i thought i'd talk a little bit
about and show you a demo about how i
like to use github um this is how i use
github on my live streams how to use get
help in my daily work it's super fun
so i'm gonna switch to a demo so if the
team is stream yard can put me on full
screen
um so i can stop sharing this screen and
go start sharing a new screen
um
and then give me a second before i
actually show everything because right
now there's gonna be some funky
inception stuff going
on um all right
let's pop that over there
and then
cool so now you should be able to see
my screenshot awesome sweet so this is
github
obviously uh use it in dark mode which
is really fun
um so this is by github profile readme
and there's a whole lot of cool things
going on in here now as i mentioned you
can add lots of different things to your
profile readme so i thought i might just
go really briefly through some things
i've got
um so i've got a gif which is really fun
people ask me where i got this gift made
it is actually a gift of my room as you
can see um some of the things in here
are obviously show up in the image i got
that done on fiverr so i'm not an artist
go to fiverr if you want really good
stuff um i added a bunch of social media
links these are just little images
another gift so if you want a github
octocat like this you can go to my
octocat
generator and build your own octa-cat
um so i will pop this link in the chat
to everyone so you can go and build your
own oxycats and go click get started i'm
just gonna move this
over to the side
and
you can go and build your own opt cap
which is really really cool um this is
something we launched a couple years ago
now people absolutely love it you can go
in and change different things and
colors and add funky tops and do all
kind of fancy things so that's how you
get that one
uh the next slide is github skyline so
if you haven't checked out um skyline
our skyline got a lot of hype
when it went live um
it feels like we did a lot last year um
so if you chuck in your username into
the little bar here and click create
skyline you'll see a 3d contribution
graph of your github
contributions which is really awesome
so you can grab this you can flip it
around there's some cool music i've got
muted at the moment
if you want to grab a quick gif of this
you can turn the ui off and just see it
like that um you can also download the
stl file so you can go and 3d print it
yourself like this
um or you can go and get it printed by
someone else as well so that's really
cool um then there's some bunch of
github stats and things and i also have
some github actions writing on my
profile so this is a little snake um it
comes my profile so each every six hours
i've set this action to generate a
contribution graph
of the last herb along and then the
snake comes along and eats it
if you want to know how to do that i
wrote a dev post on how to do that so i
will grab that one for you and pop that
in the chat so this is something that i
set up and um well i didn't set this up
sorry um something that i wrote um on
dev2 and somebody else created this
amazing action i wrote a tutorial on how
to actually put it in um so you can see
here how to have an awesome profile and
i've linked back to here um which is the
person who created if you ever share any
open source
stuff
um or anything that someone else has
created comment go and um shout them out
this is a nice thing to do so i've added
them in here which is really cool um
there's a bunch of codes for this
profile one there's a bunch of code
snippets on how to create an amazing
profile
so on to github itself so
one of the ways i love to use github
every day
is when i'm either coding or i want to
add some changes to a repo
um what i'll do is i'll often come into
github see which roof i want to do make
sure it's cloned onto my personal
computer use vs code make some changes
and then push that all up to github now
i'm going to show you the process i used
to do that and some of the different
github features because i'm one of those
people that likes i like using all the
things um so when i use github today i'm
using
the desktop the cli
the web and you can choose which way you
want to use it as well
so i have this repo set up called github
like a boss it's a public repo that we
use to do a whole bunch of demos and
cool things like that so say if i wanted
to make some changes just read me i
could obviously click edit and make some
changes but what if i want to do it on
my personal machine first and then make
some changes and then add it to
um the rainbow some of the ways i would
do that is to make sure i have this repo
on my personal computer first now the
way i'm going to do that is i'm going to
use the cli and i'm going to make sure
that i've got the github cli installed
first by typing gh into
my terminal of choice
and seeing if i've got it installed so
obviously it's installed and there's a
new version available and literally i
used this last like a few days ago so
there's new versions all the time i can
go grab the new version or i can just
keep using it um right now if i like so
i'm just gonna keep using it for the
moment so what i need to do is i need to
cd into location where all my repos are
stored on my public computer and that is
not it that's my ndc file um but if i go
to my documents i've got a folder here
called git repos
so we're going to cd into that location
and we're going to clone the repo into
here
so if we go
into this location
and then we're just going to go to h
repo clone hopefully this is big enough
for everyone i'll make it bigger no um
so do you hate triple coin and then
because you're using the github cli
already you don't need to write github
for this you just need to write the name
of the uh repost if i was creating a
github repo it would be github slash
github if i was working
um on our organization level um but this
one's my personal account so it's just
mitch manners and it's github like up
boss is the name of the radio now if i
hit that and enter it'll say it's
cloning
and it'll say done sweet so now if i go
over to my folder
should have here beautiful we can see
it's got a little
one drive spinning thing which means it
just got added
uh now the way i like to use these is to
open them up in um an editor of choice
my editor of choice is bs code this is
something i was working on a little
while ago um when i say a little while
ago i literally yesterday so i'm just
going to close this folder so i can open
up a new one and all i can do is i can
drag this folder that i've just cloned i
can dump it into
vs code and then it'll beautifully add
everything in with all my nice um
my nice files and everything all right
here
so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna make a
change to the readme here so let's just
say i've got ndc talk here
um and they say melbourne and
um so i've got like an image here so
this can have like a boss i usually put
like where this talk is being given so
let's just say
this one
i'll just make a small little change
i'll save that
now how do i know that it has been added
to
my
um reaper in the cloud if i go back have
a look
and we click on refresh we'll scroll
down and there'll probably be nothing
there because right now the change is
just made on my computer so the way that
i want to make sure that's updated i
like to use github um desktop so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to open up
this folder this local folder in desktop
i'm going to add that repository
and sweet so it's already picked up that
i've made a change so we can see i've
made a change here it's online 45 it's
in the readme file and i want to commit
that change to my main branch so i can
go commit so now it's committed but it's
not pushed up to the class that's
committed is my get on my local machine
and now what i'm doing is commit that to
the um the clouds i can click push
origin
and it'll do some fancy things and it'll
say yes you're all done which is awesome
now what happens if i make a change once
let's refresh that whatever happens if i
make a change on
um
on the clouds let's just make a change
uh let's make a real small one
let's go
show some tips and tricks digging delays
and
sometimes
even see a demo
so let's commit that
directly to the main branch
cool
uh so someone's asking well oh i knew i
would get a question about my vs code
theme
um i'll jump into that in a second all
right so let's go to desktop and let's
have a look if there's been any changes
made so it should
give it a second and my internet will
work which should say
there has been a change made on the
machine and actually
let's have a look here
uh it's taking a little bit but let's
open up vs code
actually you know what so
since aaron already asked what theme is
this
this is a really cool theme um
for bs code it's called biggest code
fortnite theme
um i think it was sarah hernandez she
was like this is the most useless um
open source project i've ever shipped
and it's a fortnight theme you can even
have like clouds and chickens and
if you set it up you can even have a
llama running across your screen but um
i just have the colors because i i
really like it
um
so let's make a tiny change in here
and i'll show you what happens if i try
and make a change on my local
and try and push it up so if i go commit
and
it should
make uh there we go it's give me an
error which is perfect that's what i
want so it says desktop is unable to
push commits to this branch because
there are commits on the remote they're
not present local you need to fetch
these before reconciling them so we'll
grab them
so this is why i like desktops it does
all these things so you don't have to
think like oh what's there or what's
that command for that thing or
get push merged i don't know what it is
so this is a really good one if you're
getting non-developers to work with you
as well um i just like it because it's
got great ui
um
please don't hear the llama
no i don't have the llama um i totally
did not get the lava
okay perfect that's all done and changed
which is awesome
um now one thing that we also shipped
really recently that i want to show you
before i jump back into a couple of the
other features
um was
this cool thing here so if i got a
repository that i've been working on
um so b doggie and i did this really
cool like get twitch
um
thing where we built a um chatbot
interaction between github and twitch
and i fought this repo and we worked on
it for a while now i haven't worked on
this for a little while which is why i
had to scroll quite down quite a bit now
if i have a look at this it says
my branch is seven commits ahead of the
main but it's now eleven commits behind
b doggies branch
um this is i love this ui github's it
tells you like what's
like how far ahead or behind you are and
it's got this brand new button if you
can see i'm going to zoom in a bit more
that says fetch upstream so i'm going to
click that and now i can just open a
pull request straight from here um which
is really cool so if you've been working
on something for a little while um and
you have worked on it and you come back
to it you're like oh i wonder if i um
help if i'm ahead or behind or what's
happening so you can go and fetch that
in now which is really cool
uh that was just like i really want to
show off because it's just it's really
cool now i thought the other things i
wanted to talk about with some of the
new um issues stuff that we show i'm
just going to keep an eye on something
about 10 minutes left for demo
um so i talked about one of the new
issues we talked about one of the new
features we talked about with issues is
being able to create form um task lists
will come to forms instead of create
task lists
um for ad issues so say i wanna
um like you like my setup so let's um
mish wants a new setup
okay
here are the things i need for my new
setup in my room
all right i need a new christianity in
your computer i actually don't need a
new computer let's just say i need a new
computer um i need some lights
and
i want maybe some new
i always thought something wrong with
peripherals i knew i'd spell that wrong
it's always ph okay that's uh smaller
okay cool let's go
so that's a pretty good overall project
now obviously if i was running a bigger
project or um if i was setting up a new
house for example this let's be a lot
longer but the purpose of this then
we're just gonna do three things
okay submit your issue so there we go
other guys this is pretty cool and i'm
like oh i actually want to build my own
computer for this so i'm probably gonna
need a list design style list now one
thing i could do is obviously go
edit and add like a
another layer of list and maybe add like
a bullet points but is this probably not
going to be what i want so let's cancel
that
um that's not really what i want but oh
actually what's this new thing okay i
can convert this to an issue so let's go
and convert that to an issue
oh look there's an issue oh i say what
issues all these things
okay so now i can go into here
and go oh look there's a new issue
that's being created sweet there's no
description because obviously it just
creates it with blanks let's go right my
new computer
i want to be really bold i want a 3080
rtx ti graphics card
i want 64 gig of ram
um i also might want to buy a
heat sink
i'll do for the moment i won't get too
greedy right now
um gold for australia yes go for us so
say i've got these things and i'm like
cool um this task list is now done so
say i bought all these things it'd be
really ambitious you can see the
progress bar at the top here is telling
me how many tasks i've completed and
also telling me where this issue is
being tracked so say this issue is
tracking another issue and i can hover
over that i can see the things there
so say i've done that so all three tasks
are done now what if happens if i go
back to that issue
um
would that issue be ticked off as
complete for that thing now obviously i
need to refresh
um but it should
be tracking it then sometimes it works
sometimes not um there we go so i'm
going to take that off there we go one
of three tasks then i can go into my
lights
go cool all right what lights do i want
here um let's go i want the new elgato
ring light
some nano leaves
like that some wi-fix lights maybe a
phillips hue
and then put them all in our
googleness using
home assistant
today with github access
wait
um sounds pretty cool so let's tick all
those off
um i won't take off the last one because
that is actually a um a live stream that
i'm eventually going to be doing very
soon i've got i bought a google nest and
using home assistant some fancy kind of
actions i get up to manage shopping
lists you laugh but i actually use
github to manage my shopping list um
which is really exciting
um
sounds exciting i don't know all right
let's go i want to show you about how to
do this um the issue forms because this
one's really exciting um we'll just do
them directly in github just uh um
for fun because i can show you the
previews as we're going
but i set up one before here this little
test file here what i can do is i can
set up an issue form now if you haven't
used issue templates or issue forms
before um issue your issue templates
lives under your github and this
volatile issue template that means
whenever i open up an issue and i see
like these things here these are all the
templates here
let's say we want to create a template
um we want a new we want to build a new
issue form so the issue forms are run on
yaml files so let's go add a file create
new file
um and we're going to call this um
request demo i want to i'm going to
build a form for rooks this is my github
like a boss i want to build a form for
requesting um a live demo um and i'll
just do a really short one so we can
jump into a couple of questions
um so say what this one we want
um request a demo on this
um
that did not work out there we want
credit
there we go perfect so it says now i was
like why is it not popular
this is an issue template need help
check out the documentation um now we
can obviously preview that but it's um
it's in yum also
that's all good so let's go we want a
description here oh maybe it's a little
bit bigger so you can actually see it
uh let's go right we want a description
and we're going to call this
um
ask
to
demo
something
get hobby
i'm just reading some of the comments as
i'm going
um title
um let's go
request
and then whatever the title is
types in
and we want we can add labels to it as
well so we want
labels um what are the labels i've got
in this one
um
let's have a look
uh labels so i've got bug documentation
enhancement
well let's just put money as twitch
which will do
labels and we'll go
twitch and maybe
it's not feature enhancement just spell
that right you might probably cody
always spell things wrong
signings i will assign myself to it
perfect all right so we want the body of
[Music]
so we want this issue to be um done and
written in mafia
we also want some attributes for it
these attributes are going to be the
form that we fill out
i don't think i spelt that wrong
abuse again this is my problem with
coding i always
mess up the
actual
spelling of things i'm like why does my
thing not work um okay value so the
value is like the thing that we want to
give people when they feel like
thanks sir requesting a demo
we'll get back to you soon
we
will get back to you soon make that easy
so don't worry about the comma
there okay now we want type so we want
this to be
um an input type um so we want people to
be able to fill out this form
so we're going to go type this is input
so this bit up the top will be
what they say if you like a little bit
of a text which is why it's just written
marked up and this next bit is going to
be user input so let's go
um
all right let's go we want some contact
details from this person
tributes
and we want
to grab their
[Music]
contact emails
um
so let's go description
um now if you have a look at the
documentation we can make this whole bit
really easy by just um copying and
pasting some of the code we've got um
here as well so we go syntax for issue
forms you can have a look at all of the
stuff here
um
i want to wrap this up so i can answer a
question or two
um so let's just grab all this
and then we're gonna basically copy and
paste this in and we can go
up the top here
uh
demo
request
i've just snuck in in the background
here mish
[Laughter]
um we didn't have any questions on
slider because you were very very very
good at answering questions on youtube
oh there we go so i'll keep going right
for one more minute so we'll finish this
up
just cause no i just wonder because you
went through a million things now is
there one or two that you would pick out
and say hey if you just want to focus on
really getting some you know
productivity or whatever these are the
things you would focus on
yeah cool so if you're really wanting to
get into some of the productivity stuff
i really really like the project boards
um now as i mentioned our um github
public roadmap is available on project
boards um
and it's available as protocols if you
go and look at it it's just it's just
really really simple and easy now this
is my number one thing now when
somebody's mentioning like the chat like
oh
github
shopping list i actually use a project
board like a github project board to
manage my life and i have a column for
like things that need to get done i have
a conf like github stuff that needs to
get done i have a column for like
tracking issues that i just want to like
keep an eye on but i'm not sure where
exactly i want to put them i have i play
a lot of pokemon go so i have a column
for pokemon go which pokemon i'm going
to be trading to my friends
that's awesome what about one for rare
octocat stickers
yeah so the roadmap go and have a look
at it as an example of how to do it but
i i think the the projects are really
exciting which is why this um
the new the github issues is uh well
like the new project boards are going to
be really exciting like giving you all
these different views on how to do stuff
um
so i think it's really cool and um i
will once i finish up
um talking here i will pop some links
into the chat um but basically
yeah like if you want to find out more
about what's happening come follow us on
um twitter and
youtube because they're always shipping
new features
and um yeah just hit me up on any
socials if you want to know more but
yeah it's just it's really exciting um
all the different things we're doing and
um i think the new project stuff is i
can i can just i'm just absorbing your
enthusiasm it's really cool
it's awesome
fantastic oh thank you so much mish
we're gonna we're gonna go to something
stretchy now actually uh
i'm actually gonna join in for the yoga
because i'm really nice yoga so i'm
sticking around to join your fantastic
thank you so much mission thanks for
being part of ndc melbourne that's
awesome
all right i'm going to hand it over to
melissa who is going to take us into the
world of yoga
thanks liz so yeah i don't know about
you but i have been sitting here kind of
a little hunched over at my desk all day
super engrossed in all these awesome
talks so it's time for us to to get
moving a little bit and get a little bit
of a stretch in we have a very special
guest amy dunstan from happy melon
studios in armadale melbourne so here
local in melbourne victoria and she is a
gonna lead us through a mindful yoga
session she is the corporate wellness
manager and league lead yoga and
meditation teacher she has more than
seven years of experience teaching both
in studios and online in this new
virtual world that we have she's here to
help us release some of that tension
from sitting down at their desk so i
hope you follow along and get some
movements in so take it away for us amy
hey amy sorry we can't hear you
so let's just fix that sound so we can
follow along with amy's cool stretches a
chance to to get out of your seat uh if
you can get a floor mask
us talk yeah sorry amy
maybe try
if you're on mute maybe
see if you're on mute within are there
good unmute
can you hear me now
yes we can hear you okay awesome
let's take two i was just talking to
myself but what i was saying was that
you made me sound much more famous and
important than i am um but welcome
everyone we've got a short 15 minute
sequence together today so i want to get
you up and away from your desk if
possible so
make your way over to somewhere that's
not your desk come up into a standing
position to start
and if you've got a map that's amazing
but if you don't just imagine that
you've got one and you need that kind of
amount of space
so when you make your way into your
standing position
just slide your shoulders all the way
down your back
let your palms face forward and then
close your eyes down when you're ready
can you quite literally just stop here
take a pause before we get started and
just notice where you are
begin to draw your attention inwards
just away from the world around you away
from whatever's happened this morning
and just start to find yourself very
much in your body
grounding down into your feet take a
full breath in
and a full breath out
from here reach your arms all the way
out and up
take hold of your left wrist with your
right hand and then from here lean over
towards the right
soften your knees and here can you take
a big breath into the left side of your
body so imagine your left lung is
breathing here
and then bring yourself back through the
center take hold of your right wrist and
lean over to the left
soften your knees take a full breath in
from here bring yourself back to center
release the hands now behind your back
and you can either interlace your
fingers or take hold of opposite elbows
behind your back roll your shoulder
blades down your back
soften your knees lift your heart up
take a big breath in
[Music]
from here bend your knees and start to
slowly fold yourself forward
so from here this is going to look very
different on all of us so you might have
to bend your knees quite a lot but see
if you can ground yourself down into
your feet soft knees and then let your
head hang just as best you can
from here you might actually move your
head a little bit side to side just
release any tension through your neck
and if you've still got your hands
interlaced behind your back can you
gently squeeze your shoulder blades
together
now take a big breath in right in
between your shoulder blades
and release your hands down to the floor
from here we take what's called a
halfway lift so you slide your hands off
your shins if you've been to the gym and
done a deadlift it's kind of like that
so you move your hips back and the
sternum moves forward and see if you can
find a really long flat back here
take a big breath in
from here slide your hands down the back
of your legs as you breathe out and just
fold all the way down from here bring
your fingertips to the floor bend your
left knee and step your right foot all
the way back quite a long step
staying on the fingertips send your
right heel back your left knee forward
just starting to loosen up through the
hips a little bit can you take an easy
breath
from here lower your right knee down
point the back foot and reach your arms
up so this is called a low lunge
and see if here if you need to you can
have your hands resting on your side
otherwise the arms can be up and
overhead see if you can invite a stretch
into your right quad so you might
lengthen your tailbone down
lift up through your spine and look
forward
take a breath
bring your fingertips down to the floor
tuck your back toes lift your back knee
step the right foot forward now and
again fold
so your feet are about hip distance in
their wings so two fists would fit
between the arches
then from here take your halfway lift
again so hands slide up the shins flat
back inhale
hands down the back of your legs fold
forward exhale
bring your fingertips down this time
left foot steps all the way back
left knee down
actually lift your back knee back up we
took an extra moment here so send your
back heel back
right knee forward and see just how long
you can get here so big stretch the left
hip
find your breath
gently lower the left knee down now then
point your back foot as you press down
into your feet reach your arms all the
way up
give yourself two breaths here and see
if you can just keep inviting length
left quad left hip press into both of
your feet
and bring your fingertips down
and from here tuck your back toes lift
the back knee and from here i'm going to
give you two options so you can either
come into a plank
or lower your knees and do a modified
plank whatever suits you from here
settle your eyes forward take a breath
in
as you exhale bend your elbows and
slowly lower yourself down to your belly
so i'm hoping that you like this stretch
so you'll take your right arm
into a 90 degree bend take your right
elbow in line with your right shoulder
right hands flat
turn your head now to the left
rest on your right cheek press into your
left hand and roll the left side of your
body on top of the right
so if anyone's got lower back
sensitivity just bend your knees and
towards your chest here
take a breath into your right pec your
right shoulder
i know we've all been sitting behind the
computer so just feel yourself reversing
that you're literally opening up through
your front
and from here extend your legs straight
come back onto your belly and we'll swap
sides so your left arm now goes out into
a 90 degree bend
turn your head to the right
slowly roll yourself onto your left hip
your right kick stacks on top of it and
then maybe bend your knees towards your
chest
right shoulder down your back
and then here take an easy breath
one more
relax your jaw
and then from here bring yourself back
onto your belly
we'll come into child's pose from here
knees a little bit wider than your hips
big toes together
and as best you can let your hips get
heavy towards your heels
if you can't bring your head down to the
floor or down you can stack your fists
underneath your forehead
and i'm aware that it might not look
like this for everyone so just be nice
and gentle soften through the front of
your hips
and see here if you can breathe into
your lower back
so especially if you're feeling
like you're a bit depleted at the moment
or you're sort of teetering on burnout
anything where you breathe into your
lower back is really nourishing the
kidneys so take one more deep breath
down into lower back
and then from here release your hands
come on up onto all fours
from here we'll do a couple of rounds of
cat cow lengthen out your spine inhale
so here you keep your hips stacked on
top of your knees shoulders on the
wrists tail goes up crown of your head
goes up and forward
and then reverse that round through your
back tuck your tailbone tuck your chin
spread your shoulder blades apart
and we'll do that a few more times with
breath so lengthen out your spine inhale
round through your back and breathe out
two more lengthen
and round as you breathe out
one more
exhale
from here slowly find neutral spine
and from here make your way down onto
your butt
so from here you're going to bring your
legs out in front of you you can you can
face any direction that you like
and then from here reach your arms all
the way up
you can bend your knees if you need to
fold forward see if you can keep your
spine long
and then when you're folding you're
folding all the way you might walk your
sit bones back
again it might look like this for some
of us see if you can tuck your chin
wherever you are you can always bend
your knees
and then let your head go heavy
three breaths
where every time you breathe out it's
like you're literally releasing tension
you really stored up stress from your
body from your tissues from your joints
it's letting go of the day that's been
then from here use your breathing just
to slowly roll yourself up
from here reach your arms forward and
you're going to roll all the way down
onto your back
and as you bring yourself down onto your
back let your palms face up and just
close your eyes down here for a moment
feel the floor
feel your breath
and then from here bring both of your
feet onto the floor hip distance apart
bring your right ankle on top of your
left one
from here interlace the hands behind the
left thigh draw the left knee towards
your right knee away from you
this is optional so you might just leave
the left foot on the ground here and
take a full breath in
big breath out
releasing tension through the right
glute hip
softening your face
and then slowly you'll swap sides so let
go with both of your both feet on the
floor left ankle on right thigh
from here interlace your fingers behind
your right thigh draw the right knee in
towards you shoulder blades down your
back
and see if you can take two relaxing
breaths just give yourself some space
when you finish your next breath out
bring both of your feet onto the floor
from here take your arms out into a big
t-shirt or that double cactus again
and let your knees just drop casually
over to the left
your head can go to the
right so any kind of twist is very
nourishing for your nervous system
nourishing the spinal column
releasing any tension through your back
your belly
in your own time swap it over your knees
will now go to the right your head can
go to the left
soft natural breaths
from here bring yourself slowly back to
the center from here hug your knees in
towards your chest give yourself a big
squeeze
and releasing to shavasana here which is
where you just lay yourself completely
flat it's probably what you've been
waiting for slide your shoulders down
your back palms facing up
your feet will naturally turn out and
then take a full breath in just fill up
your whole body
sigh at your mouth
and allow yourself here just to dive
quite deeply into rest
just letting your breath be natural
letting your mind go wherever it lies
i'll let you know when it's time to come
back
slowly starting to bring your awareness
could you relax your body even just 10
more here
begin to deepen your breath
and from here roll yourself over to the
right for energy or the left for a
little more calm
a fetal position here so you can bend
your knees just rest on your bottom arm
and then from here bring yourself slowly
up into a comfortable seat if there's
such a thing you can straighten your
legs if you need kneeling is welcome and
then roll your shoulders down your back
sit up nice and tall
hands on your thighs and then close your
eyes down
bring a little smirk or a smile to your
face even if it's from the inside out
and notice how you feel
notice if you found a little more room
inside for breath and for quiet in your
mind
take a slow breath in
and an easy breath out
from here please bring your hands to
prayer just in front of your heart
gently bow your head down
just giving thanks to your body
to yourself for making this time
and to each other
namaste
enjoy the rest of whatever today holds i
hope that was a nice
little pause for you and you feel like
you've got some space
thank you very much amy i don't know
about everyone else watching but we here
in the studio definitely got a good
stretch in if you go on larsa's twitter
you can see some some nice shots of the
team here doing our stretches um so
that's really easy
yeah thank you very much for joining us
today emmy
thank you so much see you later
great and now it's time to get back into
our talks so i'm going to hand over to
lars to introduce our next speaker
thank you melissa um now just before we
get into the next talk i'm going to bang
on about this expo site please go there
expo.nbcmelban.com
you can win excellent prizes i'm just
going to read out a few of them there's
of course a ticket or one or more
tickets for next year's ndc melbourne
hopefully in person that is the plan
there are amazon gift cards there are
gift pay vouchers there are smart
watches me bands and there are digital
keep cups i don't even know what they
are but you can win one so please go
there raise your details and we will get
to the price draw at the end of this
conference on this day for ndc melbourne
now that brings me to our next speaker
and he is one of the original ddd
melbourne founders which was a long time
ago more than 10 years ago
um
he uh he's a tech lead for willow he is
working on iot solutions he has
australia's largest collection of hg's
and he's a volunteer firefighter i'm not
sure if those two are related but in any
case welcome alex mackey and thank you
for being part of
ndc melbourne
thanks very much guys
oh you're welcome
so um you're going to talk about rockets
or
uh we're not going to be talking about
rockets well maybe we will a little bit
very good now i know you're going to
talk about digital twins because that's
what it says in the title um this is one
of the things that i haven't actually
played with so i'm kind of keen to see
what the possibilities are i know it's
iot and i know it's
that sort of world of things on azure
but other than that i have no idea
yeah now for those of you planning to
use this to go and stretch around and
take a break please please stick around
i'll tell you why i think this is going
to be interesting and applicable to a
lot of people
it is one of those sort of maybe niche
services that's a little bit rarer but
let me tell you uh all about it
so um welcome to introduction to digital
twins and the azure digital
twin platform my name is alex mackey
everything i'm going to show you today
i'll put up at my website
simpleisbest.com so you can go and get
this stuff later
i work as a tech lead for an
organization called willow at willow
we're very much focused on digital twins
um and
for for the building systems and
critical infrastructure
so
if i do my job correctly what are you
going to learn in the next 45 minutes or
so well we're going to start off by
talking what exactly is a digital twin
in the first place how are digital twins
being used in the real world
where did these things come from in the
first place and then we're going to look
at the fundamentals of the azure digital
twin platform so you can go and
implement this stuff yourself
so before you nip off for lunch one
thing i do want to mention is that the
global twin market is massive now those
crazy analysts and some of them are a
bit crazy have estimated this is an area
that's going to be growing to 17.4
billion us dollars by 2024.
i think because of the size of this
there's a reasonable likelihood that if
you're a developer or involved in some
aspect of software engineering at some
point you might quite
likely will touch a digital twin
project
so what exactly is a digital twin anyway
well
simply put a digital twin can be thought
of as a virtual representation of a
real-world item or process
let's take a simple example we've got a
cog and this cog is equipped with a
number of sensors maybe they measure the
revolutions of this cog and they send
this data into some kind of digital twin
system or platform and on this platform
we create a virtual representation of
this cog now linking these two things
you'll find in the literature this is
referred to as a fred which i think is
kind of a nice analogy given these two
things are inextricably linked
now an important thing i want to get
across is you don't necessarily need to
use digital twins to model things like
cogs
or engineering or engines which is often
a lot of examples you see these could be
processes as well and i'm going to show
you a few examples of how this has been
employed at the moment
let's start off with a simple example of
a digital twin now let's take any
typical large building this building has
several um probably hundred different
systems operating inside of it it's got
electricity
it's got water it's got heating there's
various security systems
all sorts of things going on there
we'll take one of these um pretty much
every building will be uh or hopefully
will be equipped with some kind of air
conditioning unit
on the top there now this air
conditioning unit could have a number of
sensors on it and this sensor is
providing various different details and
on a difficult one we might be able to
pull out maybe the temperature the
humidity uh the air quality
fan rpms maybe even when this unit was
last serviced
now this data could all be fed into
another system where the building
manager could see what's going on with
this air conditioning unit um what
temperatures is it at the moment when
was the last time it's been inspected
and so on
now when i started working with digital
twins one of the first questions i had
were are digital twins just a form of
dashboard
well i think there's more to it than
that and let me tell you more
so with all of these type of device
devices there's an enormous amount of
data they could be giving us and it's
almost too much to do anything useful
with there could be data from literally
hundreds or thousands of different
sources in a typical large building
and one of the things that i think
digital twins enable us to do is to go
and take this data
we'll go and process it blend it get all
the good stuff out and then we can start
drawing insights which we can actually
do something with rather than actually
just dealing with a large blob of data
that's no good for anyone
just means there's a number of people
involved in this study i don't know um
how they decide who's the main one i
like to think they fight it out
highlander style divides digital twins
into three different types
he talks about digital models or
simulations and that's where data is
exchanged manually maybe um so for
example maybe in kovid we're getting
some stats each day someone's taking
those stats and then plugging them into
a model
and that's a manual process and we have
digital shiddo digital shadows which are
one-way data exchange so the real world
item is sending data into the platform
and finally the most complex and mature
digital twin where we have
bi-directional data exchange so perhaps
in our air con
example then we have
the ability to go and control this
aircon unit from our digital twin
now typical digital twins will give you
four main functions they allow you to
visualize the current state of the item
or process how hot's this room right now
what's the
air conditioning unit operating at
they'll probably trigger alerts under
certain conditions is that room getting
too hot is it cooking everyone inside
it will probably allow you to review
historical data maybe how hot was this
room last year at this time and year and
the more advanced digital twins will
allow you to simulate different
scenarios and there's even examples of
people creating digital twins prior to
creating the actual physical product
this can save a lot of money and time in
product development
summarizing the benefits of digital
twins i think digital twins can help you
make better decisions they can assist
with maintenance and safety they can
reduce the costs of several things they
can improve efficiencies in your
organization maybe your building you
shut off different lights and rooms if
they're not in use
and of course making prediction and i'm
going to show you some examples of this
very shortly
now our product um one of our products
is focused on the real estate market and
i want to show you a few key aspects of
this now this isn't going to play so
well um over um a stream so i encourage
you if you just look up willowink.com
you'll find us on our home page but i do
want to show a couple of key aspects to
it
so we create complete models of these
buildings down to very fine levels of
detail and what this enables you to do
the building manager can look at these
models
they can zoom into them
down to the level of individual pipes
and units and see where the problems are
we've got another product associated
with rail and what we're seeing here um
is some details of some rail track there
allowing the people managing these
systems to quickly find issues
where did digital twins come from in the
first place
does anyone know what this is
it's a bit of a grainy image
but some of you folks probably are
familiar with um what this image is um
already
now this image here is of apollo 13. i
think even if you're not that interested
into space a lot of people were probably
aware um of the somewhat ill-fated
apollo 13 mission
so
um and apparently this was due to a
technician originally due to a
technician carrying
a oxygen cylinder and accidentally
dropping it which would lead to
a number of events and eventually one of
the these oxygen cylinders exploding
apollo 13 had some problems
and the problem with this was that
obviously apollo 13 is really really far
away from those down on earth who can go
and help apollo 13.
now one of the unique things about this
was that prior to this mission nasa had
set up 15 different simulators
of apollo 13 and the lunar module
apparently there was four computers
alone um for needed in order to simulate
um the rocket system
now what was unique about these
simulators and i'm not going to claim a
simulator as a digital twin um they're
definitely not is that these simulators
allowed
the controllers to specify various
parameters in order to set the state of
the system and they could set these
things up very quickly so by taking the
real-world state of what's actually
happening to apollo 13
some of those details they'd have on
hand and some of them they might need to
query from the crew they were able to
create a very accurate replica of what
apollo 13 was allowing them to test
various scenarios in order to help get
these astronauts back to work uh back to
you uh
um
and um i think this is probably one of
the furthest first examples of what
could be considered a digital twin
going forwards and we have this guy um
david galentia i'm probably pronouncing
your name your name wrong um he did a
lot of work in parallel computing and
the linda language but what we're
interested in um is a book he wrote
called mirror worlds now bear in mind
this is in 1991 and i'm going to read
the second paragraph for this and he
says this mirror world you are looking
at is fed by a steady rush of new data
pouring in through cables it is
infiltrated by your own software
creatures doing your business and david
kind of puts forward this idea of
digital twins that we have today
we have john vickers who is widely
credited for being the first person to
coin the term digital twin and depending
on the source you look at this was in
2002 or um 2010.
um but what we really find is it's this
guy michael greaves who goes and
popularizes um this concept now
michael's interested in how he can apply
digital twins to the manufacturing
process and he proposes that we could
create this digital construct um that's
linked to the physical item
and that this could create a lot of
efficiencies allowing us to test various
proposals
but of course digital twins wouldn't
have been popular without several other
advances so we see all sorts of things
from
the proliferation of cheap iot devices
because if it's expensive to implement
these kind of things then you know
that's a bit discouraging to actually do
it and of course these things are
dependent on various things such as
processing improvements
comms advances uh even batteries because
if your devices are running out all the
time then that's no good to anyone and
then we see a heap of other things
protocol standards uh cloud hosting
systems to go and process this data um
down to 3d modeling vr
augmented reality and so on i think
you'd even argue recently
that our least favorite coronavirus is
probably also accelerating some of the
work here
um a great example um again i'd
encourage you to go to um the link here
i'm going to
pick out a couple of key points is a
digital twin that's been created of the
state of uh victoria now this digital
twins kind of focuses on a couple of
aspects it focuses on planning aspects
so they believe this is going to assist
get various building planning
applications through a lot quicker
they look at integrating uh energy um
sources uh into it and also for disaster
planning so you'll see how they go and
use um flooding data uh in order to look
at how you know uh what might happen um
to this location had a flood occur so
i'm just going to play that and pick out
a couple of
will be parts
so it's pretty cool um some of the stuff
that's going on with this uh singapore
there's been a digital singapore since
2014. um if you go look it up there's an
immense amount of details um in that
model they use it for urban planning and
also again for disaster planning and
modelling
some recent examples
these digital twins have been employed
in order to optimize vaccination centers
in order to get people through as quick
as possible but also in a safe socially
distant way we see it used across
nuclear power solar car energy and even
in livestock farming now this livestock
farming um is particularly interesting
in the the um people who put this paper
together they propose using facial
recognition technology on cows in order
to understand how um the cow's going at
the moment and contribute to that
animal's welfare so it's quite a
creative use of some of these things and
you can see there's a lot of different
um examples here some of these things
are quite abstract in nature they're
more concepts rather than
a physical device that we're mirroring
here
so um hopefully i've convinced you that
maybe this is an interesting
area and it's got a widespread use of
examples of where you could deploy this
and what i want to talk about next
is how you can go about creating digital
twins yourself and using the azure
digital twins platform now i also think
it's fairly unique service to azure and
i haven't come across anything
similar that's going to offer some of
the stuff i'll show you in a minute
before we get into that however azure
offers another service called iot hub
now a lot of you will be familiar with
this service you can certainly use this
with azure digital twins if you want to
but don't feel that you have to these
are independent things
and somewhat confusingly iot hub has its
concept of device twins
this is completely different concept to
digital twins and in iot hub world
device twins it's all to do with config
and firmware management
so let's imagine we're setting out to
create a new digital twin project maybe
we want to do something similar to our
building example that we talked about
earlier on we've got lots of devices in
our
building we're getting measurements from
various different places um what do we
need well at the start of it you can
think of well we're going to need to a
few things in order to create a digital
twin of this building
one of the first things we're going to
need is the ability to go and actually
define a digital twin
we're going to need to define what is
this air conditioning unit what are its
capabilities what measurements can we
get from it also how are these things
related so maybe there's some kind of
plumbing system it's gonna be pretty
useful if you know which pipes connected
to which pipe and this feeds into this
component here
and so on we're gonna need a way to go
and update the twin state because if
it's not reasonably up to date well it's
not that useful um
we'll probably want the ability to be
able to perform uh different queries
across the digital twins that we've set
up so for example we might want to know
which air conditioning units are
operating above 30 degrees
because that's really quite hot and we
should go and check that out we're going
to want a way of securely integrating
with these things and ideally maybe
you've got investment in the azure
platform already it'd be great if it's
integrated with a lot of existing azure
services
so that brings us to azure digital twin
now microsoft marketing say that azure
digital twin is an internet of things
platform that enables you to create a
digital representation of real world
things places businesses and processes
and people
but what does that actually mean well i
think we can divide the azure digital
twin platform into five maybe five and a
half main things now underlying all of
this is a graph database and this is
going to store your twin models
the state of your twins how they're
related but we're going to need a way of
defining them and this is where twin
schema or dtdl comes in
now twin schema or dtl dtdl is the
equivalent of creating some empty tables
in the relational database world um
we've created our tables we've set how
they're related we've specified our
fields and their types but we haven't
actually created any definitions of
twins so we're going to need a way of
doing that and that's where the 20
different definitions come in
now if you want to work with any of this
the azure digital twin platform and i'm
going to call that adt now um because
that's kind of a mouthful as your
digital twin platform
is
we've got this rest api that we can work
with so this means whatever language or
platform you work with you can work with
this platform
but of course it's not that convenient
to go and hand code all of these things
ourself so microsoft also offer
a number of sdks so we have.net go
python java javascript and you can also
perform some of the operations i'll show
you through the azure cli
let's go and actually go and create some
digital twins but prior to that let's
have a obligatory warning the demo code
now what i'm going to show you today is
not a good way to actually model your
twins and i'll tell you why shortly it's
done because it's simple now in our
scenario let's take a typical digital
twin we've got a house and this house is
using electricity and we want to know
which houses are using
more electricity
so how are we going to do this well the
first thing we're going to need to do is
actually come up with a way to go and
describe our digital twins so let's come
out slides and look at how we go and do
this
now the way that you actually come up
and define your digital twins
is using a language called dtdl
which is
formatted as json
now what i've got here is my definition
of my house object here and you can see
the type of this is something called a
interface
now interface is equivalent to a class
in programming terminology and it has a
number of different types of
fields within it
so
there's only a few of them that you're
going to need to be aware of
we're going to look at properties and
these are data fields that hold the
state of our entity these are equivalent
to classes fields and there's
relationships which link these classes
or interfaces together in our example
perhaps we go to a deeper level of
detail and our house has rooms and a
relationship is going to allow you to
define the rooms within the house
there's also two other types of property
which i'm not going to cover today
called telemetry and component just be
aware they're there
now our example wouldn't be too
interesting on its own so we're going to
build that up
so we're going to say we've got a house
that's got an address property and
this house also has a consumption of
electricity which will define as
electricity kilowatt hours i've no idea
if that's a realistic measurement i'm
not electrician and we're also going to
create another interface called street
and street has houses so a street could
have
zero or more houses if you will
and finally we're gonna have a district
and a district has streets
let's look at how to go and actually
define this um in our dttl there so the
topmost thing that we need to care about
is this id property here and this
specifies um the name of
the class there and this needs to be
unique
this has a couple of parts to it you can
see this ndc bit here you can think of
this as kind of a namespace it needs to
prev
be prefixed with dtmi prior to that we
then have the name of the object in this
case house that's kind of equivalent to
class name and we have this number here
now this is the version of the model
that we're operating here so in adt i
can have multiple versions of the same
thing at the same time if i want to and
then house has a couple of properties
we have our street
we have
this new property here called
relationship and we've basically
declared the name of the relationship
here and we've also told it
what type of objects it's pointing at
the other item i just want to call out
is this display name here now this is
used by some of the tools i'm going to
show you in a second
and can make it a bit easier
to actually go and see what's going on
with your adt models there
now
this is a very simple set of models and
once you start getting into a few more
it's quite easy to go and make a typo or
mistake so microsoft provider tool
called the dtdl validator which will
actually go and take all your files and
go and tell you whether something's
wrong with them so i've created a bat
file which just goes and kicks this off
and passing in the directory and i'm
going to run that there and you can see
i get this
output here that's gone and validated my
free files and everything's looking good
if i was to make a mistake say we'll
change the type there to interface two
that's probably going to be enough um to
pick up hey look something's not quite
right there
there's a bit of an issue there you
might want to take a look at it so i'd
highly recommend you use this tool as
it's going to save you a lot of time
later
let's put that back because that's going
to cause us trouble later
so
um we'll run the validator again
all our files look good um okay we're
ready to go and load these into adt
so i'm going to bring up
the browser here and what this is here
is this is the azure digital twins
explorer and you can get to this there's
a little button in azure you can click
it and open digital twins explorer and
you'll get this screen here and you can
see at the moment there's nothing in our
digital twins graph now the first thing
we need to do is um go and upload our
models so i'm going to click that upload
button there and you can see
here's our three files that i was
showing you earlier and we're going to
go and load those
in so i'm going to select all of those
we'll go and open those
it will chug away a bit and all being
well
over on the left there we'll then have
these items loaded in and we can see
we've got our district our house
and so on um i have the ability to go
and create a twin from the ui here
i can go and click this bottle here this
button here and i can go and look at the
information on the model
and i can have a quick check what's
going on now let's say i wanted to make
a change to some of this stuff we talked
about this version number
i could declare
version number two of the house there
and i could go back and then i could go
and upload that if i wanted to
and you'll see that we now have two
house and we can see that's the second
version there
that's going to get a bit confusing so
let's go and get rid of that one
now at this point we've uploaded um our
structure here we've kind of got empty
tables in database terminology
and we actually need to go and create
our twin graph
now like everything in adt there's a
number of different ways to go and do
this the way
i'm going to go and do this
is i'm going to go and load upload an
excel file now this excel file needs to
be in quite a specific format
and microsoft specify the column order
and structure of this
so what we have here we have our model
id that corresponds to our class name
we have the id property now this is the
unique name
of that particular digital twin instance
there so you can see we've created
several different houses there so we've
got house zero um to seven uh we've got
three streets two districts and so on
now you can also set um some initial
data to define the state of um these
digital twin items here so i'm just
going to give it a simple numeric
address there
and we'll initialize electricity
kilowatts to xero we'll set some street
names and district names
let's get rid of that now once you're
ready with that the way to actually
upload it i go and click this
uploads arrow there
i'm going to go and upload this twin
setup there and then we get this preview
here
of what it's actually
going to create
now this isn't created until i go and
click this save button there to start
import so i'm going to go
and click that start import there
and all being well that's going to load
in everything into our digital twin
graph there and we can see we've had 13
twins imported and 11
relationship that's uh imported there
now you might be thinking
that's going to get kind of unmanageable
once you've got a very large number of
items
and i think you're right and i'd
actually unless you're doing some
initial experimentation um i would
discourage this way of doing things the
other disadvantage of uploading stuff
through to ui
is it really doesn't give you very many
error messages so whilst i was putting
this
when i was putting this example together
you literally get something like digital
twin could not be created which isn't
really very helpful in order to
understand what it is that you've done
wrong
so
adt offers several different ways to
actually update your and create your
digital twins you can use the azure cli
you could use one of the sdks
my preference i'd encourage you to use
one of the sdks and you're also likely
to run into a scenario where you'll
start to get dependency issues so you
need to create certain things before say
you need to create the house type before
creating the relationship of
a street
has houses so that will give you that
fine grain control you need
in order to
set up and go and create your twin graph
so that's my recommendation there but
it's great for playing around for small
examples like this
so we've imported our graph here um and
you can see we've got um this structure
here uh that's the structure that i
showed you on the slide earlier we have
a district and the district is made up
of streets
and streets uh have houses in them now
if i go over to
the twin graph i'm not seeing anything
here at the moment um
and that's because i haven't run this
query a bit here now i'm going to go
back um to uh the query stuff in just a
minute there's something a bit more i
want to talk to you about with models
so we've defined our models and
relationships
and we've now got everything set up
now you might be asking it could take a
bit of time to go and create some of
these models um and especially once you
get into a more complex domain like
imagine you're trying to model a smart
city or a whole building that's going to
take a lot of time to go and create
these models
and also go and get these the modeling
around it right it's not easy this is a
fairly early days um for how to how best
to model these things there's not a lot
of um
there are best practices but we're still
working out you know what some of those
things are so one thing you can do
is you can look at ontologies now
ontologies are a collection of models um
for a specific domain and there's
already some examples of many different
domains so there's an example for a
power grid system already there's an
example for
smart cities
all sorts of things so you could go and
take one of these models and that's
going to save you a lot of time
from going and creating one of these
things yourself
and also potentially a lot of error as
hopefully someone's worked out some of
the issues and the approach they've
proposed is going to work well for a lot
of people now microsoft put forward
there's three main strategies for using
these models you could potentially adopt
them entirely maybe you convert them and
you just take the bits you want maybe
you go and extend them but all in all
this can spend save you a lot of
development time when you're working
with these type of things so i'd highly
encourage you if you're coming to a new
digital chin product
go have a look what's out there first
because there's probably something that
you can at least base
your work on before you set about
creating your own models
um we've actually got our um our own
building-based one which is an extension
of some of the smart cities work there
you can find that on the public github
there and you'll see just how detailed
and how complex some of these models can
get
here's a visualization of the the smart
cities one
on the azure repo there
so probably your next question is okay
so we've got everything set up there
we've defined our instances of digital
twins um how do we go about actually
updating these things well again you've
got several different uh options in you
of course have the
various rest apis and sdks
some integration with logic apps at the
moment
and then we have iot hub as well now i
put an asterisk next to iot hub as you
do have to do a bit of work yourself
you can trigger an event which creates a
function which i'm going to show you an
example of in a minute um but you do
still need to do a bit of programming um
yourself so it's it's not completely
plug and play
in terms of getting data out of it of
course you could create some polling
mechanism via the rest apis sdks but you
also have a number of different other
options um there's out the box
integration with event hub grid service
bus
you can make use of events for
various things occurring from
relationships changing
telemetry being received and so on
um
let me show you a simple example of how
to integrate this from
net so um i've got a application here um
and the first thing you need to do is go
and specify um your digital twin
endpoint
now i'm going to use the default azure
credentials to connect to this uh in my
example because it's a little bit
simpler now these are created when you
go and log into azure through something
like that azure cli um and they save a
bit of work and also means i don't have
to
hide credentials while um
showing this to various people so i've
already logged into my subscription
friday azure cli
so that's how that's authenticated into
this now of course in the real world um
you're not going to do that and you have
two main options with adt for
authentication
if you've got something already running
on the azure platform you're going to
want to use managed identities and here
you basically
find out you tell azure digital twins
hey i want this azure function that i've
just created to
be part of this role in this adt graph
and have these permissions uh it sounds
complicated it's it's actually not
there's a couple of commands you have to
run i'll show you in a minute
but that enables adt to authenticate
that your servers should have access and
authorize the actions that they're
taking on it now if you've got something
external um it supports the standard
oauth
protocols you'll need to set up an
application in azure ad and so on again
there's detailed instructions on how to
go about setting this up
so back to our simple example i've got a
simple net core
cli program here
and we want to go and update the
electricity usage of house zero how do
we do that well we're going to create a
new jsonpatch document with this line
here
i'm going to set the electricity usage
to 22
kilowatt hours however much that is and
then i'm going to apply this
to this property here electricity
kilowatts hours and we um i know if you
remember we declared that property at
the top level here so we can see the
name of that so that's mapping through
to that property there um and then we're
just going to write out that it's
successfully updated um this value so um
all been well we'll go and run that up
um and uh hopefully that will connect um
and then when we go and look at the
graph again we should see that 22 um in
the value all done so that all looks
good um we'll go over to azure digital
twins explorer there i'm not seeing any
digital twins right now we'll go and run
the query there and let's go and get our
twin graph um there's all the twin items
that we've created there
i could go down and many go and select
house zero there
and we can see by selecting this i can
see the properties over on the right
here
and i can see that the electricity
kilowatt hours has been updated to 22
here
now it's exactly the same approach if
you want to go and update this through
an azure function for example
so go into a more
complicated example and
this is based on
some of the
example i code in the documentation but
i've cut it down a little bit to make it
a little bit more simpler what we're
going to do is we're going to have a net
application and that's going to send in
some random values to azure iot hub here
now when these values appear on the hub
we're going to raise an event which is
going to go and trigger we've got this
azure function that's listening out for
and this azure function is going to use
some very similar code to what i've just
shown you
in order to go and connect to azure
digital twins graph and update the state
of this item there
and of course we could then write a net
application website api whatever it is
to go and read out the state of um this
graph
now there is one more step we need to do
and that's that security step i
mentioned earlier so we're going to use
managed identities and we're going to
say
we want this as a function
to have an identity and we then want to
put
the identity and associate that with the
azure digital twins data owner role
there that's going to give it quite a
high level of permissions there so you
probably want to get a bit more granular
but it's going to enable us to go and
update that twin graph
there
so just to show you
that working there
i have
my simple
program which is just a console
application and this application here is
just going to send in some random values
into
the iot hub it's triggering that event
which is triggering the function
function's picking up and then it's
going updating the state of our house so
all being well we should see this value
change
i'll click off it we'll go and click on
it again
and
let me close that one down and we should
hopefully see that value updating over
time so we can see it's changing there
as these events are received and update
um the state of the twin there now one
thing i should mention um is it will
only hold the state of the um the last
value updated so you're going to need to
if you want every single value of the
history you're going to need to
implement that yourself and it does kind
of make sense when you think about the
immense amount of data
that could be sent and stored on this
item you're probably going to want some
control and to choose how you go and
store and what you do with this data
so at this point we've got everything
flowing into our graph but how do we go
about actually getting
data out of it well again we have a
number of different options azure
digital twin supports a sequel like
query language now it's not sql so
there's some things you can there's many
things you can do in sql which you can't
do in adt world but some of the basic
sort of sql like statements
it supports
there's also some new keywords and
digital twin specific functions that
have been introduced to make your life
easier
and again you can use this through the
rest api sdks um and uh so on so what do
the queries look like well you've got
your standard sql ones where we might do
select star from digital twins um and um
where we might specify a where clause um
i can go out of this and we could go
flip star from digital twins uh where
address one uh equals
ten and then hit the run query um i can
also click this overlay results on which
is kind of an interesting thing so that
kind of filters out the other stuff and
shows you where the results of your
query
sit there so that might be quite nice
for some sort of visualization there
so you can see it's quite easy to go and
work
work with this graph there
so going back there's a couple of
more complex
things or
functions that adt enables you can do
you can check where specific properties
are defined whether there are specific
types whether they're of models
and of course because this is a graph
database we can perform some more
complicated things so for example if we
wanted to only select houses within an
individual street
we have the ability to do that now it's
probably fair to say that it's not um as
feature rich as some graph databases um
at least right now so um but um it
certainly enables you to walk some of uh
these these relationships um that you've
set up and defined here so in our
scenario here if uh we might want to
select
see what's going on in a particular
district but only see the houses within
that now you can certainly do that for
relational database but i think it's
maybe a bit more intuitive and it also
enables you to do some types of queries
that will be quite difficult
in standard sql once you start
having nodes linked together and wanting
to walk those nodes and their path
in terms of running costs it's very very
cheap um obviously this starts to add up
if you add on a hundred thousand um
devices sending in data multiple times a
second so you'll want to do some cost
modelling um around this but right now
in terms of aud i think um this entire
demo which i've been playing with for a
number of weeks um i've spent uh one
dollar 20 cents or something and i've
sent it a heap of data so um it's not
one of those services you need to be a
bit scared of to play with um it's very
very cheap to uh to run and play with
now you might be wondering um when
should you go and use
adt well i think it's probably best used
when you've got a large number of
digital twins to manage if you've only
got 10 items it's probably more
complexity than you care about maybe
you've got very complex relationships
through between these items um perhaps
you'd benefit from flexible schema it's
a bit of a pain when you've got that
standard relational database to have to
you know manage various fields change
the schema and so on and um willow the
ability to change this schema add to it
um it's very expressive that certainly
saved us a lot of development time um
and it's been very useful
perhaps you want to make use of one of
these existing ontologies that are out
there again this i really can't stress
this enough this can save you a lot of
pain and development time so if you are
working on these projects please take a
look at
what these existing ontologies uh can
give you as its graph database we can
perform more complex graph queries um
and so that could be pretty useful i'm
working on a project at the moment where
we have a
process for modelling and
it's enabled us to jump between the
different nodes in the process
move horizontally move laterally into
how these systems are grouped
and this would have been quite difficult
some of these types of queries with your
standard databases and of course if
you've got an existing investment in the
azure platform it integrates quite
nicely with many azure services
now in terms of challenges there's a few
things i just want to raise i think a
lot of people come to iot
and digital twin and they look at it and
they think hey this is just taking in a
load of data
processing it and doing something with
it
and i must admit i did too and
it's a very naive approach
and you will very quickly find out
that's not the case so when you're
working with these types of projects you
have to deal with all sorts of things
like doing an inherent unreliability of
these devices uh and sensors you'll find
data won't be transmitted at the times
you're expecting um the batteries will
run out people will vandalize your
devices there's all sorts of different
problems
to work with here
in terms of digital twins depending on
your use case uh it's quite important
your digital twin is an accurate
reflection of what's happening in the
the real physical world and of course
there's a delay from sending this data
processing it um and reflecting it in
your digital representation and that's
gonna be something that you're gonna
have to deal with so you're gonna need
to be able to digest that um data very
quickly it can be hard and expensive to
add
these digital version to an existing
system or uh implementation
and it's probably worth noting that some
of the things that these are employed in
as well will very lightly outlive the
software that you write and that's kind
of unusual so hopefully we'd expect a
building to last maybe at least 50 100
probably more years
i can't think of many software
examples where that's that's been around
that length of time
the modelling of these things is
difficult and it's evolving i think you
can mitigate that to some extent by
working with ontologies
interoperability and standards still
developing especially in the iot world
there's a number of pain points there
and of course if you're creating a
digital representation of something you
also need to look at the privacy and
confidentially confidentiality aspects
of that as it could reveal quite a lot
of information
about people and systems
wrapping things up digital twins are a
virtual representation of a real world
object or process they bring together
data in an easy to understand and
actionable form i think they offer
several advantages around making better
decisions analysis monitoring
diagnostics
diagnostics efficiency and ultimately
the ability to even make predictions
the azure digital twins platform
consists of a number of components a
graph database a language for describing
the twins apis and sdks
and if you take one thing away from this
whilst you could implement all this
stuff yourself
i really think if
adt can save you a lot of time
and pain from doing this
um finally quick plug for my company if
this world of digital twins sounds
interesting to you and we're looking for
a number of folks please reach out to me
if you've got any questions tell them i
sent you
and
in terms of further reading there's a
great summary on an academic article
here if you want to get more into the
history of it if you're wondering how
our platform works and want to take a
deep dive into the architecture of that
please consult this link here and we've
got a great session with microsoft and
some of my willow colleagues will
explain in detail some of the projects
and how we've implemented this
thank you very much
that's awesome alex phew well there is a
question and it's asked by this amazing
guy called last clint um
there was actually another guy
there was so much information in this
session and i have like one main
question i think is sort of like holy
moly where do i even start like is there
a simple example where you can sort of
just
go away
if this looks of interest to you and you
want to have a play with it maybe you've
got a raspberry pi and some iot devices
in your house you want to play with it
what i do first of all is i'd head over
to
the microsoft azure digital twin site
there's extensive documentation it's
well written
there's multiple examples
some of the examples i've showed you
there are based on some of the microsoft
stuff it's really very easy to get
started with um and play with this stuff
so you can use a raspberry pi
oh absolutely like if you want to
integrate anything um into this you'll
have to write code to
either send it into
adt world or maybe you send it
via azure iot hub um and then you'll
have to write the bits that link those
two things together but sure um you
could that's what they're here
so that's cool
that's wow that was a lot of information
um i just i like the graphical part of
it it just appeals to me it's not all
code right you can see what's actually
going on so it does and it does this
cool animation where it goes and
arranges your yeah yeah
as well and especially on a more complex
setup um like my example is fairly
trivial i think there's what 10 10 or so
items there once you get into hundreds
or thousands you get kind of this
spectacular graph and it's quite easy to
sort of navigate between these things
that's awesome well thank you so much
alex for being part of ndc melbourne
thank you that was uh very informative
and if you want to know more about this
reach out to alex directly or put it in
the youtube chat or wherever else you
can find them so
in a minute there are dev news but first
a word from our sponsors
i love running this company i love
running it because of the people i deal
with
there's such a great team of people from
a career perspective it's the best move
i ever did being a great consultant
which we are at ssw is half half between
technical skills and communication
[Music]
it's given me the opportunity to work
with lots of different types of
technology and explore some stuff that i
maybe only dabbled in at university or
before
ssw is a company that makes enterprise
software solutions
and that's what we do we build software
for clients on demand we build bespoke
solutions using the latest technology
and the latest best practices i've been
involved in the development of some
mining software being involved in the
development of software for a legal firm
and everything in between there even in
just under two years i've been working
across so many different projects
it's just a really great place to come
into and i always look forward to coming
to work
[Music]
as an investor or wealth professional
you want a wealth provider that is
flexible smart and tech savvy
a provider with fresh eyes who sees
opportunity to present wealth solutions
differently
a partner who can administer wealth your
way
netwealth was created with an
entrepreneurial spirit to do all of this
we exist to help you see your wealth
differently to realize your potential to
inspire you to discover a brighter
future
at our core we are a technology company
a super fund an investment specialist an
administration business
but in our daily lives we are you
moms and dads call center operators
sales and marketing professionals
analysts netball teams friends
technologists developers and most
importantly family
to investors we provide award-winning
superannuation and investment accounts
products and services
to wealth professionals we provide a
market-leading platform to better their
business
underlying all of this is cutting-edge
technology anywhere everywhere
with us you can see your wealth
differently and more positively we
identify new opportunities with our
fresh perspective and natural curiosity
we provide choice through our flexible
approach to business and product design
we prioritize your security to give you
peace of mind
we are involved in your world in schools
we support financial literacy helping
our younger australians also see wealth
differently we are a team of talented
people working hard to make life better
for more australians
we are creators
we are curious always looking to spot
the change that matters
we are authentic and genuine
we believe that strength is in teamwork
we are agile and nimble upbeat energetic
and optimistic about the future
with us you can see wealth differently
because we are different in our approach
our attitude our commitment and our
spirit
partner with us to see what's possible
[Music]
and now it's time for some developer
news i have my my new hosting jacket on
and i'm ready to tell you about some
awesome new things in the world of
technology so first up angular 12 was
released last month it's even smaller
faster and easier to use it enables the
transition of the angular ecosystem to
the iv compiler so the ivy compiler
they've released in version 9 and it's
the next generation compilation and
rendering pipeline
have deprecated support for their their
old view engines so make sure you get
updated and get all the benefits from iv
also with version 12 they have stylish
improvements such as the support for the
knowledge coalescing operator and it
will allow you to write cleaner code
they're continuing to work on the
developer experience and adding all
kinds of new learning resources guides
and videos to help you get up and
running
in addition to all that with version 12
they also have released a new developer
tool called angulardev tools which is a
chrome devtool extension which came out
last month and will give you an improved
angular debug experience
so with angular dev tools you'll be able
to inspect the structure and profile of
your application's performance
visualize the component structure from
within your the developer console
and help it'll help you to understand
that the whole change detection
execution
so you can install it now it's available
in the
extension
place for develop in chrome
and you can visualize the structure of
your apps explore and expect edit
components using a magnifying glass and
that has a really nice performance
profile bar chart so check out what's
new in the world of angular
over to you william for more news
wonderful i just pulled off a lars
moment
[Laughter]
hello everybody i am william i'm going
to be talking to you a little bit about
the
theworldof.net especially.net 6.
and uh so i'm going to share my screen
so
uh
about just over two and a half weeks ago
richard lander released a
post here about dot net six preview six
uh so we have you know all these
previews coming out most of this year
and this is uh this
second to last preview so
uh after this we'll be heading in
towards the rc's or the release
candidates so if you have any
um
wishes to influence what goes into net
six uh around about november with net
conf uh you know now is your chance
because once it goes into rc's all the
features are pretty much locked in
now what's exciting is that um
for previous six is mainly focused
around the asp.net core ef core and dot
net maui and i think uh somewhere they
say there's actually a relatively small
update you know in preview six
but if you look at the content there's
quite a bit there
what would be very exciting is the the
x64 emulation update so especially if
you're on a mac or arm64
now
it's not all quite ready yet
so you'll be able to run
net
everything.net 6 on your mac your m1 if
you've got one of those new nice and
fast m1s
so hopefully with you know one of the
next updates or definitely by the the
final.net six everything should be nice
and smooth working for you
i would like to then just jump straight
into the updates for asp.net core
um so
good friend daniel roth here um
big boss at the asp.net team uh he
highlighted some stuff that is coming in
for blazer and general asp.net updates
and we can see here something very
interesting angular 12 which melissa
covered for us a moment ago
but
starting at the top here
we can see that
we have this thing called ahead of time
compilation
so for a lot of the blazer develops
developers especially this is going to
be super super nice and something has
been asked for for a long time
because
uh the dlls that our blazer webassembly
applications will be downloading to the
client
will sort of be pre-compiled and you
know be executing a whole lot faster
instead of being interpreted so we're
going to pretty much be running directly
on webassembly without having to have
the javascript
interpretation in the middle there so
i'm
very excited to try this out uh reading
some of the github issues
the sort of numbers people are posting
there for performance increases you know
70 to 80 times faster execution
that is truly amazing so i'm keen to
actually try this out so they've given
us a couple of
instructions here to install the
workloads for blazer webassembly aot
ahead of time compilation and
so the only downside of this is you may
actually end up with a slightly larger
bundle size at the end
in some cases but i think you know for
the speed improvement this will be quite
quite nice
they give us some instructions of how to
update our existing projects it's fairly
straightforward we just normally have to
rename the package references we just
bump up the version number to the
current preview which is preview six
and uh there's a few small breaking
changes but you can check out this link
here from the
devbloxdevblogs.microsoft.com
and sort of check those out if you've
already built something with dot net six
um they have some improvements in terms
of accessibility uh what i'm most
excited about here is the focus on
navigate so that when i
route to a new page
i can actually set the focus
to an element using the standard css
selectors
so they keep adding all these small
extra components over time into blazer
and you know that just like the file
upload component the input focus
component those are all getting blazer
webassembly in a much better state so
jump onto the github issues you know add
your requests in there and you know
hopefully uh
very soon yeah we can have a lot of
those things in blazer and
i'm sure you can tell by now i'm a big
blazer fan
here's something also it's very exciting
for blazer is when you've um
scaffolded up a
component or a form for instance you
know the modal model you supply must
require a value you don't want to have a
null string or an empty string in there
so here's a nice new
attribute called editor required so you
cannot so from this example screenshot
here you must assign a value to this
field and it'll get detected for you at
build time you can actually see here on
the screenshot as well the tooltip is
from within visual studio
before you even built
your application so that's doing it for
you at even coding types it's really
cool
moving on there's a very awesome
performance improvement here for when
you want to try and pass
data between the
net and javascript interrupt so instead
of the
the data being encoded in base64 which
essentially nearly doubles everything
you try and send they've optimized away
all that pain and that the decoding and
encoding of base64
directly into an unsigned integer array
for you so yeah that definitely will
make a massive improvement on passing
data between your.net
code and the javascript code
because it's all on the browser right so
c sharp and javascript living together
in a browser
love it
um like melissa mentioned earlier we've
got angular 12 and the asp.net core
templates have been updated to use
angular 12. so one line here but this is
a very big thing it's a lot of news for
angular 12 as well um so definitely go
and check that out if you're a front-end
developer
and speaking of front-end developers and
javascript
the minimal apis and top-level
statements that you have available in
net 6 and even with csharp9
this is sort of heading towards the very
minimalist minimalistic applications you
can write with node js and node express
rinses
so now you know they're also then adding
swagger support for all of this as well
so we can actually write some really
awesome little micro services or nano
services even if you want to call it
that
and we can then have it fully featured
with uh am
swagger or we're using the swashbuckle
extensions here to add that in a very
basic uh
code we need there to set it up and when
the application runs they've got a nice
little gif animation here for us or jiff
wherever you come from so
they navigate to the route here they
just
go to the swagger end point and here's a
swagger ui automatically built from the
exposed endpoints and fantastic so they
even got a slightly more fleshed out
example here uh for a few things that's
coming even for net six preview seven
which should be
just around the corner
now again with the multi the minimal
apis
when we have um
the
map.get.mapget when we're adding our
routes to our application we can even
inject services directly into the
um
the delegate here to you know implement
that route or responding to that request
so this is going to compress our
applications really really small it's
very nice very easy to see all the logic
that's going on there and i think this
is all going to be very very fun to use
what else have we got um there's a whole
bunch of security features around
signalr websockets for compression and
testing
is very exciting
and
delayed client certificate negotiation
should look into this one a bit more but
it seems interesting and a bit lower
level i could do some uh
buffering and draining the async okay
so definitely something for the security
people to check out
and
what we also have
that is very exciting for net six it's
not directly in this preview but for one
of the earlier previews i think preview
three
actually straight from preview one so we
had a
hot reload so directly in the
visual studio once you see here you've
got some code
you've got application running on the
side as well you've already pressed f5
you can go make a code change you can
click the hot reload button and that
would immediately
recompile that part of your application
and you can actually
see your code in action which is really
really cool
i want to point this out because for
again for the blazer developers
blazer web assembly this is going to get
better and better as well so currently
it doesn't support the razer files being
hot reloaded but hopefully soon that
will be the case
and
one more very exciting thing that
happened today outside of the
microsoftn.net world
but for melbourne very exciting is that
gcp has now opened up a region right
here in melbourne and that happened
earlier today it was very exciting for
google to announce this so please check
out this page here if you just google uh
google in melbourne
then you'll get this page um so you know
this definitely is if you have customers
in melbourne on gcp
this will be great for your customer
experience uh you know being right near
your customers is always good value
and that's it for me i will hand back to
melissa who's got one more exciting
piece of dev news
well that dev last piece of dev news is
going to have to wait until after our
next talk but we're going to go on to
our next speaker so next up we have phil
nash so phil nash is a developer
evangelist for twillow and a google
developer expert he's been around the
web playing with javascript and is
always working with new technologies and
writing open source code i always see
him online doing all sorts of really
cool stuff and he likes to make his own
beer which i think is really cool do you
have any beers you're making at the
moment phil no none right now no it's
been a little bit while since i did that
actually uh just enjoying the year the
the local breweries instead are at the
moment
awesome yeah definitely support local
melbourne has a lot of awesome craft
fairs
craft breweries that i've really been
enjoying checking out myself but today
he has an awesome talk about four steps
going from javascript to typescript
showing us how we can move an existing
javascript project onto typescript so
take it away phil i'm looking forward to
hearing what you have to say
thank you very much mal and hello ndc
melbourne i'm very excited to be talking
here i think this is the first time uh
in a long time i've given a conference
in the place uh that the conference is
uh even online located
so i'm kind of excited welcome from
melbourne um yeah as well said my name
is fonash uh i am a developer
advantagest at twilio uh if you don't
know twilio uh it is a communications
platform that is a whole bunch of apis
that you can use in your applications to
do things from sending text messages and
making phone calls all the way up to
video chat and full-on contact centers
if you ever want to know anything about
twilio or ask me any questions about
what i'm talking about today or whatever
find me online i'm all over the place uh
as phil nash
on the internet or just drop me an email
fillmash twilio.com i'd be happy to get
back to you but let's talk a little bit
thanks jerry
let's talk a little bit about moving to
uh moving things to typescript um
uh by the way do do shout out in chat uh
if you uh have any questions as we go
along while trying to answer things but
let's talk about movie to typescript i
do wanna first
start and clarify that uh i uh i
absolutely love javascript and that's
what i
have spent most of my career working
with uh it seems uh and that um
uh and so typescript has been an
interesting thing for me i mainly got
into javascript because i i didn't like
types uh but i'm at that stage of my
career apparently now where i'm back
into types again so i've got no problems
with javascript i love working with it
but
um what about typescript how about
moving to that and why would we want to
well modern javascript development i
mean i was working with javascript back
in the day when uh a single thousand
line uh javascript uh file was was
perfectly reasonable um and that was not
a great thing i guess uh but these days
in modern javascript we have bigger
projects we have bigger teams and you
know more tools
than ever to ensure that we are writing
uh code uh and writing our applications
correctly and can work well together
uh and timescape becomes just uh one uh
one of those tools of course um so there
are a bunch of reasons that you might
want to move to typescript
um
and that first one is of course type
safety and i know uh this is ndc uh so
there's probably a bunch of people
happy with uh
type safety in csharp and the whole.net
world and so
moving that into the javascript world as
well is an excellent thing
um the tooling around it as well um
i'm using vs code a lot and we'll see
that in a bit and just seeing that
tooling and things um
uh emerge and make things a lot easier
and we'll see as we go through demos
later is amazing uh refraction of course
um
becomes an important and easier thing to
do when we have that type safety uh
backing us up
regardless of who wrote that code in the
first place and ultimately i think all
of these things lead to confidence
confidence in our applications doing the
things that we want to do
um there are of course reasons not to
move to typescript
you know these are not the reasons to
choose to move to typescript if uh if
that makes sense uh you know so don't uh
uh don't if you are scared of the
learning curve or if you have a team of
developers who've
uh you know just got in involved in
javascript and uh and you're now trying
to shift them on straight to typescript
like there is a learning curve to go
this is not the same as writing
javascript
um
the overhead uh you may already have
quite a a build pipeline uh for your for
your existing javascript applications
and adding another tool in front of that
which is actually compiling all of your
code together
may well cause you problems so that that
is a good reason maybe not to move uh to
typescript
um don't move to typescript because it
gives you the idea that you don't need
tests um
like types are not a replacement for
tests uh i'll always always always say
that
um
and uh
and finally don't don't move to
typescript just to pick up new
javascript features uh firstly so many
of the new javascript features have
already made it into browsers or into
node.js depending on where you're
writing this
um
but otherwise there are other tooling
that you can use for that so you know
don't choose these reasons choose the
previous ones choose that confidence
but ultimately it is up to you and your
team
whether you want to move to typescript
and how you want to do it
but what i want to do is show you if you
have a javascript project right now uh
kind of four steps that you might take
that can lead you towards uh typescript
and and perhaps greater confidence in
that type
in that code base
so i have a demo application uh which
i'm going to quickly show you
it is a relatively simple node.js
application it's running a web server so
i have a a you know an index there
that's running the server i have a
server which is setting up some some
routes
and i have one single messages webhook
route
uh which is going to fetch a uh a dad
joke excellent from my uh from my dad
jokes uh file here so i always like to
keep myself amused whilst i'm working on
things like this
and so if i do
and so this is then uh it works with web
hooks so it's it goes through julio
because that's of course what i spend
most of my time dealing with uh but if i
send that message off it's gonna go
through this application and uh and get
me back a joke such as i am terrified of
elevators i'm gonna start taking steps
to avoid them
good
so
that is the application it doesn't do an
awful lot but it is you know there's a
bunch of javascript files that we can
move together
let's
carry on let's head on into step one
if you want to um move to typescript uh
one of the easiest things is to allow
your your tooling to kind of help you
get along that way
and as i said earlier i'm using um
vs code all the time these days and
absolutely love this code and the things
that it makes available to us and that
leads me to kind of the step one in
which typescript is built into vs code
right it's the typescript vs code it's
all microsoft
built and it's built in so we can use it
and it's available for us uh and what we
can do
uh and and it's the first thing that i
end up doing is uh head into settings
uh search for check js
and uh right here under javascript and
typescript we have implicit project
config that's a little small so i'll
read it out check js and this actually
allows the vs code itself to
employ the typescript compiler to check
check your javascript code uh to see if
typescript agrees whether it's uh uh
decent or not it can use jsconfig and ts
config files so i don't have those in
this project right now
but it has already thrown me up an error
so you can see a problem down at the
bottom or this little red tab up here
and i admit this is a this is not a bug
but it's something i snuck into uh to
the this project in the first place in
that uh this this uh function here does
not take any arguments
um it's like empty thing there but uh uh
vs code itself via the typescript
compiler has told has decided to show me
that i've made a mistake i've added an
argument to a non-uh argument-taking
thing so i can do that that's cleared my
problems uh and the application is fine
the thing is i don't have to clear that
problem uh it's just inside my editor
that these complaints are being made
and so
this is a really nice way to at least
have typescript via vs code in this case
check on your work
without kind of impacting
uh the end results necessarily uh you
know nothing's failing to compile here
there's no there's no compilation step
for the actual project it is just
checking and giving me warnings giving
me notifications about that
and so that's i think really cool um
there are some downsides to this
um
it is only in the editor so it's not
actually affecting the thing ultimately
and you can ignore any of those warnings
if you want to
it is native in vs code an atom but
not as far as i'm aware in other ids or
editors
if you do decide that this is an
important thing for you but then you
can't get over the fact that there's a
red squiggly line in there you can
include sort of typescript comments to
ignore lines or ignore entire files if
you want to uh but leaving typescript
comments in a javascript code base could
well be confusing to other developers on
your team if they're not on board with
with this change yourself
um
but i do recommend in general uh turn on
check.js globally uh in your editor if
you can all fight you know find if
you're in another uh editor find a a a
plug-in that's gonna work for you and do
this as well turn it on globally and
just have that extra check from uh the
type
from typescript type system and
why not it can only help improve your
code
so let's move on step two is actually to
get the typescript compiler involved
slightly
um this is time to actually install
typescript to your project uh installing
typescript using npm uh into your dev
dependencies and then initialize it with
uh npx tsc this is going to create you a
ts config file
tsconfig.json file that looks uh a bit
like this i mean it will have a bunch of
other options in it
there's a lot of commenting out there's
a lot of um good commenting and
documentation inside this file and
that's really useful however uh this tsc
init and this initial ts config file is
pretty much built for creating a
javascript project oh sorry a typescript
project from scratch and so it comes
with options like um
like these
ones um but we want to probably change a
few of them so for a start uh i'm going
to change the target from es5ps next and
what this means is that this is um
this is stopping the typescript compiler
doing any
um
cross compilation down to lower versions
of javascript or ecmascript i suppose in
this case um
because you may have your existing build
uh pipeline uh in between this uh we
don't actually want typescript to be
doing that work if you already have
babel involved we don't want typescript
to be doing that and then babel do it
again we can move that out but at this
point we're not we're not putting text
involved so keep it as es next and you
can use your existing pipeline as you
are
at this stage we want to put allow js
onto true this is because we still have
javascript files and in fact our entire
project is made of javascript files and
so we actually want those javascript
files to go through the typescript
compiler themselves
but for this stage we're going to turn
check js off this is actually the
opposite to our previous stair
but it's just allowing us to send our
javascript through the typescript
compiler and make sure it's okay we'll
also change
our root directory and out directories
to make sure that those are getting
right and we're going to turn strict to
false as well just to just to make sure
one other update we have to do once
we've added typescript uh to this is uh
is we're going to change um
change the
package.json couple of things here like
initially that main was probably sourced
in index.js now we're going to change
that to dist and add a couple of scripts
so that we can do this compilation and
i'm just going to go back to the
demo project and do that so i'm going to
npm install
to my development
dev dependencies typescript which
happened nice and quickly and then like
an npx tsc
init
and uh
that has created me a ts config file
cool
so like i said this has a load of
commenting in and that's really useful
uh but let's make our little changes
that we're gonna do let's not compile
away
um
uh some of the later javascript features
let's turn on allow js so js files can
go through the compiler but they won't
actually be checked for now
uh we're going to change our oops
router and outdoor so the outdoor we're
going to set it off to head to dist
and router is where the
files all are right now
uh and yes we don't want it to be
strict right now we'll get to what
strict does you know later
we've done that we now need to get into
the package json
because that is no longer going to be uh
this index and that's crashed my file
there because
nodemon now doesn't know what it's
looking at anymore in fact i don't have
a disk directory yet so that's fine
uh so i will need my extra scripts here
to both build
just to see and i like to have a watch
script as well you can pass
the watch argument through to the build
script but
that makes it easier
uh so if we do that i can then run npm
run watch in my bottom hand uh left hand
corner there that's going to do my
compilation
and nodemon now picks up the dist index
file
and my application is running again
and it's now being
uh typescript compiled not checked but
it's typescript is taking all the
javascript and then compiling it into
the dist directory
uh and and
we have our output here what's really
nice about this actually is if i go and
take a look at the output
really it hasn't changed uh anything
which is kind of nice um this is the
this is the output this is the original
source and all that's really changed is
my white space um you know which is fine
i'm okay with that i don't have to look
at
four spaces
which is too many spaces if you ask me
um
so it's putting it through there uh we
are making uh we are we're taking our
javascript and pushing it through the
typescript compiler without having to
check it
uh we can make sure this entire thing
works again and get ourselves another
joke as well i always like to
ensure things are still hilarious on the
dad joke side of things
uh why didn't the number four get into
the nightclub because he's too square of
course um
cool so yeah typescript is compiling our
application and it's not checking it
that's fine let's head back to the
slides
next up we actually want to bring that
checking back in of course like we've
managed to push our application through
the typescript compiler but it's not
really done anything and you know if you
have been previously pair programming
with vs code and with typescript uh in
the in your ide this stage is probably
not going to cause you too many problems
which is kind of nice
because you've already checked it and
ideally your your project is as a
javascript project that
typescript already agrees with
um
so in this case we now have to back in
and update our ts config to check the
javascript and make sure it's it's okay
and at this case this stage
you might find
that uh that things start to come up
with errors um now i
this has confused me recently because
this doesn't necessarily happen um but
uh typescript has either taken in all
the types for no node already or or it's
figured all this out for itself but uh
in the past this is definitely something
that's useful and uh and it's not
something i'm stopping doing yet uh so
you probably want to install the types
for for node itself uh that's if you're
doing a node project of course if you're
in the browser uh you maybe need
something different
um
but if we uh include the types there
these types come from the definitely
typed project uh if you've not heard of
that before it is a phenomenal open
source project to go alongside uh
typescript uh where where the community
decided that typing modules was um
uh was a job to be done and uh and
started uh creating all of these uh
under the app types um uh organization
uh in npm all the types the modules that
didn't have them already it's absolutely
wonderful i've got a link at the end of
this which gives you a history of uh
definitely types and it's a really
interesting read as a as an open source
project that also now has some kind of
guidance and and protection from the
actual typescript project
so let's go back and head into
dsconfig.json and we are turning checkjs
on
there we go
check stuff and see it's not complaining
but i will just for completeness uh
install uh types
mode to my dev dependencies um just to
make sure
and let's put that back into com
compilation
and we're away yes uh good so that is
now loaded again and uh
jokes should continue to come in now as
i said um because i ran this through
check js in the first place uh it is um
uh this this project is now actually
fairly happy uh if i was uh to put back
in my uh unnecessary
uh method uh that would actually stop
the compilation uh over the back there
so we've got an error and it would kill
it so we can take that back out again
and we're back online
cool so this is a nice easy one but
that's only because we we pair
programmed with vs code on step one
now we could stop here
at this point
the typescript compiler is taking the
javascript it's um
it is checking it and outputting it to
our disk directory and we have now as
best uh as it can typescripts uh thumbs
up appreciation for our javascript
um
and that's cool and we could you know
then start to work on our pipeline if
you did already have babel we could
change that out for um
compiling to es5 uh using our ts config
file if we wanted to we could stop there
um and there's actually some more
benefits to this uh we have type check
in the javascript we actually add
further type annotations using js doc so
we don't have to stop writing javascript
we can add extra types with js dock and
i think this is really cool and i'll
come back to in a second and finally you
actually don't need to output anything
either um this output disk directory
that's fine
but
if you don't output it it's still doing
the checks and you can still have like a
ci system or something fail
and this is actually what the webpack
project does or has been doing for a
while now um rather than uh
outputting to a disk directory
you can just have the no amit true um
setting uh that means it's not going to
emit anything but it is going to run the
compilation and check everything
and throw errors if it if it doesn't
work
so that's uh that's really useful uh and
a web web
when webpack did this they both caught
errors in the webpack
um code base and core errors in the
typescript code base at the same time
which i think is kind of a great
symbiosis between the the projects there
so at this point you could have
javascript um
your javascript application and you
still run the javascript that you wrote
but um
typescript is keeping an eye on it and
that's nice
and like i said jsdoc i think is kind of
amazing it's typescript without writing
typescript uh although uh it is with
writing some types
um js doc if you don't know looks a
little bit like this uh it's um
you know surrounded in comments and you
can set types on
for example
um a
just a just a variable here if we say
this is type string if later in our
program we try and set through to a
number or an object or something
timescript is going to have a problem
with it
and we can do the same functions um
typing the parameters and returns like
if you've ever been if you've used jstoc
to just document your code you're
actually a step ahead again here in
which um
you can
you can use the typescript compiler to
then take those types and work with them
so let's just show that uh in action as
well i'm going to go to my uh my actual
dad joke um
function here and
what i'm going to do well so we've seen
in the uh and in the slides there you
can just type regular uh
um
you can type regular uh
functions or um variables uh but what i
want to do is just uh i can create
myself a full-on type here i'm going to
create a dab joke type
uh and in this dad joke uh we're going
to have
a property
a property that's a string and it's a
joke
and it turns out that uh this api
actually returns two other things which
is an id
a string which is an id
and
and a property which is a string which
is a status
and we can know about that um what we
can say is uh that
uh if we just actually move this
slightly we can get the uh
we can get our dad joke const dad joke
uh his uh resolve body
uh and then we're gonna return uh dad
joke.joked
cool but we still don't know what this
actually is it's still down as any uh in
in typescript's mind but this is where
we can now actually type
uh this
right here we can just say the type is a
dad joke
and that is going to tell you know
typescript
and the compiler that this dad joke is
now a dad joke object and result uh and
dad joke.joke is a string
and that then flows back through our
application uh so this message becomes a
string
um
rather than uh before we before we added
the type oops where did it go before we
added the type i just commented out a
comment that's possible
before we added the type this is just
any
uh and you know removing any and and
adding types is pretty much our aim here
so we can be more confident with this
code
so yes uh this this message is now a
string and that is cool
uh you know we could also you know we
could be typing this function as well
i'm not carry on right now we've got
this new type and we're using it and it
is implying things about uh the
application
uh and and typescript knows about that
and so it can fail the build based on
this kind of thing as well and i think
that's that's pretty exciting typescript
without actually writing typescript just
just by documenting your code
um
coming out of code isn't that anyway um
step four moving to actual typescript um
finally right we could have stopped at
that last step and i kind of like that
but if you really really want to go all
in on the whole thing uh then we need to
move our javascript files into
typescript files and uh
and
do do something with that
um i'll just go back to the code for
this because i'm to start at the top i'm
going to start the end kind of of our
things and start changing just change
this
file
to ts
and when you do that
it now has problems uh because
a couple of reasons one um typescript
wants to work with es6 imports
uh so i'm going to change that to import
super agent
from
um
and then we want to export the same
thing as well so um
uh in this case i'm going to export this
as default uh that's where it came from
and that's fine that's now a typescript
file which is working for me that's cool
and these types from jstoc is still
applying which is also cool but um web
hooks which is importing uh the dad joke
is now having a problem with this it's
like this doesn't exist and that's just
because of a difference between default
exports and um
setting module exports to a to a
function or an object
um
so what we can do here is either uh if
we want to keep
this in javascript for now because at
this point we're quite good because
we've got because in our typescript
config file we are both allowing
javascript and checking it and we're now
sending typescript files through um
uh
we can we can actually have this hybrid
application uh but in order to do that
we do just have to
um
change our default uh import there to
require default and that's made it work
uh compiling happily at the bottom there
and we've moved one of our files to
typescript it's pretty cool
um but let's move let's move another
couple let's uh let's rename that to ts
and see if anything else comes up
uh there's a bunch of them imports that
i have to uh
i have to change
let's see how far i get with this
um
yeah we'll input that as well
just know that the next line is not an
import and it's uh
confusing otherwise uh and then we can
actually let's let's import our gadget
properly
um magic module properly uh from there
and we don't need defaults anymore
cool
and one more time we need to
uh export that properly as well
and that's going to change it in the
server now and it's going to have a
problem but i'm just going to set that
to default right now i don't i don't
think we have time necessarily to go
through all of our all of our files
right now but uh you can see um you know
this is a nice one we can change like
rather than exporting a whole uh module
we can change this to export default
port
equals that you know this is something
you may not have to have changed either
in your in your application if you are
building with esps modules
um
fault const of course
and once you do that
not happy with me
well all right i'm getting that wrong
today
um
i would like to undo that and just put
it back to whatever it was before
because
really i've got something wrong anyway
moving on um we now have our partial
typescript partial javascript uh
application and we can continue working
through this
um
as as bits of the application become
good for
time for refactoring or working on we
can change this to ts move it if you
need to change default imports then you
can change those as we get through um
but
this is quite good
um i don't think we're done just yet
though we have we have moved to
typescript but strict mode then becomes
uh of importance to us
uh because we turned that off originally
and strict is allowing us to do a whole
bunch of things right now that uh maybe
we wouldn't want it to
and so ts config and typescript actually
has a bunch of strict options um
uh such as no implicit any and this is
probably one that you will find you are
failing all over the place uh no
implicit any uh means that you can't
kind of import or use or return just um
the any type um without being explicit
about it
uh and so we'll see in a minute that we
are already importing a bunch of uh
implicit enemies uh we don't want to we
don't do that um there are a bunch more
options here and i recommend you kind of
read through them the nice thing about
our ts config file is that we can just
kind of uncheck them one by one pick the
ones that we think are important to us
uncheck them or sorry or
turn them on
until we get all of them done and then
we can just turn on strict mode and
we're fine
now
let's go and have a look at that i'm
going to put strict mode on in my ps
config
uh let's let's i'm going to enable it
for everything there's not too many
problems here but i should see a problem
coming up
there we go
so over here in my in my dad jokes um
module
i am
importing uh an implicit any effectively
there's no types there's no declaration
for what super agent is
um super agent is my http
uh module here in this case um but i
don't have any types for it so this is
sort of implicitly any
so if i just uh npm install um
and again this is one that definitely
type has uh sorted out so i've got app
typed and this is a bit small at the
bottom of my screen but i'm importing
sorry installing app types uh super
agent
run my compilation step again and it is
now happy with me cool
um
yes and so we actually have this whole
uh type system set up for it
now the thing is like full streak mode
is not required uh it's not required in
typescript um
uh
you know it depends on how far you want
to take uh the abilities of typescript
through to your application uh it can be
a goal
and that's the point
strict mode
in it's in its absolute strictness uh
when we are changing an application over
from this making that a goal of the uh
of the eventual transition um will allow
you to have typescript do as much
checking as it possibly can but in the
meantime as you are moving it does not
have to be that full strictness uh if
you are starting an application in
typescript i recommend like setting
strict mode to true from the very
beginning and that way uh you know
typescript can do its best work all the
time
and then we can start adding more types
once we're done with this we can add
more types now we have already uh we've
already sort of started typing up um our
dad joke uh here uh but now we can
actually make it sort of type script
official
right and we can instead uh make an
actual type
um
which you know we'll have a
joke which is a string and then we've
got you know an id which is a string and
a status which is a string
and we start to get um typescript to uh
get into our actual application here and
now we can
specifically say that this is a bad joke
um the result is that um
i one thing i wanted to mention actually
about um
uh turning strict mode on is that uh
things like um
ah yeah i'm gonna show you this just
quickly because i forgot about it
um
one of the strict modes is that uh
this function here uh you know
may return a string but if something
goes wrong it's just gonna log and
return nothing uh or undefined uh but
over here typescript is just like now
fine it's a promise original string
we're not we're okay with this um moving
to strict mode um
maybe the strict mode is going to mean
that that actually now understands that
it is a promise
uh which is a string and could be
undefined um which is which is fine uh
so we know we should handle that so here
we can you know this is what this uh
conditional is for handling in case we
don't get a message back
uh and not crashing the application
um
so yeah now i'm now i'm returning the
stat joke
uh properly and we know that's going to
be a string and the result is string
undefined uh so you know we can start
typing uh this function as well which is
cool because we are taking nothing and
returning a promise
that will eventually be a string or
undefined
um
nice uh so we're starting to see more
and more types i'd like to go back to
the webhooks one as well because we can
start typing things like uh
our routes here
so we could we can add from express we
can get its request and response types
uh and whilst the request here is not
that useful in terms of typing it
because we're not actually using it in
this particular version the response is
quite good because we can start at
responses to generic type and we can
start telling this that ultimately the
response will be called with a string or
indeed
undefined
um and that is you know either a string
here
or right at the bottom oops
right at the bottom if we don't respond
with any actual text
[Music]
move the g over somehow
um
and that's important because if we then
try and return a number for example it
is also going to have a problem with
that and like you said this is going to
be a string or nothing at all and now we
have a number uh and so we can keep
adding these things um as we move on
through our application just adding more
and more types and and just beefing up
the power and the understanding of of
typescript's
compiler
yeah
finally um we've got to uh
if you're doing in library development
this is an important one um
uh especially if you're moving a library
from from javascript to typescript
is to
in the compiler options in ts config.js
and put that declaration to true
and that's going to once you've compiled
and output the javascript it's also
going to output those.d.ts
declaration files which um you know
provide typescript types to
the rest of the ecosystem uh super
important there
so we made it and you know i i i feel
like that deserves one more one more uh
dad joke just to uh just to end uh the
fact that we've turned this project
almost entirely into typescript uh i've
got a few files there to go
um but there you go what do you call a
cow in her legs it's ground beef
excellent um
we made it let's have a recap let's have
a look back at what we did
um so first up pair program with
typescript this is something you can
turn on in any project even projects
that you uh in any javascript project
even javascript projects that you have
no wish to turn into a typescript
project in the end of the day uh adding
uh
turning on in vs code or in atom check
js and the typescript thing or finding
another ide a plugin that will add
typescript checking for you turn on
check js and it will give you those
warnings to tell you um that typescript
might not agree with this and because
it's only in your editor it's just
telling you as you program with it and
so you can take that and use it as you
will but
for the most part typescript is normally
right about things
um
step two we can then uh get the
typescript compiler involved at this
point it's about
making sure your application can go
through the compiler um
with all the javascript files you
already have uh and and you're re-kind
of reasserting how your application uses
that so you then have your your output
uh file uh your output directory as well
as the input directory
and we start working running the output
file but uh but working on the input
directories uh that's still all working
in javascript still but typescript is
just taking a quick pass through and
pushing it out somewhere else
step three then becomes making sure that
typescript compiler will fail if uh if
there is javascript that fails its type
situations um so checking javascript and
as i said we can stop here it's what a
bunch of projects do and it's real
useful to kind of show
um
that typescript agrees with this but
we'd still only write it in javascript
and at this point again we can use jsdoc
and
and typescript is going to read those
types and listen to them and then
finally move those javascript files to
typescript files uh if you have requires
uh if you have common.js requires move
them to esx imports
and
and then start adding more types
until you are happy with your system
so i've got a demo repo i've got this uh
application uh it even shows the thing
that i couldn't apparently do right
myself faster i was trying to change the
config file to typescript uh but check
this out i'll link all of these in the
slides uh which i'll publish later um
we have the demo repo here there are
some really good resources if you want
to take a more slower and at your own
pace read through this then actually my
colleague dominic
wrote the blog post uh read a blog post
on this under on the twilio blog go
check that out it also has another
example project that you can kind of
work with and work through
as well
if you want to know more about using
jsdog to js doc to add superpowers to
your javascript and and use typescript
without actually using typescript uh
check out uh stefan baumgartner's
um blog post on this uh just search for
typescript.typescript that normally
brings it up
uh and
then uh typescript actually has uh the
typescript documentations has a bunch of
uh javascript projects that use
typescript so that's like web webpack uh
and other projects that use typescript
but don't actually
get written in typescript they just use
the compiler to check their work
it's really uh it's really interesting
to see what the people do
uh some other move other links like i
said this uh earlier definitely typed is
an amazing project uh but it um given
its importance to the uh to the entire
ecosystem
has been through a lot so go check out
the uh the the blog post or definitely
type the movie
uh and then finally eric elliott uh
published quite a good uh blog post on
the typescript tax uh and this is uh
this is sort of interesting if you want
to look into
uh those reasons that you wouldn't move
to typescript as you're weighing up this
decision if that's the kind of thing
you're going for
um so that's all i've got for you uh
this afternoon um thank you so much for
joining me to talk uh about uh about
typescript but moving javascript
projects to typescript um i hope you
enjoy the rest of ndc melbourne and as i
said before uh hit me up online i'm uh
phil nash everywhere all over the
internet or drop me an email at fallout
twitter.com other than that thank you so
much and yeah enjoy the rest of the day
thank you
thank you so much phil can i just say
that i absolutely love that you used a
dad joke api for your demo i'm gonna
have to start using that in all of my
future demos and we do have a question
on slido so this is a question from
david it says as you convert should you
aim to get rid of all anys in your code
or are some of them okay
oh that's a good one um
our sum n is okay because of course uh
the ts config like no no implicit any
just means just stops you from uh like
not acknowledging that there's an any um
but uh but having some enemies i don't
think you can uh entirely get rid of
them
um it's a it's an interesting one i mean
if you think about an api result like um
uh like calling off to an api
uh that is bringing you back uh
something you expect to exist uh in the
form that you can give it a type of but
really it starts as an n e anyway um now
we we merge into something that then
looks like an object that we have but um
uh you know you can never get rid of
everything especially the edges of your
systems
um on the other hand
i think it's a
it's a good aim to
to kind of remove that as much as
possible
again it's as much as moving everything
to strict mode is not uh the ultimate
necessarily
not necessarily your ultimate goal but a
useful thing same for kind of removing
uh nes as well i think if it's useful
for you to to ensure that this is in
fact this type then
then yeah get rid of it that's where i
go with it
yeah sounds good
good take uh look i absolutely love to
talk i'm definitely gonna go check out
all those resources that you shared with
us so so thank you very much for joining
us today phil
and next we're going to have another fun
little quiz so i will be handing over to
our next quiz master which is william
welcome william
hello melissa thank you very much yes we
have the melbourne quiz
so but before we kick that off i would
just like to have another word from our
sponsors
[Music]
the idea behind distinguished engineers
is really to assemble a diverse team of
our top level engineers and some of the
best engineering minds on the planet to
really solve the most complex problems
both for cba and for our customers our
distinguished engineering program
started internally by us having a good
look at who'd really shown
amazing engineering leadership or
technology leadership already inside the
group and we basically started
assembling those people and focusing
them on really important problems both
for us and our customers
[Music]
i get to actually roll up my sleeves and
actually really help solve some really
tricky problems in the bank one of the
big challenges we have right now in x15
is how do we get small teams of
engineers to be able to within just like
a few months go for an idea and get it
into our customers hands if we can crack
that i think that's an incredibly tough
engineering problem but also means that
we can make a massive difference in
australia
[Music]
one of the main reasons that engineering
is important at combank is just the
scale of impact that we have across
australia for commonwealth bank we're
the largest lender in australia and so
the scale and importance of digitizing a
process like that has an impact on all
australians the thing for me that's
really appealing about engineering at
combank is the combination of really
important problems for australia and
really difficult engineering problems
[Music]
hello everybody
so i hope you like my uh cat in the hat
hat
so need to wear this when we're doing
quizzes so
what i'd like you to do is head over to
slido.com
and type in the event code ndcmel
in this email
and
i'm going to
get the quiz started i'll wait for you
to join so if you join please put in uh
something that we can identify you with
preferably like a twitter handle
and
we'll give everyone a bit of time to to
join in
now to be aware of if you're watching
this on the live stream
there is a 20 or more second delay so
please use the slider.com site directly
so you're going to have the up-to-date
results you're going to be in the race
to win one of these awesome hoodies
hey lars
eliza's got the
next best hat it's covered in glitter
once you have glitter on you'll never
ever get that off so
okay so we've got 16 people
joined already so let's give you
another let's say another 20 seconds or
so now this quiz is all about melbourne
uh for our audience that is not from
melbourne
might be a little bit tough but i think
you could probably learn something about
melbourne and when all these
restrictions and everything uh go away
come visit us it'll be great
all right we're 21 22 participants yeah
people are jumping in great great great
we got uh some familiar names i think
people have come back from the first
round to try and win another hoodie
more advertising
cool cool i'm just covered in glitter
now
stay away
all right all right 24 24 okay slowing
down i think uh
we are good to 25 oh last minute sergey
i think i'm just guessing someone just
joined in
okay
you guys ready
let's do it
starting the quiz right now
which church would you find opposite a
train station a pub
and federation square
got four options
well some quick starters there
and i think
there is no timer on this quiz so we i
will be timing this
a little bit uh
let's just judge by that and see how the
answers are coming in i think it has
stabilized
all right let's lock the voting
go on to the next question
the popular choice from everybody was
saint paul's cathedral
right or saint patrick's cathedral let's
see which one was the winner
saint paul's cathedral there we go so
let's see
who is in the lead first up
oh there's no leaderboard oh i think
this is going to be interesting have to
wait till the end
next question
the area's longest river in melbourne
but how long is it
oh yeah split between the choices here
this is going to be interesting
all right
all right we've got some people coming
in trying to figure this out
still jumping up and down a little bit
no okay i think we are now stable
oh one more change who goes in for the
last second
gotta be quick all right let's lock in
the votes let's see popular guess is 242
kilometers
was it the correct one is it 224 it is
cool cool
yeah let's see what's next
which well-known melbourne market is
named after a famous queen
and there are four queens
here we go let's see
[Music]
i can see the results coming in live
it's very exciting
big surprise this one all right
there we go let's lock that in i think
everyone's voted
and
everyone likes queen victoria is that
correct
sure is this is the there's the queen
victoria market here in melbourne it's
very famous everyone knows it and uh
a lot of cool things you can get there
next question
what was melbourne's original name
some interesting names there i'm sure
we've heard of all of them actually
i like the way some people think
it's getting more interesting i like
this
all right
all right here we go let's lock this one
in
and popular choice
batmania
was it gotham was it smallville or
central city i think the answer is
batmania
doesn't mean batman is from melbourne
but you know it would have been cool if
he was
and where would i find the eternal flame
in fed square the shrine of remembrance
south bank or in odin's vault in asgard
what do you think it is
oh i can see people changing their mind
it's interesting
you're not googling the answers are you
i hope not
all right
oh very last second vote here let's lock
it in
what have we got
all right
federation square is a real place trying
to remember in
south bank odin's vault i'm sure it's
real somewhere
so
uh shrine of remembrance a very uh
beautiful site here in melbourne if you
haven't been there go and check it out
it is uh
definitely worth seeing
now but sport which team won the afl
grant final in 2020 last year so for the
footy fans this should be an easy one
and uh
let's see let's see oh
good guesses some good guesses going on
here
[Music]
there might be a couple of rugby fans in
here as well let's see
if you guys could see the answers i'm
seeing oh yeah it's very exciting
all right let's uh let's lock that in
at popular choices richmond and i think
yes richmond won from memory i think
they're roughly 31 32 points that they
won over geelong
very exciting game let's see what
happens uh
this year we don't have long to go
every year in melbourne uh hosts the
australian tennis open
which stadium is home to center court
some popular ones there
hmm
may have made this one a bit easy
or everyone from melbourne is playing
the game
okay and we're nearly there we're nearly
there
let's see
okay i think i am ready to lock it in
here we go what was the popular choice
rod laver arena was 90 percent of
choices and yes it is the correct one
rod labor is home to the ato
australian tennis open not the tax
office
according to the crimes act of 1958
in melbourne you may not
do in some of these things
why do you think it is
there's some crazy options there
what do you think it is
i'm sure this is going to trip a few
people over oh yes oh yes
you sure you want to answer what you've
got in there
answers are very split
i think this is the one people are
getting the most the answers are jumping
in and out it's pretty cool
oh neck and neck all right i think we've
stabilized here i'm going to
oh no no people are still thinking about
it
oh keeps changing that's interesting
i'm giving you too much time you're
googling the answers
it's okay if you do i had to
all right i'm gonna lock this one in
here we go uh popular choices you're not
allowed to trade with a pirate
drive a goat
uh attached to a vehicle that kind of
sounds weird or change a light bulb
without an electrical license wear pink
pants or all of the above
well the answer is you're not out of
trade with a pirate according to the
crimes act of 1958 but in fact all of
those things are all illegal in
melbourne you're not allowed to do that
pirate
[Laughter]
and uh let's see what have we got
fine i think is the final question in
which month is the melbourne cup held
each year
let's see
hmm
might be the favorite month of the year
for some people
[Music]
the leaderboard is going to be very
interesting we don't see the leaderboard
yet it's gonna be a big surprise i think
the top three
players gets to win an awesome hoodie
okay okay i think we have stabilized the
answers let's lock it in
all right popular choice is november
followed by september
let's see what happened
who won
if you chose november you win which is
great let's see what's next
oh there's one more question in which
year did melbourne host the summer
olympics
there's a whole lot of years there i'm
sure you can work that one out
hmm
this must have been in the news recently
if everyone's picking the same one
or everyone's just very good at history
this is interesting
this definitely must have been in the
news
okey dokey i don't think any
there's no one changing their mind on
this one
all the votes have gone in and let's
lock it in
all right popular choice 1956 was it
correct
sure was there you go everyone knew that
answer that was great so let's find it
now we can see the leaderboard who was
on top
nelson 10 out of 10
matt 88 10 out of 10 tim comport 10 out
of 10. so there's three the three top
players all win an awesome hoodie ndc
branded hoodie
great thanks for playing everybody so i
have to remind you there is more prizes
to win today
go to the
expo.ndcmalman.com page check out the
sponsors fill in your details we're
going to draw some prizes at the end of
the day and uh definitely looking
forward to that as well so um
now next we have
pete meyer so i can take off my hat
let's change my fashion
hey pete how are you going hey william
doing well
i was tempted to join you in that
in that quiz but it would be a little
unfair being a melbourne myself
you should already have a hoodie though
right
i think it's in the mail
it's on its way
now pete you've got an awesome piano in
the background there
i i thought you were more of a data guy
rather than a like musician you know i'm
multi-talented believe it or not
all right so can you play it for us a
sort of power bi jingle on that piano at
the end of the session
oh look you put me on the spot so the
answer is today no
with a formula
i'm concerned that i don't even have
enough time to talk about all of the
awesomeness that i want to talk about
i've had a peek at your your talk
abstract this so you're going to be
talking to us about
power bi and some rich interactive
visualizations so can you give us a
quick hint uh tip of what's coming up
right so so if you're familiar with
power bi awesome um if you're not in the
shortest possible definition it is a
data visualization service
now the topic that i have is how can we
take those awesome data visuals and
embed them into our apps and why would
we do it and uh and if we do need to do
it how could we go about it and that's
really what i'm looking to explain in
this 45 minute session
sounds great i'm looking forward to it
as well i'm very very interested in all
of this visualization stuff
so please pete take that away
i will do um from a point of view of the
microphone is that all sounding good on
your end
i'm going to take that that was a yes so
yes from me it sounds perfect like loud
and clear fantastic all right so are we
sharing my presentation
there we go power bi embedded analytics
explained so welcome
my name is peter myers and i'm very
privileged to be speaking here at ndc
melbourne
and so let me briefly introduce myself
so i work for my own company bitwise
solutions i am a data platform
specialist with a focus on business
intelligence and i've been working
alongside microsoft for well over 20
years now
originally as an instructor and an mdt
teaching people about sql server 2000
but having evolved alongside microsoft
stack you know that's meant a journey of
not just sql server bi but moving into
office bi with excel and powerpivot and
in more recent years of course the
evolution of power bi which is the
leading you know data analytics service
available in the market today
so
many years ago i was a developer and in
fact i remember being on a project the
very day that.net got released that was
some date in february 2002
um so this topic brings the worlds
together of a developer and
business intelligence
and so what i would like to do is know a
little bit more about who you are and
this could be intriguing um what i have
here is a survey um you can either use
the bitly link across the top
or the qr code and you'll be presented
with i think four questions that tell me
a little bit about who you are
uh this is important for my
demonstration so i need some data you're
going to help me
go ahead answer the questions as
honestly as you can click submit and
then what you'll see before you hear is
a power bi dashboard that has been
configured for real time all right so as
you click submit we should see some
results coming up here in the dashboard
so i'll give you a moment to tell us
about who you are by your role your
country your power bi experience and
what would be the most important topic
for you in this presentation
yes
all right so far count of seven coming
in uh so as a data visualization service
it has a full capability to deliver
real-time analytics as well
this is being delivered through what we
know as a push data set um so
programmatically using the power bi rest
api we can push rows of data into a data
set and a dashboard will reflect
real-time updates
you can also leverage azure stream
analytics or there are other
capabilities like direct query modeling
that provide you automatic page refresh
all right so as these numbers come in i
get a grip um mainly aussies in the
audience which probably makes sense
given the time zone
uh but we see some from europe some from
africa
looking at the by role
really it's not a surprise here for this
conference that software developers are
the major group of people so welcome it
is a session targeting software
developers and in particular app
developers looking to embed analytics in
their apps
now as the results are coming in um
take a look at the column chart along
the bottom that tells me about your self
rating for power bi and welcome to those
eight that have confessed that they have
no background in power bi and that's
certainly a great starting point for
this presentation because i'll launch
into the fundamentals in just a moment
uh right up to the fact that we've got
some um
uh ninjas
all right so
a question that someone might have when
looking at this dashboard could well be
yes but what is
the average power bi experience
okay so as those results are still
coming in
what i can do is
close the full screen mode and at the
top left you'll see that i can ask a
question of the data
and power bi has its own
uh
what can we say it's like a search
engine you can sort of enter a natural
language question like what is the
average power bi experience look at the
way power bi already suggests
and the answer that question could be
delivered to me here as a single value
and because that's a value that i want
to monitor over time i can at the top
right corner click pin the visual and
then i can pin it back to the dashboard
whereupon
that can now be monitored now as to why
it said 6.5 and now it's 2.74
i think the 6.5 was my earlier test that
it cached the result but the genuine
result based on the fact that we have 35
submissions is that we're looking
somewhere between a rating of 2 and 3.
now just returning to q a the map is a
great visual but sometimes it doesn't
give you the detail at a glance you want
so i could also say
what were the
you know
survey count
by country
and i can see here that 30 from
australia next runner-up we're looking
at germany by two ethiopia india and
norway so welcome and thanks for
participating in that survey uh the
other thing i'll point out is that this
is a power bi dashboard um yet when i
click on a tile what power bi is doing
here is navigating or clicking through
to
an underlying report okay so we can see
the same data as a report this is a very
different experience
while it may look similar
the report is designed for interactivity
of your end users and so often when
embedding power bi visualizations into
apps it is going to be the report not
the dashboard but a report experience
and a report comprises one or possibly
multiple pages but just look what i can
do here by clicking on the bubble for
australia this is what we know as a
cross highlight so from australian
uh survey results i can see that 19
of the 20 software developers are
australian and i also get an idea here
across the power bi experience including
that the average self rating for
australians is 3.09
if we try that again one more time and
we've got a couple of people from
germany then i can see here that the two
people from germany that have come in uh
have given themselves a self rating of
zero and three giving us that average of
1.5
now page two of the report
um gives me an idea about what is most
important for you so the top ranking
topic for you in today's session is the
fundamentals of power bi not surprising
given the eight of you were coming in
with zero experience the next one is
power bi embedded fundamentals which
really is the heart and the soul of what
i'm going to talk to you about in these
45 minutes and client apis will be
covered and data permissions will be
covered as
well all right so switching back to my
presentation
that pretty much sets me up for an
agenda of introducing power bi and power
bi embedded and then describing the
client apis and how data permissions can
work
i'll wrap up quickly with a discussion
of automating solution management
leave you with some resources and then
open up for any questions that you might
have
and by the way i'll be sharing a link at
the end of the presentation that will
allow you to download a pdf document of
these slides including any links that
i've included
so let's begin from the very beginning
about what power bi is
so i've already mentioned that it's a
data visualization service
and so it's from microsoft
if you're already working with microsoft
and microsoft 365 that you've got your
outlook and your whole productivity
suite set up power bi works within the
very same tenant of microsoft 365.
bottom line is this the most common way
to use power bi is as a cloud service
is that you're going to
publish data to the service
and uh the way that you create these
data solutions would be using a tool
like power bi desktop which is a freely
downloadable uh application for windows
uh and thereupon that tool does two
things it allows you to connect to your
data and create a model over your data
and a model is a way of taking your
source data and structuring it in a way
that's going to support the analytic
requirements that power bi needs
it also allows you to create more
friendly and intuitive experiences to
support your application users when
navigating through the data
when power bi desktop creates these data
solutions they are published to the
service they become what is known as a
data set and then that data set becomes
the source of data for reports and
potentially dashboards
now just a word about keeping that data
current
if those data sources are accessible by
the internet then generally speaking
power bi can on an automated frequency
can refresh the data to keep it current
or if you're working with data behind
your firewall on premises
there are gateways that you can install
allowing power bi to securely
communicate with that data as and when
needed lastly from an access point of
view my demonstration there with the
dashboard was using what we call the
power bi service which is really just a
web portal so any of the major supported
web browsers so we're talking edge
chrome firefox safari
all you need to do is go to powerbi.com
sign in to get access to your data
there are native mobile apps as well for
ios and for
android so it's pretty simple just to
install them from their respective
stores sign into power bi to gain access
to your reports and dashboards
but really what we're here to talk about
is beyond
the portal and beyond the native apps is
that you can embed rich analytics
directly inside your own apps
so from a product portfolio perspective
i'm just going to touch off on the
authoring perspective there are two free
tools that you will use to create and
publish your solutions to power bi the
power bi service is critical because it
is the service that hosts your data and
is responsible for all of the rendering
and delivery of reports
power bi premium is a license
available to you and it could become
relevant depending on the scenario that
you use to embed more on that coming
soon in this presentation
power bi report server doesn't deserve a
mention here because it's an on-premises
delivery of power bi
especially targeting customers that
perhaps aren't ready for the cloud or
there are some
legal or governance concerns about using
the cloud
it doesn't form part of my discussion
today
lastly and highly relevant to what i'm
talking about is that power bi embedded
is a product
allowing you to package up rich data
visualizations embed them in your apps
okay so let's start the discussion then
with embedded analytics
so
in the digital workplace embedded
analytics should occur within a natural
workflow we don't like the idea of
sending users outside your app
potentially to get distracted by doing
something else and forgetting what
they're doing so there shouldn't be this
need to continue to move in and out of
apps
yet statistics are telling us that up to
22 of employees um are accessing the
data that they need to make informed
decisions
they're having to
you know either do without good data to
make a decision or they're having to
move outside the environment so as a
minimum requirement what you're looking
to deliver is obviously good quality
up-to-date credible consistent data and
then the best way to communicate from
data to your users um is often through
data visualization it's far easier at a
glance to gain an understanding of the
data than it is to look at a lot of
detail or a lot of numbers and attempt
to make sense of them and of course the
last requirement would be that you've
got some app that has some genuine
requirement to have data visualizations
embedded
so what it comes down to is this
is that you have basically two options
the first option is well do you build it
do you go and create these data models
and these visualizations from scratch
and yes you can do it and perhaps you've
done this or you've been reliant
um on this in the past but your
experience might well tell you that it's
very time consuming and therefore
expensive and it's a shift of focus of
what you're really there to do as an app
developer
so the other option is
just buy it
so if an existing service exists then
embed it and this approach is simple and
easy and faster time to market
cost effective and of course as a
product like power bi evolves which it
does very rapidly you know it's in its
sixth year but still we're seeing month
by month incremental new features taking
the product to even higher levels
so you can leverage those new features
in your app as and when they're released
so now would be a great time to switch
from the fundamentals of power bi to
talk about well what is power bi
embedded
so what it means is that power bi
content whether it's a power bi
dashboard
or a report
or even that q a experience where the
natural language can be used for by the
user to look for the answers that they
need
this is often
good because sometimes as an app
developer you may not know what
questions to answer
there are probably some obvious
questions to answer and you can build
pre-built reports and dashboards to
support that but what about the other
questions that you haven't anticipated
well the answer is that power bi would
let you embed q a into your app to allow
that free form questioning
so power bi embedded lets you embed rich
visualizations into your apps
you can embed any power bi content and
essentially it works by adding an iframe
to your web page
it relies on web standards like html5
and javascript and it works in web apps
mobile apps and even thick client
applications
as i'll describe shortly you can then
seamlessly integrate power bi content
using the power bi client apis
now there are sdk resources to support
you
uh and different development platforms
so officially.net.net
javascript and typescript and there are
also samples available in nodejs python
and java so they can provide you a quick
start or a great educational experience
to take an existing solution and perhaps
reverse engineer it to learn from it
there are five different types of
content that you can consider embedding
in your apps the reports
or even a single visual from a report
page
power bi also supports paginated reports
and if you already have background in
sql server reporting services you can
think of paginated reports in power bi
as being the new generation of sql
server reporting services in fact it's
almost identical there are a couple of
things that are different but you can
think of them as being the same and
therefore paginated reports hosted in
the power bi servers can also be
embedded in your app
next we have dashboards like the
dashboard used to
analyze your survey inputs
or a single tile from a dashboard even
if it's real time can be embedded in
your app and lastly the q a experience
now one other thing to point out here is
that if you're going to embed power bi
reports which by the way is the most
common content type of power bi to embed
in an app
is that it can also
be used as a creation experience so your
app can allow users to create new
reports
or edit reports and save them back
all right so it's not necessarily just a
consumption experience
now there's an important distinction to
be made that when you're embedding
content is it being embedded for your
organization in other words for the
users in your org or
is it for your customers and the
difference comes down to um
development methodology will differ but
licensing okay so just to cover off on
what it means that if you're embedding
power bi for your organization they're
basically users within your org right so
from a licensing point of view it's very
straightforward they just need the
licenses to act access the content and
therefore from an app perspective
there's no special consideration for
licensing
or to pay anymore
the point is that if they can access the
content through the
power bi service in the web portal or if
they can use a native app
excuse me a mobile app then they've got
permission already so the reason that
you might consider embedding for your
organization is that you want to create
a custom experience rather than relying
on microsoft's portals
all right so it's targeted at your
internal users authentication happens
through azure id
end users will require power bi
licensing
it uses an interactive authentication
flow and in documentation you might see
this being discussed as the user owns
the data scenario
now the other scenario targets more the
isv
and that is for your customers where the
user base are external users and this
allows your app to use its own
authentication store and its own methods
and the
whole concept here is that your end
users do not have licenses to access the
power bi content
it uses a non-interactive authentication
flow using either service principle or
what's known as a master user
and it goes by the name of app owns data
so the difference
is
internal users versus my app users do
not have access to the power bi content
that we're hosting
all right generally speaking from a
development methodology and just to fast
track the flow that might take place is
that in power bi you'll create what's
known as a workspace and a workspace is
a container for power bi content
and it allows you to
prepare your data and to create reports
dashboards and so on it is also a
security boundary so you'll provide
sufficient security for your app to gain
access to the content within the
workspace
next you're going to build up that
content so at a minimum you need some
data and perhaps one report if not more
then you need to move into
azure and you need to register an azure
ad application which will be used as
part of the authentication flow in your
app
to
bring in the required libraries you'll
import various nougat packages and i
have a slide on that shortly
in your web app you'll configure app
settings that set the settings to the
power bi service endpoints but also set
the workspace that
contains the content that you're looking
to embed and other identity information
what is the identity that will be used
by my app to authenticate with power bi
on behalf of users and to gain access to
content
next you're going to then add that
iframe into your web page
and
with client-side libraries you're going
to call methods that are going to embed
content now what will happen server-side
is it's going to have to embed tokens
that gain access to content so the first
thing is authentication requires an
access token if you're embedding on
behalf of your customers
then the additional development step
will be to generate what's known as an
embed token and that embed token
represents claims for particular power
bi content on behalf of the user
next you can enhance the user experience
so you can do whatever it takes to embed
that in a meaningful way and we'll talk
about this in a little more detail when
i come to the client apis
and then lastly configuring data
permissions now actually security should
never be a last consideration but in the
list here
data permissions comes down to the fact
that your user base might all have
access to the same reports but not
necessarily to the same data
and so therefore it's possible to use
what we call effective identity to limit
data visibility for various users for
example the manager has the ability to
see all of the data that individuals can
only see their specific projects that
they're working on all right so we'll
talk about that in a bit more detail
shortly
now
just to
provide you some resources that if you
are looking to explore this there are
some sample solutions available on
github and i'll share the links with you
shortly and when you go into the sample
solutions you can either
download a zip file containing a
pre-built solution to embed for your
customers or to embed for your
organization
all right
sorry by the way there's a workflow set
up so you can follow i think four to
five different steps and the result of
you setting everything up perhaps
uploading your own content or using
sample content the result is it will
download a zip file that contains a
visual studio solution and everything
set up ready to go
all right so
once we've got the embed happening
there's quite an amazing suite of things
that you can do
client-side so at this point let me
switch across to
what i have here
so
something that's very very useful you to
be aware of as a developer
is that we've got these
what's known as the playground
so i've just got to find here on my
desktop where the playground is sitting
here it is here
again the link will be shared in my
presentation now microsoft have gone to
great lengths to build this playground
and the name suggests it is a little bit
fun
because it provides you this experience
to really explore and try out embedded
without a lot of effort certainly no
very little investment in time and
certainly no investment in money
so coming to home
um what i'd like to do is
say let's do this let's go straight
to the
explore the apis and what you can see
happening right here is that a sample
power bi report is being embedded
okay and
if you want to switch and look at the
other options you've got like show me
what it's like to embed a specific
report visual instead of an entire page
or a paginated report then those options
have already been set up for you
all right and this paginated report
being of course multi-pages they will go
the next option is a dashboard
or a single tile from a dashboard
or
let's embed the q a experience
now noting that if you're going to embed
a report you can also check out what is
it like if i want to allow the user to
edit and therefore save changes back and
now you can see
here in the embedding frame
that they've got that ability
what i really want to point out to you
though is that once an embed has been
achieved take a look in the explore our
apis pane where you can see that there
are enormous number of operations that
you can run client-side
to navigate between pages
manage the authoring of reports apply
filters and so on
now what's pretty cool about this is
that the developer sandbox allows you to
use a sample or to select your own
report so what i want to show you here
is that i'm going to come into my own
power bi tenant and i have a workspace
called survey
and the data
that you um submitted in your survey has
come through to this report the pbie ndc
melbourne
and so even here
in the playground i can embed my own
report and and here it is
now what's pretty cool is that you can
start to play with the code here and
then you can run the code and see the
result that is being embedded and so i
thought i'd share one example with you
um and that would be on filtering
what if i go ahead and
filter the page so i'll go and add
a page filter
now if i click on the little eye icon
here i can see that this adds filters to
the report page if i click on the
ellipsis
i can show a code snippet
all right so that's just a matter of
copying and pasting it and adapting it
for use in my own app but this is so
cool is that what i can do is actually
drag that into the code window here and
for example i can just adapt this to say
filter the survey table
and there's a column named country
and i'm only interested
in a filter on germany
let me go ahead then and run this
to which we can see
client side we've been able to
filter the page all right so think about
it it might be you're navigating from a
customer's record and now you want to do
some analysis of the customer so you can
pass the customer key
in as a filter
all right so
what we're describing here is that we
have this ability
to work
with lots of client-side operations how
it works is your client application
hosts the iframe
your embedded report is inside that
iframe and the client apis are
bi-directional allowing you to
communicate in and for power bi to
communicate back out to the app
all right so there are many supported
capabilities and as one example
user interactions are natively supported
by report view
users can can do anything like cross
filter they can download data they can
sort they can uh
interact in every way that power bi
supports and your application can
subscribe to these events
and in response to the user clicking on
something the application can then do
something
all right so dynamic report layouts are
a possibility as well working with
bookmarks that capture state and allow
the replaying of state can also happen
and report visual creation and
personalization can also take place
within the app
all right so consider what we call an
in-context analytics workflow where the
user navigates within the app
the app shows the report filtered to a
specific view the user interactively
filters the data in the report they
click on a button
and then the app does something in
response to clicking on the button
but switching back to the playground
it allows me to come back to the home
and say
let's take a look at the showcases in
fact you'll find the showcases here on
the left and that very scenario that
i've described quite quickly is
available for you here in a sample
report
so for example embedded we've got this
list of
customers and they're purchasing
patterns we can interact by
modifying slicer values
and
using the client-side apis we've
enhanced this visual
that when we click on campaign all of
the filtered customers are now available
here and then i could narrow it down
further and say okay
these are the customers that i want to
target
in a marketing campaign go ahead send
them a coupon here is the
subject of the email and here is the
detail click send
okay it's obviously just a sample but
it's this concept of working in a report
but having your application respond to
your behaviors within the report
all right
so
while time doesn't permit in this
presentation there are further showcases
um for example
um
personalizing top insights
customizing report colors
within the app itself
allowing the user to determine
what works best for them
okay so
next topic
remember this is high level giving you
an idea of what power bi embedded can do
for you
in that scenario where we don't want all
users to see the same data we've got
this ability to enforce what we call row
level permissions
all right user one when they access the
report within your app gets to see
australian sales but the very same app
that a different user signed in
accessing the same report gets to see
german sales so this is achieved in
power bi by what we call row level
security and in power bi desktop as the
data modeling tool you can create what
are known as roles and these roles
enforce permissions under certain
circumstances
and when you add these roles into your
model and publish it
when your application needs to
generate its embed token remember the
claim
that it will present to embed the
content it will also embed the effective
identity of your current application
user now remember these users do not
need permission to your power bi content
directly
and therefore when you define effective
identity you're able to map them to the
appropriate role
for example this is the sales director
they'll be mapped to a role that gives
them permission to see all sales
territory data but when an individual
sales rep uses the same app your
effective identity will map them to a
role where they can only see the sales
territories to which they've been
assigned
so microsoft has a very mature data
modeling technology it evolved from sql
server analysis services and today what
we know is the tabular engine for
analysis services is available in power
bi as its data modeling engine
now that says a couple of things uh
mature technology uh but also the fact
is that these models can be developed in
power bi desktop or if you have existing
models already with either azure
analysis services or sql server analysis
services then these can also be used by
power bi and therefore their data can be
embedded in your apps
all right the next topic is automating
solution management
and so we'll give consideration to what
we can do and what libraries are
available but also relevant for isvs
where you might want to create you know
multiple instances and yet maintain them
as independent for each of your
individual tenants we'll talk about
workspace based isolation
so when it comes to automation this is
pretty important for us as developers uh
it can be used for life cycle management
uh in the way that you might manage your
power bi content and deploy it for
onboarding a new customer in a
multi-tenant solution or for it
operations and maintenance
so you can work with the microsoft graph
api when working with azure id
power bi has its own rest api that
allows managing content and the service
itself
and then there's the azure resource
management api as well
now with the power bi rest api we use it
to access and manage power bi content
like creating new workspaces assigning
workspaces to the capacities which is a
licensing discussion granting permission
to access content within a workspace or
importing new content be them new data
models data sets or reports
relevant for the isp then is where you
must have separation of tenants and this
can be easily achieved in power bi by
using the workspace as a boundary for
each individual tenant
so that way you know when you want to
absolutely make sure that there is no
potential mix up
is that you will just create one
workspace per tenant
but because you're likely to leverage
and repeat the content that you already
have
the way automatically set up is like
this you create what we call the golden
workspace this doesn't belong to any
tenant but it is like the template of
which is your perfect data and reports
what you would then do is through
scripts
you would create the identity that power
bi will use to access
and then you will use it to create a
workspace and then clone or copy all
those data sets and reports
you might also do things like update
connection strings if you need to point
to a separate instance of your data
source
and then you will assign it to a
capacity which is a licensing concept
i'll talk about shortly now what this
means is every time you onboard a new
tenant you're just going to run your
script that will then copy the golden
workspace into a tenant dedicated
workspace
and then it will have its specific
identifiers that your embedding app will
use to connect
i want to finish on the discussion of
licensing
so licensing will differ according to
whether you're embedding
on behalf of users that belong to your
org or their customers remember if it's
embedding for your organization the
licensing discussion is that they need
licenses themselves because they're the
end users within your organization
you're welcome to embed that content and
there's really no um special requirement
beyond that but if you're embedding for
your customer
well then you will need some licensing
from microsoft
so embedding for your organization
requires that your application users
have a power bi pro license they will
require power bi premium per user
licensing as well if they're dependent
on specific features for what we call
ppu or premium per user
it's possible that they do not have
these licenses yet if you're using power
bi premium and the content that they're
accessing resides in a workspace that is
in a premium capacity then they do not
need these pro or premium per user
licenses necessarily
all right so there's a greater bit of
research that you'll need to do but at
the end of the day from an app
perspective you're not concerned with
licensing
you will generate an access token which
will then be used by your app to access
content on behalf of your user and they
either have access or they don't
now when embedding for your customers
there are two options that you can
purchase what's known as a p sku or an
ace view now there's some good news for
you as an app developer that if you're
wanting to trial or evaluate and you
don't want to invest in
buying any licenses then what happens is
every user in power bi that has a pro or
a premium per user license
they have
a limited number of
what can we say free tokens that can be
generated
all right now providing that you do not
use them for production workloads then
you can go ahead and use these free
tokens to experiment with embedding for
your customer
there is an api method that will let you
determine what the usage percentage is
all right so a quick comparison between
aceq and pcu the aceq is actually an
azure resource it is named power bi
embedded and you will purchase it in the
azure portal it's billed hourly there's
no commitment to um
to
use it for any period of time and it
provides full elasticity so you can
scale up or down according to demand you
can even pause it and therefore
turn the cost off
this could all be automated as well
through the arm api now pskew is power
bi premium and it's purchased through
office 365
it provides you the ability to generate
embed tokens but there is a monthly
billing and a monthly commit and a
yearly commit for working with power bi
premium in addition to embedding content
however you get power bi report server
and you get the ability to do some other
cool things
now the guidance that i would provide
you at a very high level as a developer
if you were interested in betting for
your customers your power bi content
then generally speaking enterprises buy
power bi premium because they want to
benefit from the ability to share
content with non-licensed users
and other features in premium whereas
isvs generally purchase the power bi
embedded product or the a sku
but it's not set in stone you don't
necessarily have to do it because you're
an isv
what you would do is weigh up what are
the capabilities and features on offer
and what makes the best sense for what
we're delivering
but there is a final word that i'd like
to give you and again if you're moving
into that territory of we're interested
we want to evaluate and test
is that at very low cost
remember once you've uh
you've used those free embed tokens and
remember they can't be used for
production workloads but if you want to
start testing it the cheapest option
available to you today is to purchase an
a1 node which is u.s one dollar per hour
and remember you can pause and resume
this so it comes to about 720 us dollars
a month allows you
for for small scale to start out and
it'll also allow you to determine well
according to the workloads and the
number of users and the demands that our
application is making um
that if the a1 might be sufficient or
maybe we need to at some point scale up
to an a2
based on the demands that are being made
from customers all right so for those
that are intrigued want to know more at
uh wanna trial it um this is the low
cost option one dollar an hour while
you're working with embedded content
in my final minutes then
very quickly because you can download
the pdf is that there are resources like
the embedded playground link there's
also the embed setup tool nuget package
links are available sample applications
available from github
and samples for all of these
technologies as well
i'm going to leave this slide up now and
then open for any questions there might
be but if you click on this link or use
the qr code you can download the
presentation and all of the resources
that i've talked about are available to
you
now would be a great time to know if
there are any questions that i can
answer
uh william i'm not hearing you
i've done a second last moment
he's got to press two unmute buttons
these days um
that was a great uh presentation pete uh
there's a a lot of power bi that i
didn't know existed so um
i'm definitely going to be looking into
the the playground i think that's for me
going to be a good start
um there aren't any questions in the uh
the q a section but i've got one of my
own so
when
we're building a visualization in power
bi and i've got a data set that or a
component that doesn't quite fit what
i'm trying to show is there a way
can we build our own visualizations you
know custom
yeah yeah absolutely so great question
so there is a complete framework for
custom visuals allowing you to build
exactly what you want now it's not a
trivial thing to do by the way william
so
if you do have skills in you know html
and working with graphics libraries
working with typescript um and css if
you have all of those skills then yes
power bi will allow you to package up
your own visual and then you can use
that in your embedded apps as well
so you talking like libraries like say
d3 or um correct
well at the end of the day you're
rendering html so any graphics or
drawing library that you want can be
used
and then you can package up your own
visual there's also a marketplace out
there there are some very um sharp
individuals that are producing their own
custom visuals and um and profiting from
that
okay so there's ones you can pay for the
free ones as well
lots of free ones so if you go into
power bi and you edit a report in your
visualizations plane there will be a dot
dot button when you click it you can
then go to the app source and you can
import from microsoft's and the
community by the way a very very lot of
custom visuals there too
do you happen to have a link to that um
library uh or the marketplace
quick search on power bi custom visual
you would pretty much land quickly on
microsoft docs and it would lead you
from there uh pete uh thank you very
very much uh you know
telling us what we can do with our
boring data and making it look awesome
yeah turning that that that data into
some digital gold i think is super
valuable there's a lot for us to learn
from your talk today
so thank you very much pete
you are very welcome thanks for having
me william
no no problem
now
next we're going to hand over to roaming
lives because he has disappeared from
the studio
but first we want to just have a word
from our sponsors and then we'll find
lars
[Music]
the idea behind distinguished engineers
is really to assemble a diverse team of
our top level engineers and some of the
best engineering minds on the planet to
really solve the most complex problems
both for cba and for our customers our
distinguished engineering program
started internally by us having a good
look at who'd really shown amazing
engineering leadership or technology
leadership already inside the group and
we basically started assembling those
people and focusing them on really
important problems both for us and our
customers
[Music]
i get to actually roll up my sleeves and
actually really help solve some really
tricky problems in the bank one of the
big challenges we have right now in x15
is how do we get small teams of
engineers to be able to within just like
a few months go for an idea and get it
into our customers hands if we can crack
that i think that's an incredibly tough
engineering problem but also means that
we can make a massive difference in
australia
[Music]
one of the main reasons that engineering
is important at combank is just the
scale of impact that we have across
australia for commonwealth bank we're
the largest lender in australia and so
the scale and importance of digitizing a
process like that has an impact on all
australians the thing for me that's
really appealing about engineering at
combank is the combination of really
important problems for australia and
really difficult engineering problems
[Music]
hello everybody um yeah i thought i'll
just show you some of what melbourne is
really about so hello
i'm in a coffee shop i know it's quite
novel and um i'm here with alex at
the cartel roasters coffee roasters
thank you alex this is awesome and we're
just getting confused for the crew so
i'll just take you for a quick walk all
right thanks man
cheers all righty go around see ya
i'm just gonna walk out in here to the
alley
look at this so this is as melbourne as
it gets people if you're not from
melbourne we love our little alleys of
coffee shops and weird things
in all the little nooks and crannies but
um whoa make sure to drop them got the
coffees peeps got em so i'm just gonna
walk back to the studio
and i will see you there
thank you lies i'm looking forward to
that coffee
so team i promised you another piece of
developer news and it's all still all
about net six we'd be amazed to talk
about net 6 coming out without talking
about net maui so net 6 is all about
the.net unification plan and bringing in
those final bits in.net maui is the net
multi-platform app ui which is the
evolution of xamarin forms and it builds
upon and extends xamarin as part of
that.net 6 unification
so it's a cross-platform mobile-first
native ui framework for android ios mac
os and windows and it's something that
i'm personally super excited about and
it's they're been launching previews all
alongside
the different net preview releases the
latest one is all about supporting
visual studio 2022 in preview 2 which is
cool so it now has net maui workloads
you can go out and build your.net maui
projects you can get started and i'm
super excited about it because it
supports both xaml and fluent c-sharp ui
so you can now write your ui mobile
applications in just pure c-sharp if you
wanted to which is really cool
for me as a as a net developer who
hasn't used xaml before
and now you can use oh thank you guys
so i got my my melvin coffee delivery um
but yes with maui you can now do
net workload installs within the latest
preview there's support for native
alerts gestures and clipping so that's
the the latest piece of tech news
so now
i've got my my melvin coffee
and we have lars setting back up in the
studio and he's gonna
get us get all ready and i think he's
gonna bring on
our next speaker let's see can you hear
us flowers
you're on unmute there we go yes i can
hear you oh
ah coffee
ah delicious all righty
so all caffeinated again and
all out of breath i'm not used to all
this up and down stairs i live in the
country um
now
please do go and check out the expo at
expo.ndcmelvin.com there's still chance
to sign up and there's an awful lot of
prizes to give away
i just had another look at him it is i
don't know 40 or something so
there's a lot um
now our final speaker for the day is an
american
a long time sydney sider and she now
lives in munich in germany yep um
she's part of the developer relations
team at aws and has taught a bunch of
machines to code and take over the world
i think anyway she's here to also talk
about knitting for some reason and
please welcome from halfway around the
globe
chris howard how you doing chris
hey lars uh
hang on my screen sharing one second one
second it's 7am here did you mention
that you didn't mention that no no i'm
gonna send you a box of tissues you know
so you can you know just cry and quiet
oh my gosh i might have to disappear for
one second and come back to give screen
permission give me one talk about
knitting for one minute there you go i
will talk about knitting so my first
experience with knitting was actually in
primary school because my mom wanted me
to start to learn to knit i wanted to do
crocheting and i'm not even making this
up actually my grandma was a crocheter
my mom was a knitter and there was this
big fight
but um i didn't either and i liked
sandpits so there you go
have we lost chris she's not she's not
that
oh well um
now we could oh here we go you're back
again
i wasn't sure
did you want me to do your presentation
or
no well i know you offered this morning
but uh no that that will be unnecessary
okay fair enough
how are you doing this morning that
looks delicious i am drinking my coffee
because as i said it is 707 a.m so i've
i i don't know why i agreed to this
really i really wanted to speak at ndc
for years and so time zones be damp
really but just think how much you get
out of the day so now you're getting
this out the way and you got the whole
day to enjoy the post presentation high
you get a full day of work after this no
right
all righty all right so i did share can
you can you see that now
yes yes nice fantastic so there is
knitting in this and i promise you all
this is not a talk to miss um there's
always knitting within arm's reach in me
are you talking you know
exactly just um you did once knit the
genome of a certain virus did you not oh
it's around here somewhere i didn't
quite finish it you know the original
thought was i was gonna knit the genetic
sequence of the covid virus last year
when we first wanted to lock down and uh
yeah i i thought i did it throughout
lockdown gave up on that pretty quick
glad i did
i've still got it i'll finish it one of
these days yeah and then you can just
cover the whole building probably being
normal yeah i worked out the math it
would be like several football fields
just the section of it that i had oh
dear all right well we'd better get to
this talk then so you can go back to
knitting yeah that'd be great
all right no worries i'll see you after
okay cool
well uh good day everybody god it's been
a while since i've said that thank you
so much for having me you know for those
of you who don't know me as lars said my
name is chris um i'm an american
australian thank you i do have two
passports uh if you want to tweet at me
my usernames at uh web underscore
goddess um
uh they're in the corner uh it should be
on the corner of my slides yeah cool um
yeah so i've spent the majority of my
tech career in sydney working for
companies like nine digital and canva
and then aws
but yeah last year rad and i decided
it'll be fun to move to europe for a
while um so yeah that was complicated
but we did get to munich in august and
uh nowadays i'm a manager in the aws
devrel team
um
and uh it is 7 a.m here i did mention
that but as i said i've always wanted to
speak an ndc event so i'm not going to
let moving halfway around the world stop
me
um so in my career i've been a web
developer a ba um a tech evangelist a
people leader but what i have not been
is a machine learning expert or a data
scientist but it's a topic that
interested me and and maybe like you you
know i'd see talks at meetups and at
conferences over the years that i kind
of hoped would show me an easy path to
get started i actually remember
attending one uh developer conference in
sydney
um that where i went to a talk uh that
was billed as machine learning for
software developers and i got there and
it was a full room and i'm very excited
and within five minutes literally it was
slides of nothing but calculus
and i remember looking around the room
at the other people who were looking at
me and we're all like this is a bait and
switch like did did you know that was
what it was going to be i didn't
actually get much out of that talk um
so don't get me wrong though if you
actually want to get a job as a machine
learning expert or a data scientist you
need to have that foundation you need to
do the calculus absolutely go back do
that
but
this talk isn't aimed at you this talk
is for folks like me who who were
curious who were interested who who
wanted to do something practical and
just starting out um and do it as simply
as they can so i promise you no calculus
today
i just want to have some fun show you
some of the things that inspire me about
machine learning and show you a project
i've been working on hopefully hopefully
get your juices flowing and get you to
do one yourself
so this is what we're going to cover
today um i'm going to cover some of the
cool stuff people are doing in aiml some
of the stuff that's personally really
exciting to me and is maybe outside of
the examples that you see normally when
people talk about this stuff i'm going
to talk just a little bit about how you
can get started a few couple few
resources i'm going to briefly cover the
aws machine learning stack not really
trying to do a sales pitch here but it's
kind of relevant to understand some of
the tools i'm going to use in my project
we have different tools that cater to
different levels of expertise basically
and then i will show you this project
i've been working on which uh you know
lars sort of gave you the hint there
it's about knitting it's an attempt to
teach a computer to reverse engineer
knitting patterns and no you don't need
to know anything about knitting for that
part
okay so state of aiml you know like
every week there is some new
breakthrough there's a new video of
robots dancing to some song or you know
defeating the world champion in the game
of go and those are all fine um but one
that's particularly relevant to me and
to all of you right now was the success
of deepmind's alpha fold two at the 14th
casp competition and that stands for a
really long acronym that i can't
remember because it's 7am but the goal
of this competition is to use ai to
predict the structure of proteins and
yeah proteins are made from a really
long ribbon of amino acids and it sort
of folds itself up into twists and turns
and tangles
and the structure of a protein
determines you know what it does
but there's an astronomical number of
shapes that each sequence can fold
itself into um and researchers have been
grappling with this challenge literally
going back to the 70s for 50 years
but at last year's competition end of
2020 alpha fold predicted the structure
of dozens of proteins with a margin of
error of 1.6
angstroms that's
0.16
nanometers that's atom sized
this is a massive
shocking achievement like if you read
news articles about this like other
researchers in the field are like this
is a big deal and it's going to help
researchers understand diseases design
new drugs so as an example what you see
here in the slide
the actual molecule is in green there
and the predicted structure is in blue
and it's you know it's it's not perfect
but it's pretty close and incidentally
of course this protein happens to belong
to coronavirus and is implicated in
immune evasion
and even more massively just a few weeks
back deepmind published the paper and
the source code for alpha fold it's
actually on github you can go look for
it
and they also released predictions for
the shape of every single protein in the
human body as well as proteins for like
20 additional organisms that scientists
often use in their research
so far i just looked it up last night
they've released 350 000 newly predicted
protein structures of course not all of
them are accurate they're predictions
but it's a really good start for
scientists and they say they'll predict
and release the structures for 100
million more in the next few months more
or less all proteins known to science
so that's an example of ai solving
really serious problems important to me
and you and that's awesome
but let's look at some less serious
examples
the other area that i really love is
using machine learning to generate art
if any of you went to linux conf 2018
when it was back in sydney i actually
organized one of the mini conference
that day on art and tech and i had a
whole day uh with speakers around uh we
had someone from uh uh
talking about procedurally generated
landscapes um using music that they'd
written we had uh someone talking about
nanogenmo national novel generating
month which happens every year and it's
where people try and create a machine
learning model they can use code to
write a 50 000 word novel
um i remember boing boing described one
attempt as uh surprisingly plausible
but um so one of the early techniques
that artists really jumped on back in
2014 was called deep dream and you may
have seen this you know the gist of it
is you have this convolutional neural
network uh represented by this very
simplified diagram here and you've
trained it to recognize different
animals and objects uh like dog and cat
and mouse you know
all those labels those output classes on
the right
so then if you give it an image of a
puppy like this little puppy here as an
input what you expect to see is that the
corresponding output neuron for the dog
class that lights up that's why it's
yellow
now suppose that we give it an input
that it's not trained on some animal
that it's not trained to recognize like
a jellyfish
so what we can then do is try and make a
series of modifications to this image of
the jellyfish to try and get the dog
neuron to fire and after several such
iterations you get something like this
you actually get recognizable dog parts
like snouts and legs and there's some
really cool very dreamlike art that's
been uh created by this method
uh in 2016 neural style transfer sort of
exploded you may have seen the that
prisma ai app that everybody was using
for a while on instagram you know the
technology behind this is to separate
the elements of an artistic style from
the underlying content so you can sort
of like cut and paste the style of one
image onto another um so i actually went
to a tensorflow workshop at the google
sydney office back in 2017 and and
learned about this and so i have this
hus this is a picture of my husband out
on philip island actually um with a
horse and i've applied the style of
different uh different paintings uh
which is pretty cool
another big breakthrough uh was the
development of generative adversarial
networks or gans you've probably heard
of this where systems can generate
realistic looking fake images that don't
actually exist in real life you know
there are horror stories everywhere
about
i think it's these people do not exist
where there's all these people who who
are not real they're completely computer
generated
but forget people is the internet uh i
want you to go to the website these cats
do not exist.com
which does the same thing but for cats
and this was built using the uh popular
style gan on amazon's sagemaker
and some of them are virtually
indistinguishable from reality um while
others of them are are a little bit more
nightmare fuel that one in the upper
right there
but the application of gans don't need
to be limited to just photo realistic
output so this is a piece designed by my
friend jay rosenbaum um some of you may
know jj is an artist living in melbourne
and jay keynoted at that art and tech
mini conf i did they also carrying the
keynoted at i believe uh ddd was it ddd
melbs a few years back as well
um so jay works with 3d modeling with
aiml with extended reality technologies
and jay created these artworks last year
during the initial covid lockdown in
melbourne the big one
and started with drawings of faces and
bodies and then had a neural network
generate a landscape from the sketch the
series is called the isolation of being
um you should check it out it's really
sorry to see you guys are back in
lockdown again
and this is one of the magical machine
learning use cases i love the most
getting pizza to people faster
domino's pizza and i don't know if you
know this they're different domino's
franchises around the world but domino's
pizza enterprise enterprises limited is
the biggest domino's franchise holder
represents domino's uh back there in
australia i think headquarters might
might be in brisbane also randomly here
in germany where i live now
but even before the pandemic you know
domino's had 70 of their orders uh
coming from online
and so they they did a lot of study of
this data and and basically made the
surprising connection that if they could
get pizzas to people faster they were
more satisfied with their meal so back
in 2019 they launched a project called
project 310 it was an initiative that
aims to have a pizza ready for pickup
within three minutes or safely delivered
within 10.
so some of the stuff they did that you
know they had more efficient cooking
methods and transportation they
physically open stores closer to where
customers live but also they used
predictive technologies to help produce
pizza making and delivery times
so they built this system and i believe
there's there's talks about this and a
case study online if you want more
details but they used amazon s3 as a
data lake and amazon stage maker to
build machine learning models and
basically the stores that have this have
this heads-up display where as you know
uh they can see at any time the
likelihood of certain pizzas being
ordered and they can start making them
ahead of time so they're actually coming
out of the oven just as lars gets the
urge to ring up and order his uh his
hawaiian pizza
and at one store they actually managed
to get delivery times down to just like
five minutes
so that's amazing
okay so for me the current interesting
stuff happening in aiml is art
it's cats
it's pizza and you know the survival of
the human race and i don't know about
you those are pretty much the only
things that i can actually concentrate
on these days um and they're personally
more impactful and meaningful and
inspiring to me than than dancing robots
or or self-driving cars or or ever more
realistic chat bots
p.s please everybody get vaccinated i
want to come visit again
so hopefully this has you feeling more
inspired um and if you are you know you
might be wondering how to get started
there's a lot of material on this
obviously a lot of courses and stuff
like that but what one resource i can
recommend
just part of the day job here aws is
ramp up guide for machine learning it's
on our website it links to the free
resources and training courses that we
have that you can use to start building
your skills
back in february we also did an event an
online event called aws innovate it had
more than 50 sessions about the latest
innovations in aiml business use cases
architectural best practices so if you
google aws innovate i believe you can
actually still register and watch those
sessions on demand if you missed it
okay i'm briefly going to talk about
aws's machine learning stack here not a
sales page it will actually help a
little bit when i go into my project to
understand sort of the different the
different types of tools that we have
but really aws has a lot of tools
because our mission is to put machine
learning in the hands of every developer
every every software developer how do we
do this
we do that by building a lot of
different aiml services that cater to
different skill levels and i know this
this looks like a ton and actually it's
probably out of date already there's
probably more um but it's roughly three
layers we got frameworks and
infrastructure there at the top we got
machine learning services in the middle
and we've got ai services at the bottom
so just in real brief what that means
those ai services at the top and i am
going to use one of those in my pr
project this is where models are largely
pre-trained for you and you just access
access predictions basically with an api
call
so we've got like image recognition of
like basic everyday stuff we've got
natural language processing speech to
text text-to-speech
and actually re-invent last year you see
all those new labels we launched a new
suite of anomaly detection tools under
the amazon lookout brand
in that middle layer there we've got
what we call machine learning services
which which basically for the most part
means amazon sagemaker
so we've got an ide called safe maker
studios it's got all the tools that you
need to develop train debug deploy
monitor machine learning models i'm
gonna make heavy use of this uh in my in
my demo um and as you can see from all
those new labels again we we're bringing
out a lot of new features for this every
year
and lastly down there at the bottom if
you want to roll your own if you're an
expert you know of course you you we
have the foundational options in the
frameworks and infrastructure layer this
is where you can launch a deep learning
ami or a container on whatever hardware
you need and manage it however you want
but i'm not going to demo that part
because again
not a machine learning expert
and that brings me to my project
so when i am not
messing around with computers or looking
at cats that do not exist on the
internet as lars said i am often
knitting i took it up as a hobby
actually when i first moved to australia
many many years ago i've been doing off
and on ever since
in fact when we were i actually do have
knitting right next to me always have it
next to me um when we were in lockdown
last year we were in lockdown for five
months by the way last winter i actually
started live streaming my knitting on
twitch which no joke i've got 123
followers for my knitting live stream so
knitting underscore with underscore
chris if any of you want to follow me or
you can watch like 30 plus previous
episodes on my youtube page
but because you all know me as a knitter
all these these geeks and tech sometimes
i get tagged on tweets like this
um and so this is a real tweet uh
from last april uh just like you know a
few a few months back actually it turns
out this guy's mother uh turned one of
his favorite jumpers into a couch
cushion and he wanted to see if the
original jumper could be recreated and
of course in the replies somebody jokes
there's got to be an app for that
um but actually and i did comment in the
thread for an experienced knitter
this is a not an
uncommon thing to do
this is a photo i took in the aws
kitchen back in sydney uh in 2019 you
know not long before
i was thinking about moving to europe um
so i this is my colleague mega this
she's wearing this beautiful blue jumper
and i'd seen i've never seen this stitch
before i've never seen the particular
design and i took a photo of it because
i'm a knitting dork and that's what i do
i've done it on the bus um but if i look
at this i can tell you that the
background there is uh is what we call
reverse stocking stitch that's the sort
of background uh part um those raised
zigzag zigzag lines those are made up
out of three knit stitches and they use
a combination of increases on one side
and decreases on the other and that's
why you get the slant
um and some of that i get just because i
can recognize the texture of what
reverse stocking stitch looks like
and some of it is knowing how stitches
work especially if you can if you've got
a good image or you're looking at
something you can zoom in and read it
stitch by stitch almost like deciphering
cursive handwriting
and so yeah that's literally reverse
engineering it's taking a man-made
object and studying it to deconstruct
its design and of course you know we do
this all the time in technology and
software engineering but turns out if
you didn't know it knitters love doing
it too
so that's what got me thinking um about
two years ago uh about this problem like
if i if a skilled knitter can reverse
engineer a pattern from a finished
knitted object or even just a picture of
a knitted object
why couldn't i train a computer to do it
turns out i'm not the only one who has
had this idea
this is a paper that was presented at
the international conference on machine
learning in june 2019 right after i
started this project i reached out to an
ai ml expert idea but she's like oh yeah
somebody's already working on that
um so the goal of these researchers was
to take a photograph of knitting uh
reverse engineer the pattern feed that
into a knitting machine because that's
also a thing you know a lot of the
jumpers you buy in stores are machine
knit on knitting machines and get an
identical swatch back out so they're
basically trying to build a knitting
replicator a duplicator
but they recognized pretty early on in
the project that one problem is that
photographs of knitting suck for
computer vision to be frank with you
because knitting you know it's it's
floppy it's stretchy it's depending on
the yarn it's often fuzzy and hard to
see
um so they had a breakthrough and their
breakthrough was to use both yes real
knitted swatches in there and a swatches
piece of knitting real knitted swatches
in their training data but to actually
augment that with simulated knitting as
well um so those industrial knitting
machines i mentioned a lot of them have
really complex software that can
actually simulate what the knitted
fabric would look like and they actually
managed to get their hands on these
machines cost like hundreds of thousands
of dollars but they got their hands on
the software and were able to generate
lots and lots of swatches that they
could use in their training data as well
and that gave much better results and so
the papers online
it has a lot of calculus in it and i
promise you no calculus uh but from what
i can tell from the results they haven't
quite cracked it yet they're getting
close um back then they were they were
about 80 accuracy in their experiments
and they used both adversarial and
generative they used both convolutional
and generative adversarial neural
networks
so no there's not an app for it yet but
we're getting there and so i decided to
try it for myself
i'm drinking my coffee still
all right
so
rather than output though on reading a
pattern stitch by stitch like i said
like reading reading cursive handwriting
i decided to d scope of course make it
simpler treat it just to start as an
image classification problem so that's
where you take an image as an input and
you output a class label it's that slide
i showed you with the puppy going to the
puppy label
so like how with my with my brain i can
recognize the texture and know that
that's reverse stocking stitch and
that's garter stitch i just want to
build a machine learning model that
could do the same
so this was the plan as i saw it i'd get
some training data how hard could that
be label it train a model deploy it
maybe build a nice web front end for
inference and then dance on the grave of
the knitting industry you know problem
solved
again had zero zero practical experience
in machine learning at this point
all right get training data uh this is
the first thing you learn everybody told
me or when you start with machine
learning you will spend eighty percent
of your time getting data and cleaning
it up um and i was like yeah right i'm
sure like i'm sure i can i can you know
get that down so i went and looked at
what other researchers had done if
you've ever done this you know that
there are websites like kaggle where you
can download data sets um i couldn't
find any knitting ones on there but it
turns out that the folks who wrote that
paper i mentioned
they actually did make their training
training data set available so they
knitted i said they used simulated data
but they also knitted about a thousand
pattern samples really knitted them on
that industrial machine
in five by five grids and they had this
great idea um to try and counter some of
those problems i mentioned with the
floppiness and the stretchiness they
they needed a grid into it and they
inserted steel rods into that to help it
lay really flat and even for photography
uh but of course they as you can see
there how they took photos of it they
realized that was not going to scale to
the number that they were going to need
so that's when they they hit on the
simulation aspect but you can download
there's their simulated data set here
it's these researchers at mit there's
the url
um so i had a look through them as you
can see they're they're uh little sort
of different lace and and different uh
textural patterns and i i decided it was
probably overkill for what i wanted i
wanted to just identifying like five
basic stitches i didn't need to go to
this level
i was going to aim for if you've ever
knitted stuck in it reverse stuck in it
garter stitch moss and seed these are
just five very basic combinations of
knits and pearls
and so i thought forget this
i'm going to collect my own data set
directly from knitters you know i don't
know if you know this there are a lot of
us knitters online we post pictures of
our knitting and i thought i can
leverage this
i didn't want to spend hours like
manually scraping and downloading
pictures myself so i thought i'll build
some sort of a
a pipeline a little application that
would allow people to send me send me
their images via email
so i'm not going to go through this in
time i've got no time uh in detail but
the idea i built a little a little thing
on aws the idea is that emails would
come in with attachments i would you
know check them for viruses and stuff i
would save it in s3 bucket and i had a
database table where i sort of recorded
the details of who sent me what um but
the goal was to get them in s3 because i
knew i'd need them there for my training
jobs and that saved me having to
individually handle every image
so i got this working and then of course
i put out a tweet
this is the tweet i made you may have
seen it you may have retweeted it it did
kind of go viral
uh back in october 2019 asking for
knitted samples so i did write a full
blog post i talked about what i wanted
what i didn't want you know i wanted
images like this where it was just a
close-up of a particular stitch pattern
i also said what i didn't want you know
all the types of images i didn't want i
put the email address and i put this i
put this out on twitter i also put it on
ravelry which is like github for
knitters
and yeah lots of people started sharing
it they started tagging in their
knitting friends and forwarding it i got
a retweet and a reply from you know
janelle shane who does that ai weirdness
blog and newsletter which she's like the
rock star um so it was great and more
importantly images started to arrive in
the bucket random human beings around
the world random knitters were actually
doing the thing you know
it's working
um
and then and then i look in the bucket
at the images and uh
they weren't all great
you know sometimes like people get
excited they don't read quickly you know
they read closely you know they sent me
stitch patterns i wasn't looking for or
they sent me pictures of whole garments
which are really beautiful but don't
really have the resolution i need to see
the stitches sometimes they'd mess up
and attach the wrong images this one
nice lady was like i think i sent you
halloween candy you did
so yeah the first lesson is even with
the best of intentions crowdsourcing
your data is uh not the magic bullet it
is going to result in a lot of cleanup
and i'm not trying to shame or embarrass
these folks they were so nice they were
trying to help me out
um but it did mean i i spent a lot of
time cleaning these images up so i threw
out all the dodgy ones i cropped the
rest the best i could to just show the
stitch pattern
and then it was time to get them labeled
you actually have to label them so that
you can feed them into the machine to
train and so rather than do it myself i
thought again i will turn to my fellow
knitters
so one of the services we have in that
middle layer of the aws machine learning
stack is called sagemaker ground truth
and it helps you build accurate training
data sets for machine learning by
coordinating public and private
workforces basically you set up a
project in this little ui and then you
can put it out on mechanical turk and
and pay people to actually label your
images or if it's a specialist sort of
domain like knitting you can actually uh
set up your own
workforce and have give people a login
so they can log in and do it so i did
that i put out the call for volunteer
tax task force and i set up the job and
this is normally where i'd switch to the
browser and show you but i don't want to
risk i've got too much going on here so
i've just got some screenshots if you
want to see what the ground truth
interface looks like
basically down the left side there i had
some instructions that you can customize
and showing you know what they were
looking for it would give them a random
image from the data set and then it's
got labels on the right um and that they
pick the the right option and you see
i've actually got six options on there
i've got reverse stuck and stitched
stuck in it um which is the back side of
stockinette stitch as i mentioned i also
added other you know because i said
people did send me some stitches that
weren't in the uh in the set that i was
after and so other is used for anything
other than those
and i also set this up you can configure
it so that every image had to be
reviewed by at least three people to
minimize the chances somebody would
would get it wrong or hit the wrong
button
and that was a good thing because i
quickly ran into problems
without spending too much time on this
these are two of the stitches i was
trying to review this is garter stitch
and reverse stucconet stitch um they
look really similar
in real life they don't because one's
the same on both sides and one's
different um but in a flat photograph i
suddenly realized they're really hard to
tell apart i had trouble telling them
apart um and so i realized that my
labels for these two in particular were
not going to be very helpful
two other stitches that i had that i
wanted to identify were seed stitch and
moss stitch and they look very different
thought that would be easy and then i
discovered that in british patterns they
used both words to refer to the same
stitch the one on the left um only
americans call the one on the right moss
ditch
so again uh i realized that i was going
to have uh unreliable labels for those
two stitch patterns so again like what's
that like four out of my four out of my
five are now useless
so time to d scope even further can i
just identify a single pattern can i
identify stockinette stitch let's build
stockinette or not
that's what i landed on
time to train the model
okay so i showed you that slide of all
the different all the different tools we
had back in 2019 that slide was a little
bit simpler
and basically my best option to go with
was amazon stage maker that's that bit
in the middle it's a fully managed
service that covers pretty much the
whole machine learning workflow you can
use jupiter jupiter workbooks notebooks
you know all that stuff but you can also
do it directly in the console which is
what i did because remember pretty much
a beginner here
so i ran my training jobs on a single p3
instance
and that has gpus to accelerate your
machine learning jobs and again i would
switch to the console here but i'm just
going to show you screenshots instead to
uh to save switching around
but basically when you go to create your
training job in sagemaker you know you
give it a name you give it roles you
select uh which algorithm you want to
use it's got a whole bunch in there i
went with the one for image
classification and i was pretty much
relying on some blog posts and tutorials
that other people had done to show me
how to do this
uh you set up your
training data source you can point it at
your s3 bucket which because i already
had them in there that part was actually
pretty easy um you actually create both
a training data set and a validation
data set normally the rules you use
about 80
of your data set for training and you
set aside 20 of it um that it will use
afterwards to go through and gauge how
accurate the predictions are
and and so you just point it and tell it
which bucket and it'll work that out
um
and
as you can see it took me reading up
from the bottom it took me about seven
attempts before i got a training job
that actually completed uh there's a lot
of fields in the ui
i'm not an expert i'm not going to lie
it's this is a tool that experts use
but i did finally get one that ran
great
time to test it out so then you've got
to deploy your model um so you can host
it in production so you can actually use
it uh this was the simplest part you
know in sagemaker you got to create an
endpoint that takes a few minutes to be
created um then you can start passing
images to it and getting classes back as
i said like like almost like calling an
api
um so this is you can see i actually
ended up throughout i ran many training
jobs but i created you know three
different models you've got to create an
end point for an endpoint configuration
uh pointed at a model and then you
create an endpoint that you can actually
then have your code talk to
so then i wanted to build off something
pretty so that i could show it off and
test it out um with a little bit of a
web front end so my colleague gabe
hollanby who's at aws in singapore um
some of you may know him he comes out to
australia used to pre-covered fairly
regularly um he had this little react
app he built that he helped me out with
uh he had the code up at the time uh
only tricky bit just side note if you're
doing this sagemaker endpoints aren't
exposed to the public by default so i
just set up a little lambda function to
act as the inner midi intermediary
wasn't too hard and so once that was
done
i fired up my little react web app i
pointed it at the end point with that
first trained model that i had and i fed
it the first image which was a stucconet
stitch and
oh my god i got it right i'm like i
nailed it first try right out of the
gate great maybe i should try a second
image just to be sure
that's not stuck in that stitch that's
garter stitch oh crap it got one wrong
so i'm thinking
that's that's not good i'll try
something else this this isn't knitting
that's crochet it's thinking these are
all stuck in edge stitch something has
clearly gone very wrong
um so i tried one last image with a
sinking feeling in my stomach
that's a cat that is not stockinette
stitch
so uh cancel my machine learning phd
turns out this is often the case with
machine learning it is extremely
unlikely you hit the jackpot um i had to
go digging in my logs and i could see
that my validation accuracy was 45 it
was like worse than a coin flip
um so back to data cleaning and more
training
so you saw in that screenshot i ran lots
of different trading jobs trying to
figure out the magic combination of
different options that would give me the
right result
so to minimize the effects of image size
and color i wanted to rule those out i
cropped them all to a fixed size i
converted them to grayscale so i got rid
of the color information i also rotated
every image 90 degrees which had the
added benefit of doubling my sample size
so i think yeah i had 368 in that in
that first lot um so i rotated them i
also added in clutter i learned about
this from someone um clutter are images
of the things you're not looking for uh
dinosaurs and accordions and airplanes
um i found a set of these images that i
could download online and the idea is to
train if you trade the model that
everything you give it is knitting it
thinks everything in the world is
knitting like a cat so you got to give
it images of stuff that aren't knitting
um that got my sample size up to about
and i also ran a hyper parameter tuning
job which um sounds really fancy but the
idea is that you know rather than me
going in and trying out
thousands of combinations excuse me
rather than me trying out you know
thousands of literally tweaking little
hyper parameters sagemaker has a thing
where it will actually set up a job for
you a tuning job it will try out
hundreds of combinations and figure out
the one that works best like run a
little competition
um and so i i did lots of jobs as you
saw i will show you
the best one that i got back in 2019
using sagemaker
okay so this is my little um react app i
recorded this video uh to show you um
and so i'm actually gonna drag in oh
start the video i'm going to drag in
some images here
so that's stuck in that stitch and the
prediction is stuck in that stitch so
right away okay now garter stitch
not stuck in it this is better this is
already better all right dragon a few
more that's seed stitch again not stuck
in it as expected uh this is some lace
uh crochet not stuck in it brilliant
our old friend the cat also not stuck in
it i'm feeling pretty good about the
model this time so i gave this talk one
of the places i gave this talk was at
build stuff europe and i actually ran
around at the conference and i'd be
doing this if i were with you and we
were all together in melbourne i took
pictures of people's sweaters on my
phone and actually use them in the talk
and so these are these are actually
samples of people who are at this
particular conference um and it's
getting
these right
um
there is at least one that it gets wrong
i think so these are all correct so far
uh i think the next one and i might need
to uh it doesn't quite fit i think i
clear it and do it there's one that it
gets wrong like it's not perfect it gets
there's a
some images this particular one it gets
wrong it thinks it's stuck in it and you
can see why stucco net stitch sort of
makes little v's that's kind of the
characteristic i think of when i look
for it um and this particular stitch i
don't know what this girl's sweater
stitch was it's probably brioche or
something like that
it's not stuck in it but it kind of
looks like it so i i think i think
that's why the model is calling that
stockinette um but anyway just to give
you the stats
my validation accuracy got up to nearly
um which is pretty good considering
again complete newbie at this
now you are probably sitting there
thinking yeah chris you promised us
simple and that all sounds
really complicated you had to do 15
different jobs you had to tweak hyper
parameters
you'd be 100 right you know even with
sagemaker taking on a lot of the heavy
lifting i still needed a lot of help
from experienced folks to get these
results
but i am happy to report that there are
other options now aws is always
innovating and literally one month after
i went through all of this
i saw this we announced the availability
of amazon recognition custom labels
so recognition is one of those ai
services at the top layer of the stack
out of the box it allows you to identify
common objects people text scenes in
images and video we actually just
released the full list of labels that it
can recognize out of the box and there's
thousands i did note by the way it it
claims it can recognize knitting and
weaving doesn't have crochet obviously i
need to test this out
but the reason i didn't use it is you
can't use it for custom domains or you
couldn't at the time it could only
recognize those things that have been
pre-trained on
but we brought out this feature called
custom labels where you can build your
own specialized image capability image
analysis capabilities and detect your
own objects different types of objects
specific to your use case so you don't
actually have to train the model from
scratch it uses transfer learning and
you can get started with according to to
the documentation as little as 10 images
so i couldn't resist the opportunity to
see how this compared to my experience
using sagemaker
all right so this is the recognition
custom labels interface
you can tell right off the bat this is a
lot simpler than sage maker right you
got like two options you got projects
and you got data sets
as you can see here i ran i did this
last april i ran about five different uh
different each of these projects is
essentially a training job
and you can see that the model
performance there on the right um you
basically create a data set and then you
just click the button you literally just
click a button to train it and it does
it you don't have to
you don't have to do all that
configuration it will determine the best
algorithm it will determine all the
hyper parameters it needs and it'll just
go off and do it
so here are some of the different data
sets that i created because i was
testing out different combinations of
stuff as you can see there the number
number of images i'll i'll show you the
results of a couple of these
um
so to create a data set you actually
don't even need to use an s3 bucket you
can drag and drop them into the
interface in the console but the
convenient thing was i could actually
point it at the labeled training data
set that i used sagemaker ground truth
with before so it was super fast if you
already have a labeled a training data
set you can just literally point it at
it um
so that was very helpful
uh and this is what it looks like in the
interface you know as i said you can
drag in uh images you can actually it's
it's all actually got a little labeling
interface in there so you know if you
drag in 50 of your own images you can
actually just label them yourself in the
ui you don't have to use ground truth
as i did
so that was really nice i could go in
and tweak the labels on some of my data
sets as well
and then when you click train you see
you get the this is an evaluation of one
of the the projects that i did you can
see it's got some scores it tells you i
had two labels stuck in it or not stuck
in it 900 images
and you can see here uh some of the
results and i'll um i'll show you how to
actually uh how to demo this um we
actually have on the aws github page uh
some code this is amazon recognition
custom labels demo um if you scroll down
on this there's actually a cloud
formation stack you can just click a
button and it will deploy this
application in your aws account
it's very fast um so i didn't have to
you know
get my little react app and doing the
doing the the intermediary lambda
function all that didn't have to do any
of it literally was one button click and
it created this app for me this is what
it looks like um it creates this nice
little ui it will automatically pick up
all of the different projects that you
have and your recognition custom labels
um in your account depending on the
region and you can start and stop models
for inference just by clicking uh on the
buttons there
pro tip it does when you click start a
model it does take uh several minutes
for the model to actually be ready for
you to start testing um but this is
actually what it looks like so this is
the little interface and so
first thing i did i tested it out with
just 10 images to see how that worked i
didn't get great results that's when i
moved to using my whole full um full
training data set that i did with
sagemaker but this is using that same
data set i dragged in here a picture of
stuck in it and and it gives me
stockinette stitch
all right how about garter stitch not
stockinette this is looking good how
about our friend the cat
not stuck in that stitch
so i actually found that using
recognition custom labels um taking that
exact same data set creating a model
with this i got comparable performance
you know it still misidentified that one
girl's sweater stitch
but it was basically comparable
performance and it took me like
20 minutes and five clicks to actually
do this it was so fast um the metro it
uses slightly different metrics uh to to
to derive the performance it's like the
ratio of true positives to false
positive rolls those up into an f1 score
not an expert basically it's not a like
for like comparison to the numbers you
get out of stage maker but you get the
idea here we're looking at like 97 98
amazing way simpler way way way simpler
but wait there's more i was so blown
away by this and that that i got
comparable results with like so little
so little effort
i thought hey why don't i spend a little
more time try and actually expand my
scope back up go back to trying to
actually identify more than just stuck
in it or not trying to identify
different stitches
um so i spent a couple hours in that
little interface creating another data
set and going in and actually
re-labeling different stitches for
garter seed moss and other
i left out reverse stockinette stitch
because again even i can't tell that one
apart
but after training that on the different
stitches so this is uh you can actually
just select a different model in the app
to test out so this is using that so you
can see here it knows that this is
stockinette stitch it's got that uh
correct
how about this is moss stitch it
actually distinguishes between moss and
seed stitch
this is a rib
so it's actually identified this is
other um so you can see it's got the v's
that that are in stocking stitch but it
it mixes up the knits and the pearls um
so this is not stuck in that stitch and
i'm actually really impressed that it
got this one correct um so i've actually
been able to go back and expand my scope
out and this is looking really promising
i'm still working on this
just to sort of give you an overview of
how these two different methods compare
so remember we had recognition custom
labels which is that pre-trained up at
the top
i gave it my my my training data and it
just does everything for you
um versus sage maker which is in that
middle level where you have to you know
it does a lot of the heavy lifting you
don't have to roll your own completely
um but you do still need a sort of a lot
of custom knowledge um this just shows
you a little bit of the comparison here
uh training time um was one again with
sagemaker you can choose what sort of
instance your training job runs on as i
said i read i mean i work for aws i
threw like some rather large machines at
it so it took 33 minutes my hyper
parameter optimization training job i
actually let that run for 13 hours you
know i think you can you can run it for
you know as long as you want
recognition custom labels when you click
the train button it just goes off and
does it you have no control over it um
and so the one i did uh
the comparable the same
data set here took 50 minutes
um
in terms of cost that's one of the big
big differences between these two
methods uh sagemaker you pay
um so the ground truth labeling job was
the same i caught like
you know it was the same for each there
is a free tier for ground truth um you
get i don't think i have it on here oh
yeah you do um you get your first 500
labels in the first two months you use
it for free
um but it starts uh at eight cents per
labeled image for less than 50 000
images that's not counting if you use
mechanical turk obviously if you paying
someone to label for you that'll be more
but so basically my training job for 900
images cost me about 80 bucks
um
then the actual training of the model
itself um
uh you pay for provision storage you pay
for data transfer you pay for the time
running the instance um there is a free
tier for stage maker you get 50 hours on
an m4 extra larger m5 extra large you
get 125
uh that the sorry no that's for
inference for for the free tier for
training you get 50 hours on one of
those instances um but i added it up
here and you can see it's about 50 bucks
for training that i spent i didn't run
this on spot you can run these jobs on
spot instances that can save you huge
amounts that can save you like 90
um i didn't do that on this particular
one to give you the sort of maximum
there
and then for inference um that's where
you pay for storage you pay for data
transfer that's where you're actually
hosting hosting the endpoint and and
running uh predictions against it um and
so it's about a dollar 12 an hour for
running my inference instance
plus storage and data transfer there
it's a lot simpler on the pricing side
over on recognition custom labels you
basically got um a flat fee of a dollar
an hour for training
uh as i said you don't really have
control over how long that training job
can can run one of my training jobs
actually ran for four hours um and it
will actually decide it can it might not
match clock time because recognition
does this cool thing where it will
decide how many instances to use
and so it may run multiple resources in
parallel uh to train your model more
quickly and so um you know it might take
one hour on the clock it might actually
that might equate to two or three hours
of instance time behind it
but we do see that like 90 of the models
need less than 24 hours to train um if
it goes on longer than that if it hits
72 they will actually it will
automatically shut down and you won't
get charged for that
inference is where you pay a lot more on
this when you pay four dollars an hour
flat fee for while you have those uh
those models running so this is not
something where you want to turn it on
and leave it running 24 7 to run your
your predictions against you want to
turn it on run a bunch and turn it off
again that's where recognition custom
labels really shines if you're building
something where you want it to be on all
the time then maybe you want to use
sagemaker
but ultimately that last line like the
last two boxes here i get comparable
results
and recognition custom labels was so
much easier to use
that for a non-expert i i can't help but
recommend it it's so simple
um
and you don't have to take my word for
it uh this was a blog post last november
from one of the aws heroes luca bianchi
he's um he's in milan and so luca did
the same thing i did luca had built out
a model with sagemaker and then he
compared it his use case was like
snapshots of heating and ventilation
systems to check cleanliness and air
quality and so he had a data set of like
2300 images he got him labeled he's a
bit of an expert he used pytorch he used
the fastai library um he deployed a
model on stagemaker and he got accuracy
of like 92 percent so then he took that
same training data set did exactly what
i did set it into recognition custom
labels and found that it gave comparable
accuracy without needing the help of a
data scientist um you know i think he he
calls it like pretty he's pretty shocked
in this blog post as well
and this incidentally this is kind of
the perfect use case uh for something
like recognition custom labels because
you know you can actually just spin up
the model for inference batch up all
your images and run them through and
then shut it down which will help
optimize on the costs
so i'm coming up to the end here
i just want to give some thank yous
53 knitters around the world sent images
to me for my training data set maybe
some of them are watching right now um
14 humans collectively spent nearly 15
hours labeling and clicking more than 3
000 buttons to label all these images
and i also benefited from advice and
guidance from some of my colleagues gabe
hollambee and aparna langevan
so this is what we covered today i
talked to you a little bit about the
state of aiml some of the cool stuff
that's happening really look up um alpha
fold and deepmind as i said you can
check out their source code and look at
some of the predictions for uh human
protein structures that they're actually
now making public talk to you about art
and cats and getting pizza to people
faster which is really all that's
getting me through this this time that
we live in right now
i pointed you to the aws ramp up guide
for machine learning just as one way of
getting started and remember if you
google aws innovate that was our recent
aiml conference you can actually see
some of the videos online if you want
more examples from people who are
experts in this stuff
i gave you a little overview of of the
stack at aws as i said and and i know
other providers have have similar tools
where you've got pre-trained models that
you can just use out of the box uh just
by calling apis we have sagemaker that
in the across the middle where if you
are if you know a bit um you can really
have a lot of control over how you train
and deploy your models and of course
we've got those foundational services
around the bottom for machine learning
experts and data scientists who want
control over every aspect of their
machine learning workflow
and then i walked you through my knit ml
project to try and teach the computer to
recognize different knitting stitches
and i'm actually really pleased with how
this is going so
after d scoping it down to just stuck in
it or not i've gone back up to being
able to identify multiple stitches um so
now i'm going to continue on with this
and my new project is to see if i can
actually use a photo to count the number
of rows because i'm lazy and when i'm
knitting i just want to take a picture
and have it tell me how many rows i've
knitted so that's that's the next
iteration of this project
all right i think i don't know how much
q a time we have but if you would like
to ask me uh questions for q a we do
have a slido here um and you can jump
over to there but lars you're back hello
hey
yes i'm back um yeah so finish my coffee
it's getting cold here yeah i finished
mine it's it's right there in front of
me
you um yeah i think you just mesmerized
people i i find it fascinating the ml
world i think so i used it recently i
think i used it anyway google has a
feature on the android phone called
google lens i think yes i've used that
for translation here in germany i've
used that for trees because we have a
bunch of trees and i live in a farm
and one of them had died and i was
wondering why dinah tried to to
recognize it and i recognized that one
on the leaves which i thought was kind
of cool and i also i now know i have an
algerian oak tree there you go but you
can also use the back so it was all
different
things that he would recognize it on so
i thought that was kind of useful like
you said hey laziness solves many things
or encourage you to solve many things
right so
there are so many examples of like you
know when you see a lot of these talks
it's like now we will predict the cost
of housing and it's like oh that's not
interesting to me identifying a tree
that's cool oh you know
oh yeah oh sorry um recently sorry i'm a
co total lego nerd right that was i saw
your video your video i did i did of
course everybody was talking about that
it was amazing but there's an app called
brickett
and you you you just take a photo of
your pile of lego blocks right which are
on the floor and and it figures out what
you can build from them it's amazing and
it doesn't have to be the right colors
or anything it's it's quite and it's
like a beta it's really early thing yeah
i did have to use an apple device to run
it but you know we'll gloss over that um
so yeah i just i was amazing it was just
so good the whole oh there's a question
about what we where can we get knit ml
oh
um that's a good point i can put my
training i actually have not made any
data set available but i will i
absolutely you're right i crowdsourced
this i should make it a bit i don't know
why that nobody's asked me that before i
will put it up on my github if people
want to play with it i will absolutely
do that um okay i mean there's no real
code for it you know i did it in the in
the console
but i can also uh give you i'll tweet
out the url to that recognition custom
labels app yeah do that
yeah that'd be good
um yeah we uh
there's so many applications on there i
was i've set up a camera that just films
my llamas right and it's just streaming
online but i wanted to use
machine learning to tell people when
there is a llama because most of the
time though isn't the one because it's a
big paddock
and so you're tweeting about llamas i
know
and i haven't quite finished it yet but
basically i have a model that will tell
you whether it's a llama or not um so if
there's you know something in the
picture it'll tell you if it's a llama
or not it even recognized it wasn't the
llama when it was an alpaca i thought
that was impressive and again i didn't
do any coding that's just machine
learning right so
well i am working on another project um
sneak preview for re invent i'm working
with a couple people on um on a beer
recommendation engine because you know
in the old world we wouldn't go places
yes so see you'd travel places you'd be
in another city and you'd be like i
wonder what local beers i would like you
know i've got hundreds of beers and
untapped why can't i actually get myself
a prediction so a few of us are i'm
working on this we'll see how we go well
germany is the perfect sample market
exactly yeah absolutely yeah oh wow
so much goodness yeah well that's
awesome
all the important things in life
and alpacas um thanks so much chris that
was it was really good
i genuinely enjoyed that that was and
you know i'm not a knitter but yeah it's
just the application of a real world
thing onto something that's a bit more
abstract just really makes it come to
life i think so um that's that's all we
have um i think from from chris howard
unless you want to add something at the
end where can we see you next chris
oh gosh um
i mean the good thing is because the
timezone i'm still getting to do the
occasional aussie aussie thing um
probably re invent will be the next big
one i i'm guessing yeah that sounds good
look forward to that
femtech conf is coming up i'm speaking
at that one it's a conference online for
for women women in tech um it's really
it's a global one i'll share i'll tweet
that out please people come to that one
it's going to be pretty i can't go then
um
no there's a lot of watch come on okay
then
uh no thank you so much chris and um
thanks for joining ndc melbourne uh miss
you all i can't wait to see you again i
can't wait to visit
alrighty
so next up we are going to have a bunch
of prizes
but first just a quick word from my
sponsors
i love running this company i love
running it because uh of the people i
deal with
there's such a great team of people from
a career perspective it's the best move
i ever did being a great consultant
which we are this is w is half half
between technical skills and
communication
[Music]
it's given me the opportunity to work
with lots of different types of
technology and explore some stuff that i
maybe only dabbled in at university or
before
ssw is a company that makes enterprise
software solutions
and that's what we do we build software
for clients on demand we build bespoke
solutions using the latest technology
and the latest best practices i've been
involved in the development of some
mining software being involved in the
development of software for a legal firm
and everything in between there even in
just under two years i've been working
across so many different projects
it's just a really great place to come
into and i always look forward to coming
to work
[Applause]
[Music]
as an investor or wealth professional
you want a wealth provider that is
flexible smart and tech savvy
a provider with fresh eyes who sees
opportunity to present wealth solutions
differently
a partner who can administer wealth your
way
netwealth was created with an
entrepreneurial spirit to do all of this
we exist to help you see your wealth
differently to realize your potential to
inspire you to discover a brighter
future
at our core we are a technology company
a super fund an investment specialist an
administration business
but in our daily lives we are you
moms and dads call centre operators
sales and marketing professionals
analysts netball teams friends
technologists developers and most
importantly family
to investors we provide award-winning
superannuation and investment accounts
products and services
to wealth professionals we provide a
market-leading platform to better their
business
underlying all of this is cutting-edge
technology anywhere everywhere
with us you can see your wealth
differently and more positively we
identify new opportunities with our
fresh perspective and natural curiosity
we provide choice through our flexible
approach to business and product design
we prioritize your security to give you
peace of mind
we are involved in your world in schools
we support financial literacy helping
our younger australians also see wealth
differently
we are a team of talented people working
hard to make life better for more
australians
we are creators
we are curious always looking to spot
the change that matters
we are authentic and genuine
we believe that strength is in teamwork
we are agile and nimble upbeat energetic
and optimistic about the future
with us
you can see wealth differently because
we are different in our approach our
attitude our commitment and our spirit
partner with us to see what's possible
[Music]
all righty we have a bunch of uh prizes
to go through here so they're all are
listed on the expo.html.com if you click
on the
ndc prizes
and i'm just going to read them out so
we know what we're playing for here uh
there's 20 digital keep carbs 6 xiaomi
mi bands and an apple smart watch from
ssw we're just going to draw
a band and the smart watch the rest of
them will do after the fact because
otherwise it gets a bit long but we will
notify all the winners uh comeback has a
250 dollar uber eats voucher and apple
airpods telstra purple has a 200 amazon
gift card
uh net wealth has 250 amazon gift cards
as an ex has two hundred dollar gift pay
vouchers webkit has a 150 and a 200
amazon gift card and ndc is giving away
a free pass all access pass for next
year's ndc melbourne as well
so um
with that if we can uh bring up the
wheel of many names that would be
awesome
there we go
tap to spin so uh i'm just going to go
for it so the first one we have up is a
xiaomi mi band
and
we will note all the names as well said
uh killich
has won the band oh
it even does all the uh
um clapping everything i know if you can
hear that all right so then we have a
apple smart watch from ssw
and the winner is ian thompson
congratulations ian
and i'm not watching the youtube stream
so i'll let my colleagues shout at me if
i'm missing something here
comeback has a 250 uber eats voucher and
that is won by dom miller
congratulations dom
and also from cba or from commonwealth
bank we have a
uh some apple airpods and they are going
to
michael madre congratulations michael
fantastic
and we keep going telstra purple has a
200 amazon gift voucher
so we spin the wheel and that's
sebastian
i'm sorry i just butchered your name
sebastian um
congratulations with that then we have
net wealth has 250 amazon gift vouchers
so the first one goes to
ram ramanathan there you go
congratulations ram and the second
hundred and fifty dollar gift voucher
from ned wealth is goes to matthew wicks
congratulations matt
fantastic
all righty and then as an x has 200
little gift pay vouchers now gift pay is
uh it's kind of like a
a gift card that works in a million
different places and stores so you can
kind of choose where you want to use it
um the first one is one by davinci singh
congratulations to venture
and the second hundred dollar gift pay
voucher from as an eggs
goes to
reuben bond who also won a hoodie
earlier fantastic room well done
and we'll remove reuben from the listing
here now we have the 150 dollar
amazon gift card voucher from webjet
and that goes to
see han chihan so i'm not sure how to
pronounce that so budak
well well done
and then we have a 200 amazon gift
voucher which goes to
manage
i'm not even going to try the last name
i'm sorry
but congratulations minaj from the 200
gift voucher for amazon from webjet
and then the big prize the all access
pass for next year's ndc melbourne which
is
i don't know how much that's worth a lot
um yeah can probably inform you of that
but yeah it's so for next year 2022 ndc
melbourne all access pass which means
you can go to workshops and the and the
conference itself in person fingers
crossed
we really want to do that
and the winner goes to
stephen carter
well done steven
fantastic very good so those are all the
gift prices
um
for now we can
go away from the uh from the screen
share if you want
and
um all i have to say is congratulations
to all the winners thank you so much
everybody for joining and being part of
ndc melbourne here as a live stream on
youtube it's been a fantastic joy just
to
you know have everybody join tonight
tonight today and um just if you can
bring in my co-hosts as well if they're
still here
here we go we got william and we got
melissa as well thank you so much
everybody it might be an echo here in
the audio but um thank you
it's been fantastic and um
with a whole bunch of echoing
see everybody and thank you and uh hope
you have a great day and see you next
time
you